KAMALA WILL COME TO ORDER GOOD
AFTERNOON AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE
SOME PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE THE
ONGOING COVER NINETEEN RISKS THE
SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE
PUBLIC IS INVITED ACCESS TO BOTH
IN PERSON HANDS TELECONFERENCE
BUT DISSIPATION FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND IT WILL
ALSO BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN
AS I ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
844-291-6364 AGAIN. 844-291-6364
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE FOUR
ONE ONE ONE FOUR ZERO AGAIN. ONE
FOUR ONE ONE ONE FOUR ZERO. I
WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING AS IS CUSTOMARY AN
INDIVIDUAL WHOSE DESTRUCTIVE MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE OR AFTER
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHERE HELD
HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE HEARINGS
HERE IN THE- STREET BUILDING AND
I ASK ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TO BE PRESENT IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED- SO WE CAN
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND-
BEGINNER- HEARING. WE CURRENTLY
HAVE. THE WORST ORIGINALLY
SEVENTEEN BILLS ON THE AGENDA
HOWEVER WE ARE NOT HEARING- FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE FOURTEEN SIXTY
FOUR BY MYSELF PAN AND I'LL FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN- SB TWELVE
NINETY BY SARA ALLEN. WE ALSO
HAVE THREE ITEMS ON OUR PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR THAT'S ITEM
NUMBER TWO SB EIGHT FORTY TO
PLAY CENTER DODD. AYE NUMBER
TWELVE SB 1298% OR A CHILLED
BOTTLE AND ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN
SB FOURTEEN SIXTY TWO BY CENTER
BRADFORD- GIVEN THE FACT THAT WE
ARE NOT QUITE AT A QUORUM HERE
YET- I ACTUALLY- AND THE FIRST
ORIGINALLY THE FIRST ITEM WAS
GOING TO BE SB FOURTEEN SIXTY
FOUR- I WILL ALSO TAKE THIS
PRIVILEGE- I TAKE THIS MOMENT TO
ACTION TAKEN OFF THEIR
STATEMENTS ABOUT THIS THE
FOURTEENTH WHICH IS NOT GOING TO
BE HEARD. IT TODAY'S HEARING AND
WE'RE NOT TAKING TESTIMONY BUT
I'LL BE MAKING OFF THEIR
STATEMENT. SB FOURTEEN SIXTY
FOUR IS ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT
AND PUBLIC HEALTH LEADERS
WORKING TOGETHER ON PUBLIC
SAFETY. TO SAVE LIVES FROM
HEALTH THREATS. BOTH PLAY A
VITAL ROLE IN KEY IN KEEPING OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE. ALMOST A MILLION
AMERICANS LOST THEIR LIVES IN
FREEDOM BECAUSE A COVETED
INTENDS THE MILLIONS MORE HAVE
LOST HER FREEDOM DUE TO POST
CODE INJURY. THE PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKERS ON THE FRONT LINES
DEFENDING THE FREEDOM OF A
COMMUNITIES FROM DISEASE NEED
OUR HELP TO PUSH BACK AGAINST
EXTREMISTS WHO SEEK TO TAKE
THESE FREEDOMS AWAY FROM US. SB
FOURTEEN SIXTY FOUR. IS
SUPPORTED BY OUR STATE LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS ASSOCIATION AND
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT. TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR ASK FOR OUR
HELP IS LEGISLATORS. PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICERS HAVE A
CHALLENGING JOB EVEN PRE
PANDEMIC. THERE PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICIALS WHOSE WORK PROTECTS
MORE LIVES THAN ALMOST ANY OTHER
PROFESSION ALTHOUGH TWO OFTEN
THAT WORK IS TAKEN FOR GRANTED.
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS ARE
APPOINTED BY COUNTY OR CITY
EXECUTIVES BUT THE
RESPONSIBILITIES TO THE FACTS
AND THE HEALTH OF THE PEOPLE.
THEIR DUTY IS TO BE ABOVE
POLITICS AND TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS BASED ON SCIENCE
IN THE SERVICE OF THE HEALTH OF
THE PUBLIC. EVEN AT THE RISK TO
THEIR OWN JOBS AND CAREERS.
UNFORTUNATELY HUNDREDS OF PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICERS NATIONALLY HAVE
LEFT HER JOB DURING THE
PANDEMIC. MANY COURAGEOUSLY
RESIGNING OR BEING FORCED OUT
FOR TRULY SPEAKING TRUTH TO
POWER. IN DDITION EXTREMISTS
HAVE ATTACKED PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICIALS DOING THEIR DUTY.
LARGE COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICER DR NICOLE QUICK RESIGNED
AFTER FALLS VITRIOLIC PERSONAL
ATTACKS AGAINST HER INCLUDING
DISCLOSING HER HOME ADDRESS
WHICH WOULD THEN FOLLOWED BY
ATTACKS AGAINST HER AND HER
FAMILY AT HER HOME. SAN DIEGO
FELT OFF PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER
DR WILMA WOOTEN ALSO HAD HER
HOME ADDRESS DISCLOSED. AND
PROTESTERS HAVE HARASSED
FAMILIES A PUBLIC HEALTH
OFFICERS AFTER HOMES. NUMEROUS
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS
PARTICULARLY WOMEN HAVE RECEIVED
DEATH THREATS REQUIRED SECURITY
. ALL WELL EACH OF THEM HAVE
BEEN WORKING TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
WITH THEIR STAFFS TO PREVENT THE
SPREAD OF KOBE INTERLOCKED ALITY
. WE SHOULD RECOGNIZE THAT LIFE
EXPECTANCY UNITED STATES IS
WRITTEN RISEN OVER 60% SINCE
NINETEEN HUNDRED. MOST OF THAT%
INCREASE WAS DUE TO IMPROVEMENTS
IN PUBLIC HEALTH IMPACTS NATION
. HOWEVER IN THE LAST TWO YEARS
DURING THIS PANDEMIC. THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS WERE BEING
ATTACKED BY EXTREMIST. US LIFE
EXPECTANCY FELL BY OVER TWO
YEARS. IN CONTRAST BUT EXPECT TO
SEE IN OTHER HIGH INCOME
COUNTRIES LIKE OURS FELL BY ONLY
POINT SIX PER YEARS IN THE FIRST
YEAR TO PANDEMIC IN FACT
INCREASED LAST YEAR. NOT
SURPRISINGLY UNFORTUNATELY IN
THIS COUNTRY IN TWENTY TWENTY
LIFE EXPECTANCY
DISPROPORTIONATELY FELL FOR
BLACKS AND LATINOS. BUT IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE WHITE PEOPLE
HAD THE LARGEST LOSS OF LIFE
EXPECTANCY IN THE UNITED STATES
. THE POLITICIZATION OF PUBLIC
HEALTH HAS HAD SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES. LAW ENFORCEMENT IS
ALSO NOT IMMUNE FROM COVET.
TWENTY TWENTY WITH THE DEADLIEST
YEAR FOR ACTIVE DUTY LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS IN NEARLY A
CENTURY AND COATED WITH LEASING
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH BECAUSE
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT DEATHS BOTH
IN TWENTY TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THE ALMOST THREE
TIMES AS MANY LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS KILLED BY COBIT AND
FIREARMS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
DESPITE THE TREMENDOUS LOSS OF
LIFE AN INJURY AS WELL AS
ECONOMIC DAMAGE FROM COVE IT
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS HAVE NOT
RECEIVE THE SUPPORT THEY NEED TO
PROTECT US. IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY
HERE IN MY DISTRICT SACRAMENTO
COUNTY SHERIFF DECLARED HIS
DEPARTMENT REFUSED TO ENFORCE
MASKING CURFEW ORDERS AT THE
START THE PANDEMIC. IN A REPORT%
RELEASED THIS MONTH SACRAMENTO
COUNTY GRAND JURY FOUND THAT THE
COUNTY OFFICE. OF PUBLIC HEALTH
EFFORTS TO SLOW THE SPREAD OF
COVER NINETEEN WERE
SIGNIFICANTLY HAMPERED. BY LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT REFUSAL OF THE
TUNE FOR PUBLIC HEALTH WORKERS
DESPITE PLEASE FROM COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH THE PLEASE THE
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICER.
THE GRAND JURY ALSO NOTED THAT
THE COUNTY QUOTE ABANDONED A
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR CODE
SPENDING ON QUOTE AND QUOTE
UNDERMINE PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN
GOVERNMENT. ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY
ONE MILLION AND CODEPEN DEMO FOR
SPOTS FUNDS WERE ALLOCATED TO
THE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT WHILE
THE STRUGGLING OFFICE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH RECEIVE MINIMAL FUNDING.
UNFORTUNATELY AS MANY OF YOU
KNOW ALL TOO WELL SACRAMENTO
COUNTY WAS NOT THE ONLY COUNTY
WHERE THIS PROBLEM OCCURRED.
ALTHOUGH SB FOURTEEN SIXTY FOUR
IS NOT BEING HEARD TODAY I MUST
ACKNOWLEDGE AND RECOGNIZE THE
COURAGE AND SACRIFICE OF OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS ND
WORKERS OUR HEROES. TIMEA MY
LEGISLATIVE COLLEAGUES WILL NOT
GIVE UP AND HELPING YOU PROTECT
THE HEALTH OF OUR COMMUNITIES
AND STATE. I ASKED CALIFORNIANS
RESPECT AND HONOR FRONTLINE
PUBLIC HEALTH LEADERS AND
WORKERS THANK YOU. WITH THAT
WE'LL NOW MOVE ON TO. OUR AGENDA
AND I BELIEVE- SIR WIENER HERE
HERE. AND SO- WHAT LOOKS A MOVE
ON TO ITEM NUMBER THREE SB EIGHT
FIFTY THREE. HERE TO PRESENT TWO
THREE FOUR I WAS A WILL CONTINUE
THE SUB COMMITTEE STUDENT OUT OF
COURT YET. IF YOU ARE GO AHEAD
PERCENT ITEM NUMBER THREE. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IN IF I
MAY- DEVIOUS AS WANT TO THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR LEADER- INTO.
TO TAKE A SCIENCE SPACE APPROACH
APPROACH- AND PROTECTING THE
HEALTH OF ALL CALIFORNIANS EVEN
IN THE FACE OF SIGNIFICANCE-
MISINFORMATION AND AT TIMES
SOCIOPATHIC BEHAVIOR SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN- SO
COLLEAGUES- ON THE START BUTTON
RIGHT BECAUSE ANY SENATE BILL
EIGHT FIFTY THREE- THE
MEDICATION ACCESS- ACT WHICH
WILL HELP ENSURE THAT PATIENTS
ARE NOT HUNG OUT TO DRY- WHEN
PRESCRIPTION MEDICATION COVERAGE
IS DENIED- THE BILL ONE SURE
THAT WALL. AND APPEAL IS BEING
REVIEWED FOR THE NILE OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS PATIENTS CAN
ACCESS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
MEDICINE AND AVOID A LAPSE IN
TREATMENT I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF- FOR ITS WORK IN
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS- TO
CLARIFY THAT AND ROWLEY'S WILL
STILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR ANY
COST SHARING- AND- FIND. IN
REVIEW DECISION ONE THE MATTER
INDEPENDENT MEDICAL REVIEW AND
I'M ALSO COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
TO WORK WITH THE PARENTS TO
ADDRESS- THERE- THE ISSUE.
RAISED COLLEAGUES AS YOU KNOW
MANY CALIFORNIANS EXPERIENCE WHO
ARE EXPERIENCING CHRONIC ILLNESS
RELY ON PRESCRIPTION MEDICATIONS
LIVE TIONAL FIVE EVEN SERVICE.
SOME CHRONIC ILLNESSES- LIKE
INFLAMMATORY BOWEL DISEASE I
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF
TREATMENTS. AVAILABLE SENATOR
EIGHT FIFTY- DOES TO. FIRST THE
BILL REQUIRE- INSURANCE
COMPANIES TO COVER A DRUG- DOES
HER DOSAGE FORM THAT'S BEEN
PREVIOUSLY PRESCRIBED TO A
PATIENT THROUGH THE DURATION OF
AN APPEALS PROCESS- AND THEN
PROHIBITS PLANS FROM SEEKING
REIMBURSEMENT IF THE DENIAL- IS
UP HELD- THE PERSON IS ALREADY
TAKING MEDICATION- AND I HEALTH
PLAN TRIES TO- SWITCH THE PERSON
OR THAN EYES. A CHANGE IN DOSAGE
OR DOSAGE FORM FOR THE SAME
MEDICATION- IF THE PERSON
APPEALS- THEY HAVE TO GROUP PLAN
WILL HAVE TO COVER DURING THE
NEW TOWCESTER DOSAGE FORM DURING
THE PENDENCY OF THE APPEAL. TO
SOMEONE'S NOT GOING ON AND OFF
AND ON AND OFF- AND THEN IF THE
APPEALS SUSTAIN THE CHEMICAL
BACK AND RECOUP SO IT'S ASKING
THE PLANS TO SIMPLY KEEP
COVERING IT WHAT. WAS BEING
WORKED OUT SECONDLY THE BILL
STRENGTHENS CALIFORNIA'S
PROHIBITION ON NON MEDICAL
SWITCHING- WHICH IS WHAT A
HEALTH PLAN FORCES A PATIENT TO
SWITCH FROM A PRESCRIBED DRUGS
TO DIFFERENT DRUGS FOR NON
MEDICAL REASONS- AND THE-
CALIFORNIA ALREADY HAS
PROTECTIONS AGAINST NON MEDICAL
SUITE- SB FIFTY THREE B. WILL-
CLARIFY AND EXPAND. THE SCOPE OF
THE NON MEDICAL SWITCHING
PROHIBITION TO INCLUDE THE
PRESCRIBED DOSE SEARCH FORM- SO
A- HEALTH PLAN COULD NOT FORCE
YOU TO USE A DIFFERENT DOSE OR A
FORM OF DOSING- THAT YOUR DOCTOR
HAS NOT RECOMMENDED- SO IT IT'S
REALLY UNFORTUNATE. AIDS
PATIENTS IN YOU TO HAVE THIS-
HAVE TO GO THROUGH THIS-
PARTICULARLY PEOPLE WHO ARE
STRUGGLING WITH SERIOUS CRIME
FICTION. SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO
THEM AT. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT. SO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR EYEBROW- AND TESTED
TODAY- FOR ANNIKA BLANCATO. AND
DOCTORS SAID THE BOSS- AND- FOR
TECHNICAL. OUR CASHIER RYAN
SPENCER WITH THE CRIME AND
FOUNDATION OF BE ABOUT THANK YOU
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH BEFORE
TAKE A THE WITH AND SOME OF THE
LAW- WE HAVE THE MEMBERS. TO TRY
TO SALVAGE QUORUM SO CONTROL
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL HAND GEAR.
MELENDEZ EGGMAN GONZALEZ GROVE
HERE. HER TADO LEYVA LIMÓN ROTH
. MMHM MONTHS. THIRTY ROTH RUBIO
WIENER PRESENT HERE. THE CARD IS
ESTABLISHED THANK YOU- AND
DEADLY BOTH OF YOUR- WITNESSES
ARE TESTIFYING VIA
TELECONFERENCE CENTER OKAY
STRICTO MODERATOR PLEASE PLEASE
BRING ON THE LINE- THE TWO
WITNESSES VERONICA BLANCATO AND-
DOCTORS CYDIA BOSSY- TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. EIGHT FIFTY
THREE YOU EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES
A TOTAL FOUR MINUTES BETWEEN THE
TWO OF YOU. SO WHAT. YOUR
AVAILABLE YOUR LINES ARE OPEN
YES SOME OF THE RACK OF BLANCATO
CAN YOU PLEASE- YOU YOU MAY
BEGIN. AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
HELP COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
VERONICA BLANCATO AND I HAVE
LIVED WITH CROHN'S DISEASE FOR
THE LAST SEVENTEEN YEARS MORE
THAN HALF OF MY ENTIRE LIFE. IN
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN I A
COLLAPSED AT WORK AND WAS RUSHED
TO THE HOSPITAL WITH AN ABSCESS
THE SIZE OF A GRAPEFRUIT IN MY
ACCIDENT. ONE OF THE MANY COMMON
COMPLICATIONS OF CROHN'S DISEASE
. MY DOCTOR RECOMMENDED I SWITCH
MEDICATIONS FROM REMICADE HUMIRA
BOTH DRUGS WHICH FALL UNDER THE
SCOPE OF THIS BILL BEING
PRESENTED TODAY. I TAKING HUMIRA
FOR ALMOST SEVEN YEARS NOW IT
HAS SINGLE HANDEDLY SAVED MY
LIFE. BUT IT TOOK ALMOST EIGHT
MONTHS TO GET THAT PRESCRIPTION
APPROVED BECAUSE THE DOES
PRESCRIBE TO ME WITH CONSIDERED
OFF LABEL AND THE ASSOCIATED
APPEAL PROCESS WAS A GARGANTUAN
FEAT. IN THAT EIGHT MONTH TIME
PERIOD THAT I SPENT MOSTLY UN
MEDICAID IT MIGHT INSTANCE
RETURNED WITH A VENGEANCE AND I
WAS FORCED TO UNDERGO SURGERY
THE SECOND ONE I WOULD HAVE THUS
FAR. I'LL NEVER KNOW IF HAVING
ACCESS TO HEAR SOONER COULD HAVE
SPARED ME AT SECOND SURGERY.
LIKE I MENTIONED HUMIRA SAVED MY
LIFE AND IT TOOK MANY VARIATIONS
OF COAXES AND FREQUENCIES FOR
THAT TO HAPPEN. ALL OF THEM
CONSIDERED OFF LABEL AND NEARLY
ALL OF THEM REQUIRING A LENGTHY
PRIOR AUTHORIZATION APPROVAL AN
APPEAL PROCESS. WHICH GAVE MY
DISEASE THE OPPORTUNITY TO HOLD
ME HOSTAGE ONCE AGAIN. THIS BILL
CAN PREVENT MY EXPERIENCE FROM
BEING THE STATUS QUO AND CAN
ALLOW THESE LIFE CHANGING
MEDICINES TO DO WHAT THEY ARE
INTENDED TO DO YOU SHOULD SAVE
LIVES LIKE MINE. I HOPE YOU WILL
CONSIDER SUPPORTING THIS BILL
AND SINCERELY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO DR SABIHA
ABBAS HE- RICHARD CARING MEMBERS
OF THE HEALTH SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. I MAKE AFTER
INTRALOGISTICS SPECIALIZE IN
INFLAMMATORY BOWEL DISEASE WHICH
IS AN AUTOIMMUNE CONDITION THAT
LEADS TO INFLAMMATION OF THE
GASTROINTESTINAL TRACT. THIS
DISEASE IS A CHRONIC LIFELONG
ILLNESS THAT CAN LEAD TO
SYMPTOMS INCLUDING SEVERE
ABDOMINAL PAIN NOW NUTRITION
WEIGHT LOSS AND CAN ALSO
PROGRESS TO CANCER OF THE
INTESTINES. PRODUCTS BECAUSE ONE
NAY SAMPLE OF THIS UNRELENTING
NATURE OF THIS DISEASE. WE
MANAGE THESE SYMPTOMS AND THIS
DISEASE BY USING MEDICATIONS
THAT MODULATE THE IMMUNE SYSTEM
AND IN RECENT YEARS HAVE LEARNED
THE CONSEQUENCES WHEN PATIENTS
DO NOT RECEIVE THEIR MEDICATIONS
ON TIME AND AT THE RIGHT DOSE. I
HAVE WITNESSED MY PATIENTS
DEVELOPED DISEASE PROGRESSION
AND A PLAYER IN THEIR SYMPTOMS
WHEN THEIR MEDICATION IS DELAYED
DURING INSURANCE PRE
AUTHORIZATION OR APPEAL PROCESS.
YUBA PATIENTS HAVE HAD TO BRIDGE
THE TIME GAP WITH OTHER IMMUNO
SUPPRESSIVE MEDICATIONS THAT ARE
USED ON A TEMPORARY BASIS SUCH
AS CORTICOSTEROIDS. WE HAVE
THEIR OWN SIDE EFFECTS THE
CONSEQUENCES INCLUDING RASHES
AND INCREASED RISK OF INFECTION.
OTHER PATIENTS DEVELOPED AND- TO
THEIR ORIGINAL MEDICATION WHICH
- AND INEFFECTIVE AND RESULTS IN
US HAVING TO SWITCH THEM TO A
NEW MEDICATION WHICH MAY NOT
CONTROL THE DISEASE PROCESS AND
ONLY FURTHER PROLONG THEIR
ACTIVE SYMPTOMS. NINE FREQUENTLY
SOME PATIENTS HAVE HAD TO GO TO
THE EMERGENCY DEPARTMENT OR BE
HOSPITALIZED NOT ONLY TO RECEIVE
IV MEDICATIONS TO CONTROL THE
CROWD CONTROL THEIR DISEASE AND
MAY ALSO RESULT IN SURGERY. AT
FRONT. THIS TESTIFIED. IF BONDS
WITH ALL THESE- PAGES ONE
DISEASE CONDITION WHERE PATIENTS
WOULD BENEFIT FROM THIS BILL.
BUT THE ON TIME DOSING OF
MEDICATIONS IS CRITICAL ACROSS
MULTIPLE MEDICAL SPECIALTIES TO
IMPROVE PATIENT OUTCOMES
INCLUDING RHEUMATOLOGY ONCOLOGY
AND HEMATOLOGY. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING THE FERRY THIS BILL
WHICH HAS A VERY IMPORTANT
PATIENT PROTECTIONS YOU CAN HAVE
A POSITIVE IMPACT ON OVERALL
DISEASE COURSE. AND I THINK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND AGAIN I'VE I DO WANNA
THANK- ROCKABILLY CONTO FOR.
PRESENTED IT FOR SHARING HER
PERSONAL STORY WITH ALL OF US
HERE IN THE HEARING. WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THIS BILL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT FIFTY
THREE WEEKEND BUT HERE IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED. HE'S COME UP THE
MICROPHONE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. BRENT SPENCER ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OBGYN IS DISTRICT NINE THE
CALIFORNIA PRETTY ACTIVE MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AND THE SPONSORS OF
THE MEASURE THE CRIMSON CLAD IS
FOUNDATION ALL IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. TWO MEN REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA RHEUMATOLOGY
ALLIANCE IN THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF CARDIOLOGY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. SWEETNESS. JENNIFER SAID
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. STEVEN SCHULTZ
WITH THE ARTHRITIS FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO IN THIS.
FILIGREE SPOKEN CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
EXPERTNESS. CHRIS ROSA ON BEHALF
OF BIOGEN IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OKAY SEEN ON ALSO APPROACHING
THE MICROPHONE HERE IN ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED- MODERATOR PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO
SHOULD TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF
SB EIGHT FIFTY THREE NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION ONLY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR THOSE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS SPECIFIC BILL. PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE IF
YOU HAVE NOT DONE SO ALREADY.
GOING TO GO TO LINE. NINETY
FOUR. BY NINETY FOUR YEAR ONE IS
NOW OPEN. HI YES I'M HERE
BECAUSE THE OWNERS ARE STILL AT
THE NINE SEVENTY TWO. THAT WE
LATER SO WE'RE ON S. B. EIGHT
FIFTY THREE- WITNESSES WHICH
TESTIFIED SUPPORT. THANK YOU-
AND AGAIN THIS IS FOR WHAT
PURPOSE FOR BILL EIGHT THREE.
POINT SEVENTY SIX IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF A FIFTY
THREE PLEASE. GO AHEAD. THE MOVE
ON TO ONE ONE TWENTY THREE. SH
FORTY DOLLARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NINE ONE SIXTEEN. THANK
YOU MEDICARE MEMBERS ALEX
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CRIME CARE COALITION
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
ONE IS ONE THIRTY SEVEN. VISITOR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BRANDON
MARQUEE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
BY ONE SEVENTEEN. BOYER WITH THE
INCLUSION ACCESS FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
LINE. EIGHTY THE- RUBENSTEIN
WITH THE NATIONAL MULTIPLE
SCLEROSIS SOCIETY. WE SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
. LINE. ONE THIRTY. JOHNSON WITH
NIELSEN MARK MARK CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THE NEXT
WITNESS. BLIND. ONE TWENTY
EIGHT. MY HEART ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. FIND ONE TWELVE.
DONJON KIÞM BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
DERMATOLOGY AND DERMATOLOGIC
SURGERY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. ONE ONE TWENTY
NINE. STEVE HORN DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS FOR I
CAN'T INTERNATIONAL CANCER
ADVOCACY NETWORK EXPRESSING OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT FIVE
THREE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
LINE. FORTY FOUR. AND A FINAL
CALL FOR ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO. CHAIR
NO ONE ELSE THE SIGNAL THAT THEY
WISH TO SPEAK QUE THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL NOW BRING ON
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHT FIFTY THREE WE HAVE TO
LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES- AND I
THINK THEY'RE BOTH SPECIFIC IN
PERSON- JEFF HAMPTON FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS IN PRESTON YOUNG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
YOU EACH HAVE A TOTAL FOUR
MINUTES BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU
TWO MINUTES APIECE. PLEASE
BEGIN. A LOOK AT GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN OR THE COMMITTEE HAD
JEFF HAMPTON OF CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS. I
REGRETTABLY WE ARE HERE IN
OPPOSITION SPD FIFTY THREE I
WHICH REQUIRE HEALTH PLANS TO
COVER TONIGHT MEDICATION OR
DOSAGE OF A MEDICATION DURING-
AN APPEALS PROCESS. I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS AND THE IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE-
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD ON
THE BILL DATE- HOWEVER IT HEALTH
MENTAL I UPON SEVERAL CRITICAL
UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT PROTOCOLS
TO ENSURE THAT. PAID RECEIVE THE
RIGHT CARE AT THE RIGHT TIME.
THE RIGHT PROVIDER. THESE
PARTICLES ARE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT IN PROMOTING SAFE
EFFECTIVE AND AFFORDABLE CARE
FOR PLAN. RELEASED RIGHT STATION
STEP THERAPY. ARE PRO- THE ARE
PARTICULARLY IN PRESCRIPTION
DRUG- CONCERT. THE FOR. AND
ADDICTION AS WELL AS FOR THE
HIGH COST OF THESE DRUGS.
UNFORTUNATELY SB THIRTY THREE
WOULD PROBABLY DISMANTLE
EXISTING UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT
PROCESSES FOR PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS. SB FIFTY THREE
EFFECTIVELY NEGATES OUR ABILITY
TO ENSURE CLINICALLY APPROPRIATE
USE. OF PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AND
MAY ALSO ENCOURAGE THE USE OF
EXPENSIVE SPECIALTY. AND BRAND
NAME DRUGS ONE ENGINEER LOWER
COST BRAND CLEVELAND. IS
AVAILABLE IN CLINICALLY
APPROPRIATE. ADDITIONALLY WE
BELIEVE SB FIVE THREE COULD
CREATE SIGNIFICANT PATIENT
SAFETY CONCERNS FOR OUR RELEASE.
I WANT HEALTH PLAN TO THIS TO
LIMIT OR A DRUG OR
SPECIFIC DOSES OF A DRUG I
GENERALLY FOR SAFETY REASONS. A
SPECIFIC REASONS INCLUDE
POTENTIAL ABUSE OR OVER USE. AND
CONSISTENT USE WITH FDA APPROVED
LABELING. OR PREVENT USES AT
DOSES THAT HAVE NOT BEEN STUDIED
OR SHOWN TO BE EFFICACIOUS. SB
FIFTY THREE DOES NOT CONSIDER
THESE SAFETY CONCERNS AND ALLOWS
ENROLLEES UNFETTERED ACCESS TO
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS DURING THE
APPEALS PROCESS THAT ANY HEALTH
PLAN OVERSIGHT. I ARE STRONGLY
CONCERNED THE STRIPPING HEALTH
PLANS OF THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE
CLINICAL OVERSIGHT AND ACCESS TO
CERTAIN DRUGS. MAY CAUSE
POTENTIALLY ADVERSE REACTIONS IN
REAL HARM TO OUR RELEASE. LASTLY
WE LEAVE SB FIFTY THREE WILL
LEAD TO DRAMATICALLY INCREASE
COSTS AND HEALTHCARE DELIVERY.
THE INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA
HEALTH BENEFITS REVIEW PROGRAM
ANALYSIS OF SB FIFTY THREE.
CITED THE PREMIUMS AND COST
SHARING WILL LIKELY INCREASE BY
NEARLY EIGHTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ENROLLEES. RIGHT NOW
CALIFORNIA'S RIGHTLY FOCUSED ON
ACHIEVING ABOUT UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE AND COST CONTAINMENT
WITHIN THE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM. TWO MINUTES AND
UNFORTUNATELY THIS BILL WILL
LEAD TO HIGHER PREMIUMS AND
HARMING. CURRENT AFFORDABILITY
EFFORTS TO FOR THESE REASONS WE
OPPOSE THE MEASURE BUT I LOOK
FOURTEEN WITH THE AUTHOR. THANK
YOU- WELL BRING ON- KRISTEN
YOUNG FROM CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
YOU HAVE A MINUTE AND FORTY NINE
SECONDS THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS PRESS UNION FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE TODAY RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO SB FIFTY THREE. THE BILL IS
OBVIOUSLY WELL INTENTIONED I'VE
YET TO COME ACROSS THAT THE
HEALTH BILL THAT ISN'T-
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT WITH SB
FIFTY THREE THE PRIMARY CONCERN
THAT WE HAVE THIS BILL OR THE
COSTS THAT ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE- CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS-
REVIEW PROGRAM CONDUCTED AN
ANALYSIS IN THE DETERMINE THAT
EMPLOYER PREMIUMS WOULD RISE
TWENTY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS AT
THE BILL WENT INTO EFFECT.
EMPLOYEE PREMIUMS WOULD INCREASE
OVER NINE MILLION DOLLARS UNDER
SB FIFTY THREE SO WHILE THE
INCREASE ALONE MAY SEEM
TOLERABLE WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
THIS IN CONTEXT NUMEROUS BENEFIT
MANDATES HAVE BEEN INTRODUCED
THIS YEAR AND COLLECTIVELY THE
INCREASE PREMIUMS AND HEALTHCARE
COSTS FOR EMPLOYERS AND
EMPLOYEES OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEARS THE AVERAGE FAMILY HEALTH
PLAN PREMIUM FOR JOB BASED
COVERAGE HAS INCREASED TWENTY
TWO PERCENT. OR TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE KAISER FAMILY
FOUNDATION EMPLOYER HEALTH
BENEFITS SURVEY INDICATED THAT
FOR JOB BASED COVERAGE THE
AVERAGE ANNUAL PREMIUM FOR
FAMILY COVERAGE IS 220-002-0020
ONE DOLLARS THAT WAS A 4%
COMPARED TO PRIOR YEAR. THE WALL
SB FIFTY THREE ADDRESSES AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE WE NEED TO
REMAIN COGNISANT OF THE
CUMULATIVE IMPACT OF THESE
MANDATES HAVE A DRIVING HEALTH
CARE COSTS UPWARDS TO FOR THESE
REASONS RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS
SB FIFTY THREE THANK YOU. THANKS
VERY MUCH I WILL NOW TAKE ON
HERE FROM ABOUT THE DGITAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHT FIFTY THREE PM ROOM.
TWELVE HUNDRED NAME OR EXISTING
POSITION. WELCOME. THREE SEVENTY
ONE ON BEHALF OF THE THIRTY OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE IN HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES ALSO A BEST
THANK YOU. SEE NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE HERE
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHO SHOULD TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT FIFTY
THREE NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION
. AND FOR THOSE THAT LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT
FIFTY THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN ONE ZERO
PROPOSITION. AT THE TIME WE DO
HAVE TO IN OUR QUEUE. THE FIRST
MOVED TO NUMBER ONE TWENTY
SEVENTH. MISTER CHAIRMAN JOHN
WHEN YOU'RE ONLY HALF OF
AMERICA'S HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT WE'LL GO TO NUMBER
ONE TWENTY ONE. I CAN HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN WORK YES. YEAH MY
NAME IS I AM FROM YUBA COUNTY
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE- SB EIGHT
FIVE THREE THANK YOU. THANK X.
WITH THIS. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
NUMBER ONE FORTY SEVEN. UPPER OF
THE AIR ALLOW IS BE NICE TO SEE
. THANK TO THANK YOU MODERATOR.
RIGHT NEXT WITH THIS A NEXT WEEK
NEXT TO THE NUMBER ONE FORTY
EIGHT. NUMBER ONE FORTY EIGHTH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WILL MOVE TO
NUMBER ONE FORTY FIVE. CAN YOU
HEAR ME PLEASE ENTER YOUR NAME
YOUR NAME FOR EXAMPLE DECISION
VERY. IT WAS KIND OF HARD TO YOU
KNOW FROM THE- HONORED THESE
INTERNATIONAL. HELLO MY NAME IS
SHERRY ALL ACTION AND I AM
REPRESENTING JEWS YOU PROBABLY
FOR U. S. SENATE AND WE STRONGLY
OPPOSE ITSELF THANK YOU. NEXT
WITNESS. AND AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHT FIFTY THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. MR THIS TIME THERE'S
NO ONE ELSE IN OUR QUEUE RIGHT
THANKS VERY MUCH MODERATOR WILL
BRING IT BACK TO ME AS A
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. THURMOND IS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- SAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS- WHAT I'M
READING IT SAYS REQUIRES HEALTH
PLAN CONTRACT- THAT COVERS
PRESCRIPTION DRUG BENEFITS TO
PROVIDE COVERAGE FOR A DRUG- OR
DOSE OF A DRUG. DURING
UTILIZATION REVIEW ANDANY
APPEALS THAT THAT DRUG IS BEEN
PREVIOUSLY PRE APPROVED FOR
MEDICAL CONDITIONS SO. ONLY
DURING UTILIZATION REVIEW AND
ANY APPEAL THAT MAY BE TAKING
PLACE BUT IF FOR INSTANCE. THE
PEEL UNITS THEY GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND THEY SAY NO THIS IS
JUST NOT RIGHT VIEW THEN IT
DOESN'T APPLY IS THAT RIGHT
RIGHT IF YOU IF YOU LOSE YOUR
APPEAL THEN THEY DON'T HAVE TO
COVERAGE. BY DURING THE PENDENCY
OF THE APPEAL WE WANT TO
MAINTAIN THAT STABILITY AND THEN
THEY CAN GO BACK AFTERWARDS AND
SAID FOR THOSE TWO MONTHS YOU
HAVE TO KNOW PASSED BACK OKAY I
JUST. REALIZED OKAY SO I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR- JED HAMPTON WOULD
YOU MIND COMING MISTER CHARITY.
OKAY IF YOU IN MY ANTHONY PLEASE
COME LIKE A PHONE I JUST HAVE A
QUICK QUESTION BECAUSE YOU
MENTIONED- CONCERNS ABOUT PEOPLE
PERHAPS- YOU KNOW ABUSING THE
PRESCRIPTIONS THAT THEY MAY BE
PRESCRIBED BY THEIR DOCTOR AND I
JUST WONDER WHAT TYPES OF DRUGS
WERE YOU REFERRING TO THE ARE
YOU THINKING OPIOIDS OR BECAUSE-
DURING THE COURSE OF THIS
CONVERSATION WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT DISEASES LIKE CROHN'S AND
CHRONIC ILLNESSES THAT. I'M
CERTAINLY NO ONE IS- YOU KNOW
TAKING DEAD. TO GET HIGH EITHER
TAKING IT BECAUSE OF THE ILLNESS
AT THE HOUSE I'M JUST IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND ANSWERING THAT
QUESTION YET NOT NOT NO PROBLEM
THANK THANK YOU AND MAKE SURE-
YES- SO. WITH THE BILL THOUGH
ISN'T IN RIGHT NOW IT IT DOESN'T
LIMIT- WHICH DRUGS- YOU KNOW OR
APPLICABLE TO THE BILL SO WHAT
WHILE. THERE ARE SOME DRUGS
EXCELLENT YOU KNOW FOR CRUNCHING
OR COLITIS BASED DRUGS ON THIS
THIS BILL DOES NOT SPECIFY WHICH
DRUGS WOULD BE SUBJECT TO THIS
NEW YEAR REQUIREMENT OR LACK OF
UTILIZATION REVIEW. OR
UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT SO I
THINK THAT THAT'S ONE OF OUR
PRIMARY CONCERNS IS THAT THE WAY
THAT WE READ THE BILL IS THAT
THAT THIS CAN BE OPEN TO IT TO
ESSENTIALLY ANY AND ALL DRUGS
ARE PRESCRIBED. BY DOCTORS TODAY
BUT SO ARE YOU IMPLYING THAT
THIS YOU HAVE A CONCERN WITH SAY
OPIOID PRESCRIPTIONS OR IS THERE
SOMETHING ELSE WHAT IS YOUR
SPECIFIC CONCERNS. YEAH I THINK
GENERALLY SPEAKING THAT COULD BE
A CONCERN I THINK GENERALLY
SPEAKING WHEN WE'RE WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE BILL WE'RE
LOOKING AT THAT THE BILL SENATE
THERE IS NO- ABILITY TO LIMIT
THE DOSAGE OF THE DRUG IN
PARTICULAR. AND THE FACT THAT
THE BILL DOES NOT SPECIFICALLY
LIMIT WHICH DRUGS ARE OR NOT
APPLICABLE TO THE BILL- WE SEE
THAT AS BEING KIND OF WIDE OPEN
SO IT COULD BE SOMETHING LIKE
OPIOIDS WHICH COULD. POTENTIALLY
BE AN ISSUE THAT THAT WERE
PRESCRIBED- IT COULD BE OTHER
DRUGS- IF WE DON'T HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO A CLINICAL RADIO
AND LOOK AT THE CLINICAL
PROPRIOCEPTIVE DOSAGE OF THE
DRUG IN PARTICULAR- YOU KNOW WE
FEEL THAT THAT. PATIENT SAFETY
CONCERNS COULD ARISE FROM FROM
THAT OKAY SO. THEN ON THAT NOTE-
YOU KNOW THEY- A REAL. BETWEEN
PATIENT AND THE DOCTOR AND THE
PATIENT. IN THE ENSURING THE
DOCTOR BY. UNITY DO YOU THINK
THAT THE DOCTOR. MIGHT HAVE- A
BETTER INDICATION OF WHAT'S BEST
FOR HIS REPORT HER PATIENT MORE
SO THAN SAY AN INSURANCE PLAN
WOULD. YEAH I THINK GENERALLY
SPEAKING YOU KNOW PROVIDERS
PLANS- INDIVIDUAL WORK TOGETHER-
AND IN THAT SCENARIO TO ENSURE
YOU KNOW- COMING UP CLINICALLY
APPROPRIATE TREATMENT ALL RIGHT
WE CONTRACT WITH PROVIDERS WE
CERTAINLY- YOU KNOW UNDERSTAND
TRUST AND WORK THESE PROVIDERS
ON ON ON A- CLOSELY RELATED
BASIS. YOU KNOW I THINK OUR
GENERAL CONCERN IS RUNNING
AROUND THE UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT PROTOCOLS THAT WE
TYPICALLY USE THAT ARE IN PLACE
CURRENTLY- YOU KNOW WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT THAT THIS BILL
WOULD DISMANTLE THAT PROCESS A
CENTRALLY AND SO WE WOULD HAVE
NO ABILITY AS- YOU KNOW. ACTING
IN OVERSIGHT POSITION TO LOOK
FOR REVIEW ANY OF THE CLINICAL
COMPLETE APPROPRIATE. POTENTIAL
USES ARE TREATMENTS FOR THESE
DRUGS SO THAT'S GENERALLY AROUND
THAT PROCESS WHERE WE ARE
CONCERNED WE CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE
THAT WORKING WITH OUR PARTNERS
PROVIDERS YOU KNOW BUT THE
NETWORKING CONTRACTED PROVIDERS
ARE OBVIOUSLY A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF THE HEALTHCARE DELIVERY
SYSTEM- BUT I THINK THESE
PROCESSES- YOU KNOW ARE IN PLACE
FOR A REASON- AND THAT'S
GENERALLY WHITE WE HAVE- OKAY
SIR THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE
THAT- I. THE THIS IS ALWAYS A
TOUGH ISSUE YOU KNOW BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY COSTS ARE A CONCERN
AND IF COSTS ARE GOING TO
INCREASE FOR THE OTHER- AB PLAN
HOLDERS THEN YOU KNOW THAT
CAUSES PROBLEMS FOR PEOPLE. BUT
THEN WE HAVE TO GO TO THE
REALITY OF THE SITUATION WHICH
IS WHAT YOU WERE DESCRIBING A
PEOPLE HAVING A CHRONIC ILLNESS
FOR WHICH THEY NEED IN THEIR
PARTICULAR PRESCRIPTION AND THEN
RUNNING INTO ISSUES WITH THEIR
INSURANCE PLAN SAYING WE DON'T
NEED THAT ANYMORE AND WHILE I
CERTAINLY. APPRECIATE AND
RESPECT THE CONCERN THAT PERHAPS
YOU KNOW SOME OPIOID ADDICTION
MIGHT BE COMING INTO PLAY HERE
WITH OTHER MEDICATIONS I JUST. I
DON'T THINK THAT'S THE EMPHASIS
OF THE BILL AND I THINK IT'S-
IT'S TERRIBLY. CRUEL TO TELL
SOMEONE THAT THE MEDICINE THAT
HAS BEEN WORKING FOR YOU- AND
THAT YOU HAVE DISCUSSED WITH
YOUR PHYSICIAN IN YOUR POSITION
IS MADE THE DETERMINATION THAT
THIS IS THE BEST THING FOR YOU
BUT THEN AN INSURANCE PLAN STEPS
IN AND SAYS WELL WE DON'T THINK
SO WHEN THEY'VE NOT GONE TO
MEDICAL SCHOOL ALTHOUGH THEY
HAVE COLLECTED THE DATA. AND I
DO HAVE TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
RESPECT FOR THE WORK THAT GOES
INTO THAT BUT THE REALITY IS THE
PHYSICIAN IS KNOWS THEIR PATIENT
IS SAT WITH THEM IN THE ROOM AND
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S GOING ON AND I
THINK THAT'S THE FOCUS OF THIS
BILL- SO THANK YOU FOR ASKING MY
QUESTIONS. ARE ANSWERED MY
QUESTIONS EXCUSE ME THINK CENTER
WIENER. ASSEMBLY ROW. THANK YOU
THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR I DO HAVE
A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS IN LINE
WITH WHAT. MISS MELINDA'S ARE
GASSED- BRIGUS I SHOULD SAY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM HAS CAN DO- SO
THIS BILL OF THE WAY I READ IT
AND PLEASE CORRECT ME IF I'M
WRONG THE AUTHOR'S INTENT IS
DIFFERENT IT'S- CURRENTLY.
INDIVIDUALS CURRENTLY ON
MEDICATION. M. FOR ANY TYPE OF
SPECIFIC DISEASE. AND THEN
SOMETHING COMES UP AND THERE'S A
REVIEW AND- YOU JUST WANT TO BE
ABLE THIS BILL WANTS TO BE ABLE
TO JUST ALLOW THEM TO CONTINUE
THE MEDICATION THEY'VE BEEN ON.
DURING THE REVIEW PROCESS. TWO
CAN. THE MEDICATION OR IF THE
DOCTOR DETERMINES THAT A
DIFFERENT DOSAGE OR DOSAGE FORM.
IS REQUIRED LIKE IF THEY WERE-
IF IT IF IT DOESN'T MAKE UP
MEDICAID AND THAT THERE. HAVE TO
USE VIA A PATCH AND THEN IT
COMES OUT. AS AN INJECTABLE AND
THE DOCTOR DETERMINES THAT THE
INJECTABLE IS GOING TO BE MUCH
MORE EFFECTIVE. THAN THE PATCH
FROM THE DOG BEN IS SWITCHING
BUT IT'S THE SAME DRUG- OR LET
ME. GIVE YOU ANOTHER EXAMPLE I
WAS GOING TO DO THIS TODAY-
BECAUSE I DON'T LIKE TO
PERSONALIZE THESE THINGS BUT I
MAKE AN EXCEPTION. BECAUSE OF
VERONICA BLANCATO COULD TELL HER
STORY AND SO CAN I. UNLIKE
VERONICA. MILES CRISIS I'VE HAD
IT FOR THIRTY THREE. YEARS AND-
HI YOU MAY RECALL LAST JULY
COLLEAGUES THAT I MISSED A
HEALTH COMMITTEE. HEARING AND
THEN- CENTER EGGMAN WAS KIND OF
TO SIT IN FOR ME AND HOUSING
COMMITTEE- I WAS OUT FOR A WEEK
BECAUSE I WAS IN THE HOSPITAL-
BECAUSE- UNLIKE VERONICA- ONE
EVENING- I. EXPERIENCE THE MOST
INTENSE OF DOMINO PAIN THAT I
COULD EVEN IMAGINE- AND I WAS
ABLE TO CRAWL UP THE STAIRS AND
GET MY LANDLORD TO. DRIVE ME TO
THE HOSPITAL THANK YOU SUTTER
FOR DOING A GREAT JOB CARING FOR
ME- AND IT WAS BECAUSE I. MIGHT
BE HAVE DEVELOPED ANTIBODIES TO
MY BIOLOGIC AND SO I HAVE NO
MEDICINE MY SYSTEM AND I HAD
ABSCESSES LIKE VERONICA DID AND
SO I CAN TEST EVERYTHING. THAT
SHE SAID. AND SO MY DOCTOR
SWITCHED ME TO A NEW BIOLOGICALS
LARA- AND THANKFULLY AND THANK
YOU TO ANTHEM ANTHEM QUICKLY
APPROVED AND THERE WERE NO
ISSUES- AND I TAKE IT. IT'S
INJECTABLE BY TAKE EVERY EIGHT
WEEKS AND IT'S WORKED
BEAUTIFULLY FOR ME IT'S REALLY
DONE A GREAT JOB. BUT FOR A FAIR
NUMBER OF PEOPLE. LARA EIGHT
WEEKS MIGHT BE TOO INFREQUENT
AND YOU HAVE TO DO IT EVERY FOUR
WEEKS OR EVERY SIX WEEKS AND
YOUR DOCTOR MAKES THAT DECISION-
AND YOU HAVE TO GET PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION. FROM THE HEALTH
PLAN. TO DO THAT- AND SO IF I
WERE TO NEED. AT SOME POINT. AND
THEY DENIED IT. THAT I WOULD
HAVE PROTECTIONS THAT ARE UP TO
MY DOC TO YOU KNOW IT WOULD IS
NOT. YOU NEED IT SIX WEEKS OR
FIVE WEEKS OR FOUR WEEKS INSIDE
A HEALTH PLAN AND I AND I
APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS CENTER
MELINDA'S. AND SO THAT'S REALLY
WHAT IT IS ABOUT AND IF I HAD TO
APPEAL- I COULD GET THEM TO HAVE
THAT PROPER DOSAGES DURING THE
APPEAL. SO THAT I WOULDN'T HAVE
TO MISS MORE HEALTH COMMITTEE
MEETINGS SO THAT'S REALLY WHAT
THE BILL IS ABOUT. THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU CAN ASK MISTER HAMPTON
TO COME FORWARD AGAIN I
APOLOGIZE JUST TO CLARIFY A
COUPLE OF THINGS. THE BASED ON
WHAT THE AUTHOR JUST SAID AND
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING IS IT'S
IS IT IT'S A CURRENT. MEDICATION
PRESCRIBED ALREADY APPROVED BY.
THE PLANS AND THEN THE DOCTOR
MAKES EITHER AN ADJUSTMENT OR
SWITCHING THE MEDICATION. I'M IT
YOUR CONCERN- YOU SAID ACTUALLY
YOU SAID- YOU'RE VERY CONCERNED
ABOUT THE COST AND ADDICTION
WHAT'S WHAT'S THE APPEAL PROCESS
TIMELINE THE THIRTY DAYS NINETY
DAYS HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS YEAH
IT'S YOURS. IT'S DIED GENERAL
GENERALLY THIRTY DAYS THIRTY
DAYS ON SCIENCE TRIED TO
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW- DUE PROCESS
THESE THESE APPEALS AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE- BUT YET THAT'S
GENERALLY THE CASE. AND I KNOW
IT WAS THE GENTLEMAN FROM THE
CHAMBER HE MADE THE COST
ESTIMATES I BELIEVE- 22%
INCREASE TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS NINE MILLION DOLLARS
COST INCREASE. I MEAN NEED
RATTLED OFF A BUNCH OF NUMBERS
AND I'M SURE IT'S IN THE
ANALYSIS. AND HOW MANY OF THESE.
UTILIZATION REVIEWS FOR
MEDICATION THAT'S ALREADY
EXISTING IN A PATIENT YOU GUYS
DO AN ESTIMATED BASIS. YOU KNOW
CENTER I WOULD PROBABLY HAVE TO
GO BACK TO MY FOLKS YOU KNOW TO
GET MORE ACCURATE ANSWER FOR YOU
ON HOW AND HOW OFTEN THE
INTERVIEWS ARE CONDUCTED I MEAN
THAT MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THAT THAT THEY'RE DONE. YOU KNOW
SOMEWHAT REGULARLY BUT UP FOR ME
ON A SPECIFIC NUMBER I WOULD
PROBABLY NEED TO FOLLOW BACK UP
WITH YOU AND WHEN YOU DO THEM
SOMEWHAT REGULARLY AND THANK YOU
FOR THE FOLLOW UP I'D APPRECIATE
THAT INFORMATION WHEN YOU DO
THEM SOMEWHAT REGULARLY DO YOU
STOPPED. THE MEDICATION REQUESTS
FROM THE PROVIDE THE MEDICAL
PROVIDER AT THAT TIME CURRENTLY.
BUT SO I'M SORRY IT JUST SO I
UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION CREEK I
JUST WELL I WAS ONE MAKE SURE-
SO IF YOU'RE AT IF YOU'RE ASKING
IF. IT'S IN ROWLEY- IS SEEKING
TO HAVE A CHANGE OF OTHER DRUG
OR DOSAGE OF THE DRUG- ARE YOU
ASKING THAT YOU KNOW WHETHER WE
STOP THAT UPON I'M ASKING IF YOU
IF SAID OKAY SO LET ME REPHRASE
THAT QUESTION. IF A MEDICAL
PROVIDER SEND YOUR PRESCRIPTION
THAT I'M CURRENTLY ON IN MY
MEDICAL PROVIDER SAYS YOU NEED
TO UPGRADE THIS TO FOUR WEEKS
INSTEAD OF EIGHT WEEKS LIKE THE
AUTHOR WAS SEEN. DO YOU CAN DO
YOU PROVIDE ME THE FOUR WEEKS AT
YOUR DISCRETION I MEAN OBVIOUSLY
THE AUTHOR SAID HE GOT THE
CHANGE INSTANTLY. I'M I'M I'M
HOPING IT'S NOT BECAUSE HE
SENATOR SCOTT WIENER- BUT IF
THERE'S A AVERAGE EVERYDAY
CITIZEN THAT SAYS YOU KNOW THE
DOCTOR SAYS I HAVE TO HAVE THIS.
INJECTABLE NOW BECAUSE IT'S
STILL NOT AFFECTING ME AM I
WOULD THINK THAT YOU GUYS WOULD
BE JUST AS EXPEDIENT IN
APPROVING. THE MEDICAL PROVIDERS
REQUEST IS THAT TRUE YES YES
GENERALLY SPEAKING AFTER THE
AMONG THESE OBVIOUSLY WITH WHEN
IT COMES TO PRESCRIPTION DRUGS
SPECIALLY IF IT'S THERE I'M
TREATING YOU KNOW CHRONIC.
RESEARCH CONDITIONS- HEALTH
CENTER ARE YOU KNOW WE PROCESS
THOSE AS QUICKLY AS WE CAN. I
GET PERSONAL STORIES LIKE HIS
AND AGAIN LATER THAT LADY THAT
TESTIFIED. AND IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT YOU GUYS DELAY
FOR A LENGTHY PROCESS YOU GUYS
IMMEDIATELY EXPECT THIS YES GEN
MOST CASES GENERALLY SPEAKING
GENERALLY SPEAKING YES OKAY. SO
IF YOU DO THAT I'M KIND OF
CURIOUS AND AGAIN I'M JUST GONNA
MAKE THE STATEMENT OF A YES
ANSWER IT IF YOU HAVE
UTILIZATION REVIEW ALREADY
AVAILABLE YOU DO IT AN EXPEDITED
PROCESS- I DON'T SEE WHERE THE
COST FACTOR COMES IT SEEMS LIKE
YOU'RE TAKING A WHOLE LIKE
EVERYBODY'S GONNA BE REQUESTING
AND THAT CHANGING MEDICATION-
THE MOST EXPENSIVE MEDICATION
BUT IT'S TRULY NOT THOUGH IT'S
JUST WHAT THE MEDICAL PROVIDER
PROVIDES WRITE THAT PRESCRIPTION
YEAH I THINK IN TERMS OF THE
COST ESTIMATES CENTER I THINK-
YOU KNOW YOU THE NUMBERS WE WERE
CITING OR FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH BENEFITS REVIEW PROGRAM.
AND THEIR ESTIMATES WERE BASED
ON GREATER UTILIZATION OF THE
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS AS WELL AS
OTHER POTENTIAL OFF TED TO SEE
AN INCREASE IN THE USE OF
SPECIALTY DRUGS- AND IN THE IN
THE TRUCKS ARE OBVIOUSLY
TYPICALLY- COST QUITE A BIT
MORE- THAN CONVENING STANDARD
MEDICATION- ANYONE THAT MAY OR
MAY NOT BE SO- YOU KNOW FROM
FROM I THINK FROM THE CHAMBERS
PERSPECTIVE IN IT THAT'S WHERE
THEY WERE LOOKING AT THAT THE
RISING COSTS IS GREATER
UTILIZATION AND POTENTIALLY
GREATER USE A SPECIALTY DRUGS
FOR BRAND NAME DRUGS- IT IN IN
LIEU OF USING- ENGINEERING OR
LOWER COSTS ARE LOWER COST
ALTERNATIVE BUT IT'S ONLY FOR
THAT TIME PERIOD FROM ZERO TO
THIRTY DAYS FOR THE REVIEW
RIGHT. OR NOT YOU CAN DENY IT
YEAH I GUESS GENERALLY SPEAKING
SO DURING THE APPEAL PROCESS
LIKE AS ONCE IT'S ONCE IT'S
TONIGHT IT'S JUST DONE SO IF
YOU'VE DENIED IN FIVE DAYS. ANY
OTHER WEEK YOU KNOW. IT COULD BE
DENIED AND DAYS DAYS WHEN. SEVEN
THIRTY IS THE- OR THIRTY DAYS A
MAC. YES YEAH JERRY WE HAVE TO
GENTLY PRUDENT AND WITHIN THIRTY
DAYS OKAY GREAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR ANSWERING MY QUESTIONS
SIR. I'M CERTAIN THE LETTUCE I
JUST WANTED AND- JUST. GOING
BACK TO THE OPIOID- ISSUE WHAT
WE DIDN'T TALK ABOUT WAS THE
CARE SYSTEM THAT'S ALREADY. OUR
DATABASE IS ALREADY IN PLACE IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH WOULD ADDRESS
YOU KNOW IF THERE IS OVER
PRESCRIBING OF OPIOIDS THAT WE
KIND OF ALREADY HAVE SOMETHING
IN PLACE TO ADDRESS THAT. SO
THANK YOU. EXECUTIVES AND I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU KNOW IN
TERMS OF. ABUSE OF DRUGS AND I
THINK YOU WERE SPOT ON CENTER
MELENDEZ SAID- THAT. IF YOU'RE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WHEN SEVEN
OPP OPIOIDS. LIKE THE THIRD COST
IS NOT THE ISSUE BUT AS WE KNOW
WITH OPIOIDS ARE THOSE ARE
TYPICALLY NOT I'M SURE THERE'S
SOME SPECIALIZED KIND OF OPENS
THE GENERALLY THOSE ARE OFTEN
GENERIC AND THEY'RE NOT
PARTICULARLY EXPENSIVE THAT'S
NOT WHAT THE FIGHT OF IS ABOUT.
AND IT IS OFTEN ABOUT THE
BIOLOGICS AND THE FACT THAT THEY
THEY DO DENY- COVERED FOR
BIOLOGICS AT TIMES- AND NOT
OTHERWISE THEY WOULDN'T BE
FIGHTING. THIS BILL RIGHT THERE
WHEN THEY WON RESERVE THE RIGHT
THAT EVEN IF YOUR DOCTOR SAYS.
THAT YOU NEED TO CHANGE IT DOES
OR YOU NEED TO HAVE INTRACTABLE
INSTEAD OF A PILL- THEY WANT TO
RESERVE THE RIGHT TO JUST BE
ABLE TO REJECT THAT- AND THIS
BILL SAYS YOU CAN'T YOU HAVE TO
LISTEN TO WHAT THE DOCTOR SAYS
THANK YOU. SIR EDMUND. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH UP IN YOU CENTER WE
DON'T THINK FOR SHARING WITH THE
I NOTICED A- ALWAYS EASY BUT
THINK APPRECIATE THAT- AND
APPRECIATE ALSO. WITH SOMEBODY
WHO IS. NOT NOTHING YOUR FRAGILE
BUT WITH VERY FRAGILE HEALTH
CARE AND A LOT OF HEALTH CARE
NEEDS AND A LOT OF INTERACTIONS
WITH THE- PHYSICIANS AND
PHARMACIES AND- HEALTH PLANS I
KNOW IT'S ALWAYS. LESS EXPENSIVE
TO RATION HEALTHCARE. ARE THAT'S
JUST THE BASIC THE MORE YOU
RUSSIAN HEALTH CARE THE LESS
EXPENSIVE IT IS. AND WHAT
INSURANCE ARE PAYING FOR IT
THAT'S WHEN YOU KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE MARKING A NINE IT COMES.
BACK TO ALL OF US OF COURSE- BUT
I REALLY THINK WHEN WE'RE MAKING
DECISIONS LIKE THIS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I HEARD THE
OPPOSITION SAY WAS- IT. IT
DISRUPTS THE- STANDARD
UTILIZATION PROCESS- BUT- WE'VE
BEEN DOING UTILIZATION REVIEW
SINCE. THE BEGINNING OF TIME.
WELL NOT BEGINNING BUT- THE
LAST. THE LAST COUPLE DECADES IN
HEALTH CARE. MAYBE IT'S TIME TO
CHANGE OF THOSE PROCESSES RIGHT
WE CAN DO THAT WE CAN DO THAT IF
THERE'S SOMEBODY WHO'S ON
SOMETHING. LIKE THIS THAT'S
THAT'S- VERY PRECISE AND NEW IN
A BIOLOGIC. MAYBE THAT
UTILIZATION REVIEW. COULD BE
FASTER. THERE'S DIFFERENT THINGS
WE CAN DO. THEN RUSSIAN HEALTH
CARE WHICH OFTEN ENDS UP IN IN
MORE SEVERE COST WHEN SOMEONE
ENDS UP IN THE HOSPITAL. AS YOU
SHARED YOUR DEBT. SO I THINK IS
A GOOD BILL I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT I THINK. WE SPEND A
LOT OF TIME AND INTEREST AND WE
TAKE A LOT OF PRIDE IN. OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM AND DUBBED
THEM THE OF THE FANTASTIC
SCIENCE AND DRUGS THAT WE HAVE.
TO IMPROVE PEOPLE'S LIVES TO
EXPAND PEOPLE'S LIVES TO IMPROVE
THE QUALITY. OF PEOPLE'S LIVES-
AND IT SHOULD HAVE EVERY ACCESS
TO THE THAT THEY POSSIBLY CAN
AND IT SHOULD BE THE INSURANCES
HAS NOW. SO I WOULD LIKE TO MOVE
THIS BILL. THOSE MOVE A CENTER
EGGMAN ANY QUESTIONS ARE COMMON
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. SECOND
OKAY SEEING NONE- SIR WIENER
FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR WORKING BY STAFF AND THAT
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS- PROPOSED.
AND I REALLY DO APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION WE'VE HAD HERE I
THINK IT REALLY ILLUSTRATES THE
PORTENTS OF FILE- PATIENTS NEED
TO SPELL AND- CERTAINLY YOU KNOW
TIMES- RECOGNIZE THAT SOME OF
THE CONCERNS FROM THE
OPPOSITION- BUT- FUNDAMENTALLY
THESE ARE ABOUT. DRUGS THAT.
PATIENTS NOW I NEED THE RADION
SO THEY WENT THROUGH SOME
PROCESS BY WHICH SIMPLE PLAN HAS
YES THERE'S SOME CHANGES- AND I
THINK IS- I REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT- CENTRO POINTED OUT THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT IF YOU KEEP THE
VIEW SHORT AND IT'S A FAIRLY
STANDARD THAT WILL MINIMIZE THE
COST TO SELL AND THE RESPONSE OF
THE PATIENTS. IN TERMS OF-
MAKING A DECISION- AND- SO WITH
THAT- CERTAINLY BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL OF WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. BECAUSE I REALLY. THE
THOUGHTFUL DISCUSSION- TODAY AND
I THINK A LOT OF YOU CLOSE FOR
ME SO. ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS- SO
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. OKAY
THANK YOU- SO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS
INSECT MY CENTER EGGMAN
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SB EIGHT FIFTY THREE. PM HI CAN
I AM A LINDA'S BELINDA'S AYE
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH GROUP BY HER
TADO. LEYVA LIMON. LIMON I ROTH
ALL RIGHT ROTH AYE RUBIO. WIENER
FIVE WIENER AYE. FIFTY S. SO
THAT BILLS CURRENTLY HAS EIGHT
VOTES IT'S EIGHT ZERO- WILL HOLD
THE BILL OPENED- TO OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS LET'S NOW MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER FOR SB EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT BY SARAH WIENER. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
COLLEAGUES- THIS WE'VE DONE A
LOT OF WORK- IN RECENT YEARS BUT
OVER DECADES- TO MAKE SURE THAT-
ARE HEALTH PLANS. ARE ACTUALLY
COVERING THE HEALTH CARE WE NEED
WHETHER ITS BIOLOGIC DRUGS
WHETHER IT IS MENTAL HEALTH CARE
THAT'S BEEN A LOT OF WORK WE'VE
DONE. IN THE LAST FEW YEARS JUST
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE ARE
ACTUALLY GETTING COVERAGE WHEN
THEY- PURCHASE- HEALTH
INSURANCE. PLANS SB EIGHT FIVE
EIGHT IS THE NEXT UP TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE ACTUALLY
ENFORCING. THOSE LAWS. AND THAT
WHEN A HEALTH PLAN- VIOLATES THE
LAW PARTICULARLY IN A PERSISTENT
SYSTEMATIC WAY. THAT THE FINES
IMPOSED ARE NOT VIEWED AS A COST
OF DOING BUSINESS. BUT THE FINES
ACTUALLY MEANS SOMETHING AND
CREATE A DETERRENT BECAUSE WHEN
A PATIENT IS TONIGHT CARE- EVEN
IF THEY'RE ALTERNATELY JANET.
MONTHS OR YEARS LATER WHEN THE
INSURANCE PLAN IS FOUNDED IN A
BALL THAT DOESN'T HELP THEM FOR
ALL THE TIME THEY'VE HAD TO WAIT
WE WANT TO GET IT UP FRONT WHERE
THE HELL TIMES DO THE RIGHT
THING AND FOLLOW THE LAW AND TO
BE CLEAR THIS IS ABOUT. TIMES
WHEN HEALTH PLANS VIOLATE THE
LAW NOT WHEN THEY'RE ARGUABLY
BILINGUAL BUT WHEN THEY HAVE
BEEN FOUND BY THE STATE TO HAVE
VIOLATED THE LAW BY DENYING
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE TO SOMEONE
WHO IS ENTITLED. TO THAT
COVERAGE- WE KNOW THAT ALL TOO
OFTEN THE FINES ARE VERY LOW.
THERE WAS A RECENT- VERY LARGE
FINE- ANNOUNCED AGAINST LA CARE
WHICH WAS LA COUNTY'S PUBLICLY
ON HEALTH PLAN THAT INSURANCE
TWO MILLION MEDIC HELP PATIENTS-
THIS WAS THE LARGEST PENALTY IN
STATE HISTORY AND SO MADE
HEADLINES IS A BIG DEAL- AND
YET. THE PER VIOLATION IT WAS A
FEW HUNDRED DOLLARS IT'D BEEN
THAT SYSTEMATIC AND PERVASIVE
AND SO PER VIOLATION IT WAS
STILL EXTREMELY. LOW EVEN WE
HAVE A SEEM TO HIGH FOR. YOU
LOOK AT YEAR AND THE SUPER OF
THOSE. IT'S ACTUALLY NOT THAT
BIG OF FINE. IN TERMS OF THE
HARM- THAT WAS INFLICTED ON SO
WHAT THIS- WHAT THIS BILL WILL
DO IS TAKE THE FIND THAT
EXISTING LAW WHICH IS TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS. PER
VIOLATION. WHICH WAS SET IN THE
LATE NINETEEN SEVENTIES. HAS NOT
BEEN ADJUSTED EVEN FOR INFLATION
SEND SEND. AND WILL INCREASE IT
TO A FINE OF TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND. PER VIOLATION I KNOW
SOME SAID WELL IT'S A TEN FOLD
INCREASE FOR TALKING ABOUT A
HUGE PERIOD OF TIME. WHERE THIS
VERY OUTDATED FIND LEVELS BEEN
IN PLACE THAT IS NOT CREATING A
DETERRENT IT IS COST OF DOING
BUSINESS AND ESPECIALLY WHEN
HEALTH CARE IS NOT CHEAP. AND
YOU HAVE A LOW FINE PER
VIOLATION. BUT UNFORTUNATELY
CREATES INCENTIVES TO VIEW IT AS
A COST OF DOING BUSINESS I WANT
TO BE CLEAR THIS IS NOT ABOUT
BROAD BRUSHING. OR DEMONIZING
THE HEALTH PLANS. A LOT OF THE
HEALTH PLANS YOU'RE VERY VERY
FREQUENTLY- PROVIDING PRODUCTS
COVERAGE AND NOT CAUSING
PROBLEMS AND NOT BY ALLOWING THE
LAW BUT THERE ARE TIMES WHEN THE
BAR. THEY NEED TO BE ACCOUNTABLE
AND YOU TO HAVE INCENTIVES NOT
TO VIOLATE. THE LAW SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE I
WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE. FOR
WORKING- WITH US- AND- I KNOW
THAT WE HAVE SOME ADDITIONAL
WORK TO DO WHICH WE'VE COMMITTED
TO CONTINUING TO CONSULT WITH
THE COMMITTEE ON- AROUND-
FINDING A WAY TO ALLOW ENROLLEES
TO RECOVER THEIR FINANCIAL
LOSSES- WITH THE INCREASE FIND
REVENUE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE ON THAT.
RESPECTFULLY I BOOKS. TO WITH ME
TODAY ARE- DOES HICKS AND DIANA
DOUGLAS FROM ACCESS SPONSOR.
THANK YOU AND TO CONFIRM YOU'D
VISITED MENTION VILLA SOMEONE I
THINK TO ALSO SO. OF SOME NEW
THEM REGARDING THE INCREASE THE
FINAL. HOW WITH THE AVERAGE
PREMIUMS. WITHOUT ANY ANALYSIS-
OF OKAY SHE'S WAITING A RED OAK
WELL. I'M SURE WE CAN A CLEAR
FOR THAT A WHOLE THANK YOU YES
IT IS CONSISTENT. EVAN YOU JUST
WITH THE CAN YEAH ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT SO WHAT
WE'RE GOING AND THE IN OUR- IN
SUPPORT- YEAH JASMINE X- SO YES
FOR A PLEASE BEGIN TO MINUTES
FOUR MINUTES FOR THE TWO OF YOU.
THANK YOU MY NAME IS JEFF ACHES
AND I'M THE MOTHER OF TWO TO.
AND I'M HERE TO URGE YOU TO
APPROVE THIS LONG OVERDUE REFORM
BECAUSE IN SPITE OF CALIFORNIA'S
MENTAL HEALTH PARITY ACT MY
FAMILY SUFFERING TO QUINCES OF
KAISER'S CONTINUED REFUSAL TO
PROVIDE ACCESS TO MENTAL HEALTH
CARE. IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN
MY OLDEST WAS DIAGNOSED WITH
MULTIPLE SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESSES KAISER OFFERED US A
FEW. CENTERS HOME. IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN- SUICIDAL
IDEATIONS GRILLER WITH. KAISER.
FOR THERAPY AND- WE WERE TOLD
THERE WERE NO THERE AVAIL. SINCE
SHE HAS TRIED TO KILL HERSELF
TWICE. TWICE HE'S BEEN ON LIFE
SUPPORT THE ICU. IN THE LAST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS SHE'S BEEN
HOSPITALIZED SIX TIMES. AND
EVERY TIME SHE IS DISCHARGED
WITH NO FOLLOW UP OR AFTERCARE.
IN SPITE OF THE SEVERITY OF HER
MENTAL ILLNESS. AND REPEATED IT
FOR SERVICES KAISER HAS INFORMED
US THAT THEY HAVE NO AVAILABLE
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS ON
STAFF AND THEY'RE CONTRACTED
THERAPISTS ARE BOOKED SOLID.
THEIR TREATMENT PROGRAMS HAVE
STAGNANT WAIT LISTS AND HER
KAISER PSYCHIATRIST IS PART TIME
AND ONLY COMES IN ON MONDAYS SO
IT TAKES MONTHS FOR US TO GET AN
APPOINTMENT.THIS IS NOT PARITY
. BEEN LUCKY. BATRES ALIVE BUT I
DON'T KNOW HOW LONG I'LL BE ABLE
TO SAY THAT SHE STILL NEEDS HELP
AND WE STILL CAN'T GET IT. MUCH
LIKE THE COST. ANALYSIS FOR DID
WILL DEVELOPING THE DEADLY
PENTAHO. AS THE FINE LEVELS ARE
RIGHT NOW IT IS CHEAPER FOR
KAISER TO PAY ANTIQUATED FINES
THAN TO DO WHAT THEY ARE LEGALLY
REQUIRED TO DO. PSA'S TELL ME TO
GET I NEED IT AND WE'RE TRYING
WE HAVE BEEN FOR YEARS WITH THIS
BILL YOU'LL BE PUSHING KAISER TO
DO WHAT THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
DOING ALL ALONG. PROVIDING THAT
CARE. INCREASE FINES WON'T FIX
EVERYTHING BUT IT MIGHT GIVE MY
DAUGHTER AND THOUSANDS OF
OTHERS. THE CARE NEEDED TO HAVE
A HAPPY HEALTHY FUTURE INSTEAD
OF ENDING UP AS SAD AND ALL TOO
COMMON STATISTIC. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
SHARING YOUR FAMILY STORY- NOW
BRING UP DIANA DOUGLAS FROM
HEALTHAXIS. YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
PLUS. THANK YOU AND GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS DIANA DOUGLAS ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA
STATEWIDE HEALTH CARE CONSUMER
ADVOCACY COALITION WE ARE
PLEASED TO SPONSOR SB EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT WHICH WILL ENSURE
HEALTH PLANS ARE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE STRONG
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
CALIFORNIANS RELY UPON. THESE
PROTECTIONS INCLUDE ACCESS TO
BASIC HEALTHCARE SERVICES TIMELY
ACCESS TO CARE LANGUAGE AT.
PENDANT MEDICAL REVIEW.
PROCESSES FOR FILING GRIEVANCES.
DAMAGE THESE PROTECTIONS RELY IN
THE STRONG FRAMEWORK OF CIVIL
AND ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES AND
CORRECTIVE ACTION PLANS TO HOLD
PLANS ACCOUNTABLE. HOWEVER THERE
WERE STANDARDS HAVE BEEN UPDATED
MANY TIMES THE PENALTIES
THEMSELVES HAVE RARELY IF EVER
BUT IT. THE BASIC CIVIL. SOME OF
TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED HAS NOT BEEN
UPDATED SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE. MANY ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTIES WHICH REPRESENT THE
VAST MAJORITY OF PENALTIES
IMPOSED TO REMAIN FIXED FOR
DECADES. PENALTIES ARE STAGNATED
FOR DECADES HEALTH PLAN TO
BECOME ACCUSTOMED TO TREATING
FINES AS IT WAS ANOTHER COST OF
DOING BUSINESS. WHEN IT'S MORE
COST EFFECTIVE TO JUST PAY THE
VIOLATIONS RATHER THAN PROVIDE
PROPER CARE. CONSUMERS PAY THE
PRICE WITH THE LAID CARE DENIED
SERVICES IN GRIEVANCES GONE
UNRESOLVED FOR YEARS. SB EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT WILL UPDATE
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES BY
MULTIPLYING THE CURRENT AMOUNTS
BUT FOR. MOST DAMAGE THE
PENALTIES ARE MINISTRY DEVON
THESE AMOUNTS OF REMAIN THE SAME
FOR SEVERAL DECADES. AND CIVIL
PENALTIES WHICH HAVE BEEN CAPPED
AT FIVE HUNDRED FOR ALMOST FIFTY
YEARS. WOULD BE INCREASED TO A
MINIMUM OF TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND.
THIS REPRESENTS INCREASES IN
INFLATION AND SO ON YOUR
PREMIUMS IN COSTS WHICH OF FAR
OUT PACED INFLATION. S. FTA WILL
ALSO ENSURE THAT S. HEALTHCARE
PREMIUMS AND OUT OF POCKET COSTS
INCREASED. PENALTIES WILL
INCREASE COMMENSURATELY. AND
FINALLY S. B. FIFTY EIGHT WILL
ADD ADDITIONAL RELEVANT FACTORS
THAT MIGHT BE CONSIDERED FOR
PURPOSES OF DETERMINING PENALTY
AMOUNTS. FOR EXAMPLE INCLUDING
THE FULL FINANCIAL STATUS OF THE
HEALTH PLAN IN VIOLATION. AND
HOW MUCH MONEY THE PLAN SAVED BY
DENYING THE CARE. WE THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR SUGGESTIONS
ON- THANKS WE'RE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HOW TO SPECIFY- HOW OVER
THE PENALTY INCREASES IT WOULD
SPECIFICALLY BE TIED TO PLAN
INCREASES IT ALSO. THE BEST FOR
THANKS INSTEAD HE COMES FOR
FINANCIAL LOSSES AND LOOK FOR
THE CONTINUING CONVERSATIONS.
WHERE PROP PLANES BE EIGHT FIFTY
EIGHT ACTUALLY. THANK YOU. Q.
FIND OUT. IN SUPPORT OF EIGHT
FIFTY EIGHT AM ROOM TO HUNDRED.
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION. FOR
THANK YOU TIM MADDEN REPRESENT
THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF THE
AMERICAN COLLEGE OF EMERGENCY
PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. SEE NO ONE ELSE COMING UP TO
THE MICROPHONE- WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO TELECONFERENCE ONE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHO SHOULD TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT.
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION. M.
FOR THOSE ON THE PHONE LINES IF
YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. EIGHT FIFTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO EIGHT FIFTY
EIGHT. THIRTY EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT
WE DID A DIFFERENT ONE ZERO FOR
SUPPORT. AT THE TIME WE DO WELL
FIVE IN OUR QUEUE. OKAY START
WITH LINE ONE FORTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CARE AND MEMBERS OF
HIS JENNIFER MALLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
CALLING IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS THANK YOU. TEXAS
NUMBER ONE OH NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NUMBER ONE SEVENTY FOUR. ANDREA
RIVERA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC HEALTH
NETWORK SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY SIX. NUMBER ONE SEVEN
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE NUMBER
ONE SEVENTY. FISHERMEN MEMBERS
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF PSYCHIATRISTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU NOT
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. THANKS IS ONE FORTY
FIVE. ONE OF MY HEARING YES WE
CAN- YOU- I WOULD SUPPORT THAT
IF THE WARNING WAS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT OKAY ACTION CALLING
THE COUNTY. OKAY SO USUALLY
SUPPORT THANK YOU. SIX WITNESS.
AND AGAIN IF YOU'RE IN SUPPORT
OF SB EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THIS IS YOUR AT
THE TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
FOR THAT MOVE ONTO OPPOSITE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT- LEAD WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION IS NEXT LOUISA'S
FROM THE KALFUS AS IT HEALTH
PLANS. WELL SINCE THEY HAD TO IN
THE CITY WILL AFFORD YOU UP THE-
AND EXCELLING OF THESE ANTI TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS NICK LOUISE US ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH PLANS AND- HOW WE ARE
REGRETTABLY IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO SB EIGHT FIFTY. EIGHT- BUT
WILL RAISE HELP COSTS- BY MASS.
INCREASING PENALTIES ON HEALTH
PLANS AND CREATING A NEW PENALTY
STRUCTURE. OUR MEMBERS- AGAIN
THE BILL EXPONENTIALLY INCREASES
PENALTIES ON OUR MEMBERS IN
THERE FOR DIFFERENCE MORE MORE
RESOURCES AWAY FROM DIRECT
PATIENT CARE. AND OUR VIEW KIND
OF UNDERMINES THE NATURE AND
CHARACTER OF THE REGULATORY
PROCESS. WE DO DISAGREE WITH THE
PREMISE OF THIS BILL THAT
CREATING MORE AND MORE-
PENALTIES ON HEALTH PLANS AND
MAKING THE SYSTEM MORE PUNITIVE
. SOME IMPRO CARE AND HEALTH
SYSTEM. WE NEED TO OUT THAT- CAL
HEALTH PLANS ALREADY HEAVY
REGULATED I'M UNDER THE KNOX
KEEN ACT- THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT HAS VERY WIDE
AUTHORITY. TO LEVY DUTIES FROM
OUR MEMBERS- THEY CAN ALSO
REVOKE THE LICENSE OF HEALTH
PLAN THAT'S IN VIOLATION OF THE
ACT. AND IN MANY CASES WILL
ISSUE CORRECT ACTION PLANS. PART
OF THEIR- IF PERSON MECHANISM-
AND YOU KNOW WE WILL SAVE YOU
KNOW DESPITE WHAT HAS BEEN
ARGUED AS LIMITATIONS IN
EXISTING LAW. THE DEPARTMENT HAS
NOT BEEN SHY ABOUT LIVING PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT PENALTIES. I'M ON
OUR MEMBERS- IN RECENT YEARS- SO
DO YOU KNOW WHAT IS THIS BILL DO
BASICALLY WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS
IT COMPLETELY DELETE THE
LIMITATION ON CIVIL PENALTIES IN
THE EXISTING. LAW AND REPLACES
IT WITH THE CEILING SO- I'M
SORRY SENIOR CITIZEN CAN REVERSE
IT ELIMINATES THE CEILING AND
REPLACES IT WITH THE FLOOR THAT
IS TEN TIMES THE AMOUNT OF THE
CEILING. SO- YOU KNOW UNDER THIS
BILL THERE WOULD BE NO NO LIMIT
THAT WE CAN SEE- ON THE AMOUNT
OF CIVIL PENALTIES- THAT COULD
BE- LEVIED ON OUR HEALTH PLAN SO
YOU KNOW THIS IS A WHOPPING
INCREASE BY A FACTOR OF TEN AS
AS WAS PREVIOUSLY- TESTIFIED TO.
IT WOULD MAKE. THE AMOUNTS OF
OTHER SPECIFIED CIVIL TO IMPEDE
MINISTRY TO PENALTIES AND IT
WOULD- AD IN IT IN ANNUAL
INFLATOR- ON TOP OF THAT SO WE
THINK THIS IS- VERY VERY VERY
PUNITIVE A NEW STRUCTURE ON OUR
MEMBERS. KNOW FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE AND YOU KNOW IN
TALKING TO OUR MEMBERS ABOUT
THIS BILL. THE GOAL OF
REGULATORY ENFORCEMENT SHOULD
REALLY BE JUST CORRECTS CONDUCT
WHEN WARRANTED- YOU KNOW WE
ULTIMATELY BELIEVE THAT KIND OF
A PROCESS COOPERATIVE PROCESS
WITH THE DEPARTMENT LEAVES. AT
LEAST IMPROVE CARE- AND ENSURE A
PROVIDERS ARE ARE IN PATIENTS
ARE FOR THEIR RIGHTS UNDER THE
LAW- INCREASING PENALTIES IN THE
AMOUNT ESTABLISHED BY THIS BILL.
APPEARS TO BE PURELY PUNITIVE IN
NATURE- AND IN ALL HONESTY WE
ALSO THINK IT'LL BACKFIRE. WHAT
IT DOES IT PITS PLANS. PART
MAINTENANCE AND INSTEAD OF
FINDING COOPERATIVE SOLUTIONS TO
ISSUES. TO SEE MORE OF A
NEGATIVE STANCE- IN THE IN A
FIGHTING POSITION IF YOU WILL-
WITH REGULATOR. SO. THIS WAS IT
WAS REAL THE BILL ABOUT YOU KNOW
. FIND THAT WERE ESTABLISHED
NINETEEN I THINK YOU KNOW THAT A
DIFFERENCE POINT TO COME WIPE
OUT THE LIMITS ON CIVIL
PENALTIES- AND REPLACING IT WITH
THE FLOOR THAT IS TEN TIMES THE
AMOUNT OF THE CURRENT CURRENT
LIMIT- WHICH AS I SATED YOU
KNOW THE REGULATORS HAVEN'T BEEN
SHY IN OF EXPRESSED. A WIDE
LATITUDE IN IN LIVING PENALTIES
FAR IN EXCESS. OF WHAT'S WHAT'S
BEEN TESTIFIED TO SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME AND AGAIN WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL. I THANK YOU
. IT WILL NOW TAKE ON ANY.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB A
FIFTY EIGHT YEAR ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED. CENELEC APPROACHING
MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO
SHOULD TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT. FOR THOSE
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO BE A FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. IN ONE
ZERO PROPOSITIONS. IT WILL FIRST
GO TO LINE ONE SEVENTY EIGHT.
THIS CARE MEMBERS JOHN WHEN
YOU'RE ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS WOULD
JUST LIKE TO ALIGN OUR COMMENTS
WITH CAT AND- I RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANKS THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NEXT TO BE NUMBER ONE
FORTY FIVE. APPEARING YES YES TO
UNITY SELF A GREAT CHURCH
REMEMBERED THE STORY- I'M JUST
LOOKING FOR SOMETHING OUT THERE
REALLY QUICK PLEASE PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF AND YOUR
NAME. AND TO PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF TO LOOK WHAT'S YOUR
NAME. OKAY NEXT WITNESS THAN.
THANKS FOR THE NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY SIX. ONE SEVEN SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF NAME
WORKSTATION POSITION. YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU. THEN ONCE AGAIN LATEST
JOB IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. THIS IS YOUR THE TIME WE HAVE
NO ONE ELSE IN OUR QUEUE THANK
YOU- WHEN THEY'LL BRING IT BACK
TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM. THE MEMBERS. OKAY
IT'S BEEN- BY SEVERAL AMOUNT.
THE OTHER OKAY SEE NO ONE WITH
THE QUESTION OF YES I GONZALEZ
OUR COUNTRY. AS I'VE MOVED ABOUT
- OKAY ALL RIGHT. OKAY TO
MOTIONS AND OUTSIDE BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BY SARAH. I THINK CEREMONY
- DOES WELL SELL ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. RIGHT
ASSENAGON- SIR WIENER AYE I DO
SO THANK YOU CAN THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE I KNOW THAT YOU'RE-
WORKING WITH YOU IN THE
SPONSORS. FORD AND PERHAPS- HE
CAN YOU TELL ME ABOUT THE VISION
SAID WELL GEE YOU KNOW WE'RE
ACTUALLY NOT ONLY WE ARE
INCREASING THE FINES- WERE YOUR
YOUR TO CHANGING STRUCTURE OF
THE- LET'S SEE SAID GALGIANI A-
CEILING UNTIL FLOOR SO DO YOU DO
IT WOULD YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SEARCH THAT. YET WE ARE CHANGING
THE STRUCTURE I THINK LONG PAST
DUE TO CHANGE THE STRUCTURE THIS
WAS A STRUCTURE TO CREATE A- IT
. IT TO. AND IT'S NOT WORKING.
THAT WAY ALL AND AGAIN I WANT TO
BE VERY CLEAR WE'RE NOT SAYING
ALL THE- ARE. BAD ALL THE TIME
NOT TRUE BUT THERE ARE ENOUGH
THINGS. AND WE KNOW THAT AND SO
ERROR. FOR MENTAL HEALTH. THERE
THERE ARE A LOT OF PROBLEMS IN
TERMS OF COVERAGE BEING. EITHER
EXPLICITLY OR EFFECTIVELY. HI
I'D- AND THERE HAS TO BE BETTER
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THE CURRENT
SYSTEM. DOES NOT CREATE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND IF YOU LOOK
AT YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND THEIR
APPREHENSION THAT YOU'RE NOW
CREATING A FLOOR. BUT THAT WHAT
THAT MEANS IS IT'S ENFORCEMENT
FLEXIBILITY. TO ACTUALLY IMPOSE
A PENALTY THAT CORRESPONDS TO.
YOUR AND- IT'S JUST NOT REGIS IT
IS AND HOW MUCH HARM HAS BEEN
AFFLICTED WITH A SMALL AMOUNT.
OR A LARGE AMOUNT- AND- SO WE
SHOULD HAVE THAT A MINISTER
FLEXIBILITY AND RESPECTFULLY-
THE DIMENSI. YOU WHATEVER
CRITICISMS CAN LAW TO T. BUT
HE'S IS NOT ONE OF THEM- DAMAGE
SHE HAS. FRANKLY IN MY VIEW RED
IS A- TO REALLY GO AFTER SOME OF
THE AND MOST EGREGIOUS ACTIONS
THERE BEEN SOME EXAMPLES- BUT
I'M UNAWARE OF ANY LICENSE
SUSPENDED REVOKED A HEALTH PLAN-
AND NOR SHOULD WE BE ENCOURAGING
THAT A FIGHT IS MUCH BETTER THAN
REVOKING. LICENSE WHERE THAT'S
LIKE A NUCLEAR OPTION RIGHT OUT
OF THE ABSOLUTE WORST
CIRCUMSTANCES. AND SO YES I DO
THINK PARKING SHOULD HAVE A LOT
OF FLEXIBILITY AND THIS BILL
WILL CREATE THE POSSIBILITY.
HERE WE UNDERSTAND- HOPE YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE TO
OPPOSITION IN THE THINGS FOR
AGAIN APPRECIATE IT. AND SO- AND
FEW OF US INTO FOR YOUR- NUMBER
ASTRONOMICAL ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
. SO THE MOTIONS TO PAY ROOF TO
THE CAN ON JUDICIARY BEEN
SECONDED BY CENTERS MOUNT AND
SALAS- I CONSULT PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. PAN HAND I MELENDEZ EGGMAN
EGGMAN AND SALAS CONSULT ON IT
GROUP OF- LEYVA LIMA I'VE MON I
ROTH I FOUGHT THE. WE. THE
BILL'S CURRENTLY SIXTY HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN ABSENT THANK YOU RIGHT
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO AYE NUMBER
FOR S. B. NINE TWO PLACE LIMÓN
THE. THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO START OFF BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
PRECISION MEDICINE IS IMPROVING
PATIENT OUTCOMES BY USING THEIR
OWN GENES OR PROTEINS BIOMARKERS
TO PREVENT DIAGNOSE AND TREAT
DISEASES. BIOMARKER TESTING CAN
BE PERFORMED FOR CANCER
INCLUDING PROSTATE OVARIAN
COLLECTOR. FOR BREAST AND LUNG
CANCERS ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE
RHEUMATOID ARTHRITIS TYPE TWO
DIABETES AND OTHER CONDITIONS.
ACCORDING TO ANALYSIS BIOMARKER
TESTING IS BROADLY COVERED BY
CALIFORNIA'S ESSENTIAL HEALTH
BENEFITS PLAN THEREFORE THIS
BILL WOULD NOT REQUIRE COVERAGE
OF A NEW STATE BENEFIT MANDATES.
HOWEVER IN PRACTICE PATIENTS
CONTINUE FEEDING BARRIERS IN
ACCESSING THIS TESTING. TWENTY
ONE SIR BY THE AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY SOCIETY 66% OF ONCOLOGY-PROVIDERS REPORTED THAT
INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR BIOMARKER
TESTING AS A BARRIER TO
BIOMARKER TESTING. SB NINE
TWELVE MAKES NECESSARY CHANGES
IN THE LAW TO CLARIFY THAT
HEALTH PLANS HEALTH INSURANCE
POLICIES AND THE MEDICARE HELP
PROGRAM ARE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
COVERAGE FORBIOMARKER TESTING.
SB NINE TWELVE WILL IMPROVE
ACCESS TO BIOMARKER TESTING
ENSURING PATIENTS RECEIVE THE
RIGHT TREATMENT AT THE RIGHT
TIME. TIME CHARACTERS IDLE FOR
PATIENTS TO EASE- DOWN DISEASE
RECURRENCE OR PROGRESSION AND
LEAD BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE.
ACTUALLY TARGETED. FRIEDMAN
REDUCE COSTS BY CAN PAGE TO THE
AFFECT TREATMENTS. TO UP HERE
WITH US TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS DR SCOTT LIPPMAN OF THE
UC CANCER CONSORTIUM AND THAT WE
HAVE IN PERSON PETER. TO PROVIDE
UP A PATIENT'S PERSON ON BEHALF
OF THE UC DAVIS MEDICAL SCHOOL
OF MEDICINE. I THANK YOU CENTER
LIMÓN SO WILL ABOUT TWO OR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
TWELVE WILL BEGIN WITH SCOTT
BULLETIN IS OFF THE LAW. LEAPING
DOCKED SCOTT LIPPMAN ON THE YOU
HAVE TO MINUTES- TO GO OVER TO
TIME WE FROM THE NEXT WITNESS.
I'LL GIVE YOU TWO MEN OF THE L.
TWENTY TWO MINUTES. SO IF YOU
WANT THE GO AHEAD GET. DR LIPMAN. THANK YOU THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA IS PLEASED TO PARTNER
WITH ACS CAN. A CO SPONSOR SB
NINE TWELVE. WE THANK SENATOR
LAMONT FOR HER WORK CHAMPION
THIS IMPORTANT PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR
BIOMARKER TESTING FOR ALL
DISEASES BUT TODAY I WILL SPEAK
THE BIOMARKER TESTING IN CANCER
BECAUSE THIS IS THE AREA I KNOW
BEST. IN CANCER BIOMARKER
TESTING IS CRITICAL IN MANY
STEPS OF THE PATIENT'S CARE.
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT CANCER
TREATMENT BIOMARKER TESTING IS
THE FIRST OF TWO STEPS WE TAKE
TO MATCH PATIENTS TUMOR. ASIAN
THERAPY THE TESTING OF TUMOR
TISSUE OR BLOOD ALLOWS US TO
LOOK AT THE TUMOR BIOLOGY AND
IT'S VULNERABILITIES AND MAP TO
THE RIGHT TREATMENT FOR THE
PATIENT WE KNOW THAT PATIENTS TO
RECEIVE THESE TARGETED THERAPIES
CLEARLY PROVE SURVIVE AND
OUTCOMES. ANOTHER ASPECT OF
PROTECTING IT IS DETERMINED WHAT
DRUGS WON'T WORK FOR A PATIENT'S
TUMOR. IT HAD NEXT CANCERS WHICH
IS WHAT I PRIMARILY SEE IN MY
CLINIC IT'S A TYPE OF TUMOR THAT
WILL NOT RESPOND TO
IMMUNOTHERAPY. AND CAN IDENTIFY
THIS TYPE OF MARKET TESTING THEN
THE PATIENT CAN RECEIVE THE
RIGHT TREATMENT. AVOIDING
UNNECESSARY TOXICITY AND COST.
FOR MANY OF THESE PATIENTS TIME
IS OF THE ESSENCE. MY LAST POINT
IS THAT THERE ARE STARK. THIRTY
IN ACCESS TO BUY MARKET TESTING
. LUNG CANCER THE POSTER CHILD
FOR BIOMARKER TESTING AND
PRECISION THERAPY IN CANCER
RECENT DATA SHOW THAT ONLY 50%
OF AMERICAN PATIENTS AT FTA
RECOMMENDED BY MARKET TESTING
DONE. ONLY 39% OF BLACK PATIENTS
AND ONLY 39% OF LOW SOCIO
ECONOMIC STATUS PATIENTS
RECEIVED THIS RECOMMENDED BY
MARKET TEST. ENSURING THAT ALL
RECEIVE INSURANCE COVERAGE FOR
BIOMARKER TESTING WILL HELP TO
COME SOME OF THESE BARRIERS TO
ACCESS AND REDUCE HEALTH
DISPARITIES. I ENCOURAGE YOU TO
PLEASE VOTE HI ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU- WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
DR PETER KALA- ALL RIGHT IF YOU
CAN PLEASE COME TO THE
MICROPHONE YOU HAVE A MINUTE AND
FORTY NINE SECONDS- I'M A TALK
FEST THAT. MY NAME IS PETER
CALLA I'M A STAGE FOUR
ESOPHAGEAL CANCER SURVIVOR I WAS
THERE DIAGNOSED IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN AND GIVEN FIVE TO SIX
MONTHS TO LIVE. AS A MEDICAL
SCHOOL- IN PHYSIOLOGY AT THE UC
DAVIS SCHOOL OF MEDICINE I NEW
ADVANCES WERE TAKING PLACE BY
THE WEEK GET ONTHLY AND
TREATMENT AND- TESTING. SO I
IMMEDIATELY SENT MY- BIOPSY
OFFERED GENOMIC AND BIOMARKER
ANALYSIS. IN THE MEANTIME I
BEGAN CONVENTIONAL THERAPY THIS
WAS NO PICNIC I MEAN THERE WERE
MANY DAYS I WOKE AND WONDERED IF
IT WAS GOING TO BE MY LAST DAY
ON EARTH. BUT EVEN THOUGH I
COULDN'T GET THE TARGETED
THERAPY AT THAT TIME BECAUSE IT
WASN'T APPROVED. JUST KNOWING
THAT THERE WAS A TARGET GAVE ME
HOPE AND THAT'S SOMETHING IN
VERY SHORT SUPPLY AMONG CANCER
PATIENTS. I STARTED SEARCHING
FOR CLINICAL TRIALS AND I RAN
INTO A LOT OF ROAD BLOCKS BUT I
WAS DETERMINED IN MY ACT I'M
COLLEGES EDWARD KIM FINALLY SNAG
ME A SLOT IN THE ONLY SLOT
AVAILABLE IN THE NATION WIDE
TRIAL. MY SCANS STARTED IT'S
STAGE FOUR METASTATIC AFTER THE
SECOND TREATMENT WITH THE
TARGETED THERAPY THE SCANS WERE
DEEMED NORMAL OR NEARLY NORMAL
AFTER THE FOURTH TREATMENT IT
WORK WEEKLY NORMAL I'VE BEEN OFF
THEIR A BE ALL TOGETHER SINCE
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. I GO BACK FOR
SCANS ALL THE TIME BECAUSE THIS
IS NOT SUPPOSED TO BE A CURABLE
CANCER. I THINK IT'S BRACKET
LISTS AND I FEEL TRULY BROUGHT
BLESSED I'LL HUGE DEBT OF
GRATITUDE TO THE UNIVERSE AND
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE AS A PATIENT
ADVOCATE TODAY I WANT OTHER.
CANCER PATIENTS TO HAVE ACCESS
TO THE SAME MODERN PRECISION
CARE THAT I RECEIVED. I WASN'T
SURE MY INSURANCE WAS GOING TO
COVER THE SIX THOUSAND DOLLAR
COST FOR THAT MATTER CAN IN
GENOMICS ANALYSIS BUT I HAD THE
MEANS THAT I WOULD COULD AFFORD
TO TAKE THAT GAMBLE AS A-
PATIENT ADVOCATE. PEOPLE I TALK
TO DON'T HAVE THAT AND THEY'RE
UNABLE TO ACCESS THAT HIGH
QUALITY CHARACTER MATHIS SHOULD
WRAP UP YOUR OVERTIME YOUR
OVERTIME OKAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOU TO SUPPORT BILL SB. NINE
TWELVE SO THAT MORE CALIFORNIA
PATIENTS CAN BENEFIT FROM THIS
IMPORTANT TESTING. THANK YOU AND
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR SHARING
YOUR STORY WITH US YEAH PERSONAL
SORY THANK YOU. RIGHT WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
TWELVE- WILL BEGIN HERE ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED. PLEASE COME OF
MICROPHONE NAME WORKSTATION
DECISION. BRENT SPENCER ABOUT
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
SUFFICIENT NINE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. BRENDAN MARTY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. FIELDING
GRIEVES A BY A CALM CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
STEVEN SCHULTZ WITH ARTHRITIS
FOUNDATION SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JENNIFER SNYDER BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LIFE SCIENCES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
. HELLO REJECT HILLARY G.
GOVERNOR ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY CANCER
ACTION NETWORK CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MACROCYTIC FROM NATIONAL MEDICAL
CENTER IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. SARAH HICKEL AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA OFFICE
OF THE PRESIDENT CO SPONSOR AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AC NO ONE
ELSE COMING BEFORE THE FRONT
MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
TWELVE NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITIONS. THE BILL ON THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE TWELVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. IN ONE
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. ENTER THIS
TIME WE DO ABOUT THIRTEEN IN THE
QUEUE OKAY YOUR NAME WAS ASIAN
POSITION. THE SERVER NUMBER ONE
SEVENTY SIX. OKAY NUMBER ONE
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE
MOVED TO NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
SEVEN. MY AND HER ON BEHALF OF
THE CHILDREN SPECIALTY CARE
COALITION AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. TEXAS ONE FIFTEEN. NUMBER ONE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE NUMBER TWO OH FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHURCH MEMBERS
OFFERED A MEDINA- BEHALF OF
CEDAR SINAI MEDICAL CENTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANKS TO NUMBER ONE SEVENTY
FIVE. CARE AND MEMBERS OF THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
STEVE HORN DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENTAL RELATIONS FOR I CAN
INTERNATIONAL CANCER ADVOCACY
NETWORK EXPRESSING THEIR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR S. B. NINE ONE TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NUMBER ONE SIXTY SEVEN
. HELLO MY NAME IS KATE COLEMAN
AND I AM A CANCER SURVIVOR FROM
ENCINITAS CALIFORNIA AND I
SUPPORT FIFTY NINE ONE Q. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NUMBER ONE
SIXTY TWO. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
MEMBERS MY NAME IS CHRISTY FOR A
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CLINICAL
LABORATORIES SUFFICIENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE ONE TWO.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NUMBER
ONE NINETY SEVEN. HI THIS IS
KIRTI WALLER BET ON BEHALF OF BE
THE MATCH THE NATIONAL MARROW
DONOR PROGRAM IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU X.
WITH THIS. ONE ONE NINETY ONE.
HI THIS IS REBECCA BIRCH AND- ON
BEHALF OF SUSAN G. KOMEN IN
SUPPORT OF NINE ONE TWO THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
NUMBER NINETY ONE. HI THIS IS
NICOLE SHEEHAN GLOBAL COLON
CANCER IS THE CASE THEN IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
ONE ONE SEVENTY ONE. INTEREST
PEOPLE THE WORLD PATIENT
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. ONE ONE NINETY
EIGHT. ALIMENTARIA TRIAGE CANCER
URGING SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NUMBER ONE FIFTEEN.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
ALEX HARM ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. LINE. ONE
NINETY NINE. CAROLINE BEALE
HUNTER ON BEHALF OF ADVAMED IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. X. IS
TWO OH NINE. THE CURRENT MEMBERS
PRODUCT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOCIETY COLLEGES
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
IT AGAIN IF YOU LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE TWELVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. THIS YEAR THE
TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR
QUEUE I THANK YOU MODERATOR WILL
MOVE NOW TO THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE TO LEAVE
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO BE
TESTIFYING- WE HAVE STEPHANIE
WATKINS FROM THE SENSATION
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN NYC
LOUISA'S FROM CALIFORNIA SAYS HE
TO HELP PLANS BOTH HERE IN
PERON SO BEGIN WITH STEPHANIE
WALK INS. WELCOME MISTER CARE
MEMBERS STEPHANIE WATKINS ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES. FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE WOULD LIKE TO THINK
THE AUTHOR IN THE SPONSOR WE
MOST RECENTLY HAD A VERY
PRODUCTIVECONVERSATION ABOUT
THEIR OBJECTIVES. UNFORTUNATELY
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE CURRENT
BILL IN PRINT. WOULD LIKE TO
PREFACE MY COMMENTS THOUGH WE DO
NOT SEE THIS IS AN ISSUE OF
COVERAGE. AS ILLUSTRATED IN THE
JOB INDEPENDENT ALICE'S ALL
ENROLLEES IN INSURANCE WITH
HEALTH INSURANCE SUBJECT TO SB
NINE TWELVE HAVE COVERAGE FOR
BIOMARKER TESTING. BY MEDICAL
AND SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE IS
DETERMINED TO BE MEDICALLY
NECESSARY. AS YOU NO BIOMARKER
TESTING IS A PROMISING FIELD AND
CERTAINLY USE. THE BENEFIT IS TO
SUPPORT MEDICAL LITERATURE. THAT
BEING SAID. IT USES REQUIRES
CAREFUL OVERSIGHT IN
CONSIDERATION WHEN DETERMINING
ITS APPROPRIATENESS THE CONCERN
OUR MEMBERS HAVE SHARED DEAL
PRIMARILY WITH THE VIEW THAT
NINE TWELVE COULD INCLUDE
COVERAGE FOR TESTING THAT IS
BEYOND THE CURRENT STANDARD.
CARE HELP. INSURANCE ENSURE THAT
PATIENTS THE CARD. THE TAP THE
PRO. OF THE- IS BEING ORDERED.
BY MY- TESTING IS A- CATEGORY.
INCLUDES THE TEST. STAND UPS
INCLUDES OUR THAT ARE CLASSIFIED
EXPERIMENTAL. MANY TESTING. A
CREATED LARGE PANELS TESTS ARE
OFTEN TO BECAUSE THE SINGLE TEST
IS REALLY ALL THAT IS MEDICALLY
NECESSARY. YOUR CONCERN THE AB
NINE TWELVE IS CURRENTLY
DROPPED. TESTING WHICH COULD
SWAY SOME POTENTIAL HARM TO THE
SYSTEM. AGAIN WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS FOR THEIR WILLINGNESS
TO. SPEAK WITH US AND TO SHARE
THEIR THOUGHTS GOING FORWARD WE
LOOK FORWARD TO OF THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD TODAY TO CONTINUE
THIS CONVERSATION. THANK YOU.
LOUISA'S WELCOME. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS- YOU KNOW
I'LL BE BRIEF I YOU KNOW GOD
NICK LOSES WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS- WE
AGREE WITH THE COMMENTS- BY THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM BACK LAKE
THE ONLY THING I WOULD ADD IS
THAT YOU KNOW LAST YEAR WE
WORKED COOPERATIVELY WITH THE
AUTHOR ON HER SB FIVE FIVE WHICH
I'M DEALT WITH THE SAME ISSUE A
WE WERE INITIALLY OPPOSED OF
THREE SOME DISCUSSION WE WERE
ABLE TO REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION
AFTER AMENDMENTS THAT BILL DOES
NOT GO INTO EFFECT UNTIL JULY
FIRST OF THIS YEAR SO IN ONE OF
THE REASONS OPPOSED TO THE BILL
IS- YOU KNOW WE'D LIKE TO SEE
VALLEY. FOUR ONE. READ IS A THE
ISSUE THIS ON BEFORE THE
ENACTMENT THE OFFICIAL ENACTMENT
OF SB FIVE THIRTY FIVE BUT AGAIN
OPEN TO DISCUSSIONS ON AND I
NEED A GOOD TRY TO ADDRESS SOME
OF THE LIMITATIONS THAT MIGHT BE
NECESSARY AS PART OF THE
LANGUAGE SO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. RIGHT NOT TAKE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
NINE TWELVE HEARING ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED. SEEN ON COMING UP
BEFORE THE MICROPHONE A
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO IS TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO SB NINE TWELVE
NAME ORGANIZATION A POSITION.
FOR THOSE IN OPPOSITION TO SB
NINE TWELVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
REALLY THERE ARE TWO IN OUR
QUEUE. START WITH NUMBER TWO
TWELVE. HELLO. PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF WHAT WE CAN HEAR YOU.
THE. YOU LOOK. OKAY THIS IS FOR
S. B. NINE TWELVE. NINETY WELL
YES. NINE OKAY WE CAN HEAR YOU-
ARE YOU HERE TO TESTIFY ON S. B.
NINE TWELVE PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF. NINE FOUR. I CAN FOR
MIND TEAM ACTUALLY ACTUALLY A
STAR REVIEW IF YOU DON'T MIND
SAYING IT I MISSED BY NOT LOCAL
LAST TIME MOST OF THE TIME
THOUGH YEP WITH BESET OF LUCK
PUBLISHED LAST ALMOST AS WHICH-
IT AROUND WITH THE BILL. IT
COULD YOU UP FOR YOUR RIGHTS
DIVISION I WAS IN FAVOR. GOOD
ASK YES. OKAY THANK YOU CENTER.
**** OKAY NEXT WE GO NUMBER
NINETY SIX. MISTER CAREY MEMBERS
JOHN YOU'RE ON THE OF HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS JUST LIKE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS OF CAPEN
APPLICANT ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED. THANK YOU. X. WITNESS.
AND AGAIN HERE IN OPPOSITION TO
THE SP NINE TWELVE THIS PRESS
ONE ZERO. THIS IS YOUR AT THIS
TIME WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN OUR
QUEUE OKAY THANK YOU MODERATE
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. NO ALL
RIGHT- SEEING NONE- SERVICE.
OKAY FOR TO MOVE FROM CENTER
GONZALEZ SO THE BILL'S BEEN
MOVED BY SECONDS ALSO THURMOND
FIRST OF ALL I THANKYOU FOR
WORKING WITH MY COMMITTEE STAFF-
WE DID TRY TO ADDRESS SETTING
SOME RECORDS EXPRESSED BY THE
OPPOSITION IN TERMS OF A
DEFINING THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
WE CAN USE FOR SCREENING TESTS
ARE APPRECIATE YOU WORKING WITH
US. CAN YOU TO WORK WITH THE
OPPOSITION AND PERHAPS YOU MIGHT
IN YOUR CLOTHES ALSO ADDRESS
THAT POINT MADE BY- THIS IS A
HEALTH PLANS ABOUT WHY WERE WE
DOING THIS BEFORE THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF YOUR PREVIOUS
. IF MILLION GONNA. FORTY BILL
TODAY AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR.
WITH WITH- MY- ON THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU IN YES. SO I JUST WANT
TO CLARIFY WELL THIS IS THE SAME
POLICY TOPIC IT'S NOT THE SAME
BILL. SO I THINK THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT SB AT. FIVE THIRTY
FIVE FROM LAST YEAR. WAS LIMITED
TO REMOVING PRIOR AUTHORIZATION
FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH STAGE THREE
AND FOUR CANCER. THIS BILL IS
ABOUT ENSURING COVERAGE FOR
TEST. THE ONE WITH PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION FOR SPECIFIC
STAGES OF CANCER THIS IS ABOUT.
THAT TEST THE BOTH BILLS ARE
DEFINITELY COMPLEMENTARY. I
THINK THEY WORK TOGETHER- THE
BUT- WE DON'T SEE ARE AT A YOU
KNOW AS AUTHOR I DON'T SEE A
CONFLICT IN RUNNING THIS BILL-
THAT AND ALSO HAVING. EXIST THAT
GOES INTO EFFECT JULY FIRST WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
OPPOSITION I THINK IT'S AS BEEN
STATED LAST YEAR. WE DEFINITELY
WORK GET TO A PLACE. THAT
WORKED- IN SO WE WILL CONTINUE
TO HAVE THE CONVERSATIONS- AND
MOVING FORWARD AND THANK YOU TO
THE COMMITTEE STAFF- THE FOR ALL
YOUR HELP- WITH. A ADVANCE IN
THIS BILL. THANK YOU SERVE
AMOUNTS OF THE- DEEP. AS AMENDED
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
APPROPRIATIONS AND SECOND I
SENATE GONZALEZ CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL HAND BY
HAND I'M A LONDON. MELINDA'S BY
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ AND
SALAS I GREW UP GROUP BY HER
TADO. LEYVA WE MOAN I LIMON I
ROTH ROTH FIVE RUBIO HI RUBIO
AYE WIENER WIENER AYE. THANKS TO
THOSE CURRENTLY NINE ZERO HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. RIGHT WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER SIX SB NINE
SEVENTY TWO BY SEVEN CENTER
GONZALEZ. WELCOME THANK YOU
MISTERCHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT SOME
REALLY YUMMY FOOD- BUT
SPECIFICALLY SENATE BILL NINE
SEVEN TWO WHICH WILL MODERNIZE
THE CALIFORNIA RETAIL CODE CAL
CODE IN ORDER TO INCLUDE SIDE
FOOD VENDORS AND BRING THOUSANDS
OF MIGRANT ENTREPRENEURS INTO A
MORE EQUITABLE AND RALPH WELL
REGULATED FOOD ECONOMY WHILE
ENHANCING CRITICAL HEALTH AND
FOOD SAFETY REGULATIONS I'LL BE
TAKING THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
TO REINSTATE THE CAPS IN THE
MICRO ENTERPRISE HOME KITCHEN
OPERATION THE MAKO AND COTTAGE
FOOD LAWS AND NARROW THE NON
CRIMINAL ADMINISTRATIVE FINES O
ONLY APPLY TO SIDEWALK FOOD
VENDORS AS WELL AS- ALL THE
IMMENSELY OUT IN THE MARKET BUT
I WANT TO. THANK YOU IN THE- FOR
WORKING WITH US. REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. SIDEWALK FOOD
VENDORS STABLE AND CAL COME. AND
ARE PART OF THE VIBRANT FOOD
CULTURE THAT MAKE THE DISTRICT
MY DISTRICT AND CALIFORNIA
UNIQUE UNDER THE EXISTING
RESTRICTIONS AND CAL CODE. IT IS
NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR FOOD
SIDEWALK FOOD VENDORS TO OBTAIN
A LOCAL HEALTH PERMITTED AND
FOOD. THESE VENDORS ARE FACED
WITH A COMPLEX COMBINATION IN
ACCESSIBLE PERMITTING.
PROCEDURES EXORBITANT COSTS
INCOMPATIBLE EQUIPMENT AND
DESIGN STANDARDS AND PUNITIVE
ENFORCEMENT MEASURES. AT NINE
SEVEN TWO WOULD ALSO DEFINES A
COMPACT MOBILE FOOD FACILITY TO
BETTER INCORPORATE SIDEWALK FOOD
VENDORS INTO CAL CODE AND MAKE
SMALL CHANGES TO THE MAKO. AND
THE CFO COTTAGE FOOD OPERATION
LAW TO ALLOW SIDEWALK FOOD
VENDORS TO ACCESS THESE EXISTING
PROGRAMS. SPECIFICALLY NINE
SEVEN TWO ADDRESSES THE
FOLLOWING ELIMINATING
UNNECESSARY EXPOSURE EXPENSIVE
EQUIPMENT REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS
THREE COMPARTMENT SINKS.
INCREASING THE DISCRETION OF
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO
APPROVE INNOVATIVE EQUIPMENT
DESIGNED FOR ALL MOBILE FOOD
FACILITIES. ENHANCING SITE SAFE
ON SITE FOOD PREPARATION OF NON
POTENTIALLY HAZARDOUS FOODS
INCLUDING HEALTHY FOOD LIKE
SLICED FRUIT AND VEGETABLES IN
PLACE THE MANUFACTURING OF SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE SIDEWALK FOOD
VENDING EQUIPMENT AT SCALE.
CRIMINAL PENALTIES ON CRIMINAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FINES FOR CODE
VIOLATIONS. THERE'S AN
UNFORTUNATE AND PREVALENT
ASSUMPTION THAT SIDEWALK VENDORS
ARE SOMEHOW LESS SAFER CARE LESS
FOR THE HEALTH OF THEIR
CUSTOMERS. THAN THAT OF OTHER
TYPES OF A RETAIL FOOD
ESTABLISHMENTS THIS MASK
MISCONCEPTION IS JUST NOT TRUE
AND IS NOT SUBSTANTIATED EITHER
BY ANY AVAILABLE DATA.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT TODAY I
HAVE TO INCREDIBLE FOR A STREET
FOOD VENDORS FROM BACK HOME IN
LOS ANGELES MY LEAN OVER AUTO.
AND SETS OUT OF ANY PASSWORD
HERE TO SHARE THE EXPERIENCE OF
SIDEWALK FOOD VENDORS WE ALSO
HAVE DOUG SMITH SUPERVISING
SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT PUBLIC
COUNSEL TO ASSIST WITH ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON SB NINE SEVEN TWO. OKAY THANK
YOU CENTER GONZALEZ AND- BOTH
YOUR WITNESSES ARE HERE
PHYSICALLY RIGHT YES THEY DO
THAT ON A LEAN OTHER AUTO SELECT
TO COME UP OKAY SO YES WE CAN
PLEASE. BEGIN WITH THAT MARLENE
ALVA RADO AND I UNDERSTAND YOU
HAVE AN INTERPRETER YES WE HAVE
YOU SO- YOUR TIME SO FEEL FREE
TO PAWS FOR INTERPRETER YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES BUT I COURSE WILL
GIVE ACT. THAT THAT THE
INTERPRETER DOESN'T COUNT
AGAINST YOUR TIME YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES. BUT IF YOU. INTERPRETER
CORPORATE THAT'S I CAN KEEP UP
KEEP UP KEEP UP WITH YOU AT TOWN
IF YOU WANT THAT HER BECAUSE
THIS IS. SENATOR PER WHICH IS
GONNA DO IS GIVE A FOR TEN. TO
MINUTES AND THEN I COME IN OKAY
HOWEVER YOU WANT TO DO IT OKAY
IF YOU WANT TO DO THE WHOLE TEST
TO USE TO THAT OKAY. ALL RIGHT.
FIVE WELCOME. ONE OF IN THE
NUMBER OF OUT OF THAT BUT I. SO
YOU NOT IN THE LIST HEADED.
MEDITATED SIEGEL SIMILAR. TODAY
AND- IT THANK THIS IS A SIGN. IN
THE- AND I DID WAS TO THIS. HOW
MUCH OF IN THE LOTUS. WHEN REST
OF THE IT'LL SEND A LOT SON OF
AN- TEAM.
MOB EITHER THAT I WANT. THEY GET
ABOUT THE MENTAL SIDE RULE. KICK
OFF A GELATIN ABOLISHED YET BUT
I DID UNLESS TACKLE MAY NOT BE
THAT MOMENT THAT COMMUNITIES. I
WILL NOT BUT SOMEHOW SHE LED
THIS DATA HE THEY PUT THAT. MUCH
SAID IN THAT THE OTHER SOMEBODY
THAT DID NOT. GET STYLE. AT A
LOTUS IT'LL BE A STEPPING DOWN
THE SLIPPERY THAT STILL. AND THE
MENTAL SIDE SHOULD AFFECT FIT ME
THOUGHT. FEDERAL ONLY SYNC UP A
WOMAN ARTICLE ME BACK I
SIMPLICITY MISTOOK US OF BENICIA
THE FEDERAL. MOTOR THAN ALSO THE
MOST OF THE NAY OWN SIX R.
PLUMAS. DAYSTAR BY THE END
MYSTERY BOYS THE- IF SOMEONE IS
THE PERFORMANCE SENATE NETTLES.
BEARISH IMPOSSIBLE AND THEY
DON'T BUT WE SUPPORT I MISS HOPE
BOTH PERSONAL A BUDDY. NO FOR
MOST BUT IT'S- AND HIM BUT THE
DENTAL NOT. THEIR ASSIGNED. NO I
AM KILEY TO. SET UP IT UP CAL
TEST TACOS PROPOSE THAT. I YET
IT THAT'LL IN CONTROL CARRIED
BUT I MEAN. BEDROCK ON TO SET UP
BY THE.
IT DOESN'T BUT THE GOVERNMENT
THEY- GET TANGLED THERE SAID
THEY HAD AT THAT ARE HOT. YES
THEY ARE WE ALSO THE QUESTION I
DO NOT CALL ME. GATHER CLOSE TO
THE COMO. ESPECIALLY THAT IN. DO
UP. WHICH I GRANT IN THE CANCER
IT DYING. RESTORING BULLETIN
ADAM BUT WE SAW BUT OUT TO I
MEAN VAN. SO ACTUALLY YOU CAN
JUST TRY TO KNOW THAT- ANYTIME
SHE CAN JEEZY'S WILL BE AGAINST
THE NEXT PERSON'S TIME SO IF YOU
WANT TO STOP OR SHE WANTS TO
FINISH WRAPPING UP THAT'S FINE.
OKAY OKAY A CRISIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN- I AM A
LEAN ABOUT ALTHOUGH A MOTHER OF
THREE AN IMMIGRANT FROM ON
BLUEGRASS INNER FRUIT AND HOT
DOG STREET VENDOR IN THE
HOLLYWOOD AREA FOR THE PAST
SIXTEEN YEARS LIKE MANY OTHER-VENDORS HI CELEBRATED WHEN THE
CITY OF LOS ANGELES LEGALIZE
STREET VENDING BUT AS A FOOD
VENDOR THE ROAD TO THE STATION
HAS BEEN TREATED CALL. ME OF US
FOOD VENDORS SPRINGS THE TRAUMA
OF THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT COMEY
WITH POLICE OFFICERS TO THROW
YOUR FOOD AND GIVE US CRIMINAL
TICKETS SOME PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
ARRESTED AND DEPORTED LIKE MY
CITY IN A REAL FROM SAMPOERNA
DINO WHO WAS ARRESTED FOR
STEALING A LOT THEY AND IT'S
STILL FIGHTING HER DEPORTATION.
THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT SAYS THEY
HAVE TO GET THEIR PERMITS B.
DON'T SEIZE IT IS ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE FOR A FOOD VENDOR TO
GET HELP PERMITS TODAY MANY OF
US HAVE ALREADY OBTAINED A
BUSINESS LICENSE WE ALRIGHT WE
ARE ALREADY PAYING OUR TAXES WE
ARE READY TO FORMALIZE OUR
BUSINESS BUT IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO
GET A PERMIT FROM MY GRILLED HOT
DOGS AT LEAST FAMOUS SPEAKING
RAP TAUGHT THE TAX. THERE IS NO
CURBSIDE CAR FOR GROWTH. DOGS
TACOS ARE PEOPLE SASS I TRIED TO
FIND A CURBSIDE GRILLED HOT
TUKAR. IT DOESN'T EXIST THE ONLY
ONES THAT EXIST COST THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN DON'T FIT ON
THE SIDEWALK SO WHAT ARE MY
OPTIONS. THE HEALTH DEPARTMENT
SAYS THEY HAVE TO REPAIR MY FOOD
AT HAD A COMMISSARY.
COMMISSARIES DON'T HAVE SPACE
MAYBE YOU CAN FIND A COMMISSARY
IN A FOR AN HOUR FROM YOUR
HOUSE. IT COST SIX HUNDRED TO A
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO RENT THAT
SPACE EVERY MONTH. SO THEY'RE
BASICALLY TELL ME THAT I HAVE TO
STOP WORKING. I AM PROUD TO COOK
A MEAL THAT IS RECOGNIZED AS THE
ELLIE SPECIALTY. I REALLY
APPRECIATE MY CLIENTS AND I WANT
TO CONTINUE TO BEEN MY DREAM. TO
HAVE MY OWN PERMIT. TO SELL HOT
DOGS LEGALLY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I WANNA BRING UP OUR NEXT
WITNESS- AS A CAESAR BEEN ADDED-
INTERNET IS. A PRONOUNCED CREW
OKAY. WELCOME ONE OF THAT IS IN
A LOTUS THE NUMBER IS A SET OF
ANYTHING EVEN THOUGH THERE WAS
FISCAL SINGLE MISSING CUANDO
THAN A SECOND. THIS FELLOW IN
THE IN THE BOOK RESILIENCY MENU
DISPLAY A KEEP IT UP IN THE LAST
COUPLE IN A PROPOSES YOUNG AS
SEVEN WITH AT THEM THEY THOSE
QUALITY OF POSSIBLY A SENATOR
MICHAEL ACTUALLY PEOPLE THAT
MONTH AND IT ON THE SHUTTLE'S
MEANS ONE. LESS ACADEMY IN
CONCERT SOME OF THE SINGLE
pHER BATTLE IS STILL BUT GIVEN UP
IN A SENATE COMMITTEE STUDENT
DISSIDENT. THIS CHEMICAL IN
CONTEMPT A LOCAL. A ON A PERSONA
. GIVE ME VALUABLE SHE MUSED.
LOGICAL YOU KNOW NOTHING DENTAL
MANY US BUT BY I MEAN IT LITTLE
BIT IS THAT RAN. FOR THE NEXT.
IDEA CLEAN IT OKAY GONNA COME
THAT WHAT'S BEEN GOT. A
BENEFICIAL. INDEPENDENTLY THAT'S
BECAUSE YOU THINK GIVEN THAT
SIMPLE WANT SO THEY ARE ONCE
THEY BECAUSE- ONE MAN'S. BUT
POLITICAL ABSOLUTELY SEE. NEVER. YEP IT'S EVEN MORE THE- I MEAN
IF YOU QUIT MONTHS. FOR THAT
SERVER SEVENTY THE- GET THE MOST
AND THE ARE GOING THIRD WEEK OF
WHOLE. WEEK OR SEEN AS THAT THE
WORLD NAME BE A- YEAH THE
WEATHER BUT I ABOUT EMUS WITH
WITH WITH. THE MICKEY BOARDMAN.
I MEAN A MONTH INCLUDING. YOU
CAN SET UP A LITTLE BIT I MEAN
SO WAS GREAT BECAUSE BECAUSE OF.
BATTLE MISTER COOPER ELEVEN SIX
ANOTHER PRO I MEAN. I THOUGHT NO
MATTER HOW DO YOU HAVE A THIS
OFFICE ENOUGH A I WHAT. BUT THE
SECOND SCHOOLS US THIRTY M. TO
THE PUESTO. UP IN THERE ONCE
THEY WERE LISTEN THAT THING
BECAUSE- SOLIS BILL THAT IS WILL
NO. ME THOSE.
AFTERNOON SENATORS MY NAME IS
SAYS THAT BENITEZ I'M IN OUR
OFFICE GOT VENDOR IN THE CITY OF
COMMERCE AND BEEN SELLING FOR
THREE YEARS. I'M HERE TO ASK YOU
TO SUPPORT SENATE BILL NINE
SEVENTY TWO WHICH WOULD MAKE IT
POSSIBLE FOR US TO DO OUR JOB
JOBS UNDER THE LAW AND BE ABLE
TO SUPPORTER. SIXTY TWO. SENATE
HAVE DVD DISCS IN MY LOWER BACK.
I SHARE THIS BECAUSE A PERSON
WITH THIS BACKGROUND CAN NO
LONGER FIND WORK. I'M A PERSON
WHO BESTED FOR HIMSELF. SOMEONE
LIKE ME DOESN'T HAVE THE MEANS
TO PAY THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO
RUN A COMMISSARY. THE MONEY I
EARN FROM OUR OFFICE COSTS
BARELY ENOUGH FOR MY EXPENSES. I
HAVE TO SELL HUNDREDS OF GLASSES
OF OUR OFFICE BECAUSE A MONTH TO
BE A BIT. OF MONEY. THANK YOU
THE SITE. MAKES IT BETTER FOR ME
TO. ME TAKE A LOT. DOING COMEDY.
THIS CALL IS DOUBLE FOR REPAIR
OUR PRESCOTT. IN MY MISTY'S
CLEAN. I WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO PER. MY OUR FISCAL HOME. BUT
I WE GET THE- CURRENT CORPORATE
SOMEONE UP BE SET UP TO MAKE MY
PROFIT. I WOULD BE WHAT I WOULD
BE. THAN WILLING TO LEARN HOW TO
ENSURE SENATE. IN MATH TODAY THE
MY WHOLE IS SANITIZE. ONLY ASK
YOU FOR THE ARE. LASTLY I ASK
YOU NOT TO CRIMINALIZE US.
BECAUSE IT WOULD IT WOULD HAVE.
IT WOULD AFFECT RECORD IN IT
WOULD IN HER. IN A BILL ALL IT
WOULD IT WOULD. SOME OF US. TO
DEPORTEE. TAT'S WHY I'M ASKING
YOU TO SUPPORT SEVEN SB NINE
SEVENTY TWO THANK YOU. I THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT WELL NOW
I MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SEVENTY TWO. RESOLVE BECAUSE
DOES. HI I AND YOU SELL BEHALF
OF THE SEVEN THOUSAND MEMBERS
ABOUT DAY IN CALIFORNIA SUPPORT
THANK THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
DOUG SMITH WILL PUBLIC HEALTH
STROKES. THANK YOU. HI MY NAME
IS SANTA CLAUS I'M HERE HAS
SPARKED COMMUNITY POWER
COLLECTED TO SUPPORT SB NINE
SEVEN TWO. THANK YOU NO HERE I
HAVE TWO HUNDRED LETTERS FROM
STREET VENDORS WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL HAS WELL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GROCERY CENTERS MY
NAME IS RUDY ESPINOZA A SERVICE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF INCLUSIVE
ACTION A NONPROFIT CDFI AND IN
LOS ANGELES WE ARE ONE OF THE CO
SPONSOR OF SENATE BILL NINE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE SUPPORT THIS.
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS MONIES BENEFIT HERE
BEHALF OF PUBLIC COUNCIL AND I'M
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
EIGHTY. GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS
MY NAME'S ESTEFANIA LOPEZ SENIOR
POLICY ASSOCIATE AT AN INCLUSIVE
ACTION AND I ASK YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATORS MY NAME IS LARRY COKER
AND I'M ALSO IS INCLUSIVE ACTION
FOR THE CITY AND I'M PROVIDING
MY STRONG SUPPORT FOR YOUR BILL
NINE SEVEN TWO. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS YURI BONDS
FROM THE- OIL IMMIGRANT JUSTICE
CLINIC. AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SALLY
ACOSTA AND I'M A CLINICAL
STUDENT AT LOYALIST IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE CLINIC AND SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS MY NAME IS
QUAN ESPINOSA AND I'M AN EQUAL
JUSTICE WORKS FELLOW WITH PUBLIC
COUNCIL ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
PROFESSOR MARIE SOMEONE DAYS AND
WE ARE AND I'M FROM THE LEGAL
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE CLINIC AND
TRANSPORT THANK YOU. HELLO I'M
LIZARDMEN THOUGH SIGNED I'M WITH
THE INLAND COALITION FOR
IMMIGRANT JUSTICE AND WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE
SEVEN TWO THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KARINA
CORONADO AND I WORK WITH THE
INLAND COALITION FOR IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE AS A COACHELLA VALLEY
ORGANIZER AND I'M IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. HELLO SENATORS MY
NAME IS BRIAN SANCHEZ I'M A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WITH THE
INLAND COALITION FOR IMMIGRANT
JUSTICE. AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB NINE SEVEN TWO THANK YOU. HI
MY NAME IS DANIELLE RODRIGUEZ
I'M WILL BROWN ISSUES HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. YOU SEE THANK
YOU. HELLO MY NAME IS KEY AND
I'M HERE WITH BROWN ISSUES FROM
SACRAMENTO AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
CENTERS I'M I'M A LITTLE BIT
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF BROWN
ISSUES STATEWIDE LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT ORGANIZATION AND
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. CHRIS RESPONSES
POLICY ADVOCATE THE WATCHES SAN
LAN PARTY WERE PART OF A CO
SPONSOR NOT FOUND OUT MY
COLLEAGUES. FROM THE CALIFORNIA-
CALVIN'S REGNUM JUSTICE SINCE
FROM SUPPORT THANK YOU. HELLO
GOOD AFTERNOON ANNA GONZALEZ
REPRESENTING CENTER FOR
COMMUNITY ACTION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ALSO
PRESIDENT OF THE CHICANO LATINO
CAUCUS OF SAMBAR DINO COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. HI MY NAME IS WORKING CAUSE
HILLS I'M A COMMUNITY ORGANIZER
WITH CENTER FOR COMMUNITY
ACTION. AND ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE ON HERE AND SOME SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
PATRICIA BRUNO. AND I'M WITH THE
LOS ANGELES AREA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE TO STRONGLY SUPPORT SB
NINE SEVEN TWO THANK YOU THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON RITA MEDINA
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF STATE POLICY
AND ADVOCACY AT CHEERS LED
COALITION FOR HUMANE IMMIGRANT
RIGHTS PROUD CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL AND ALSO HERE IN THE
SUPPORT OF OUR COLLEAGUES FROM
HOUSING NOW COALITION IN SUPPORT
AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON CAITLIN O'NEILL ON
BEHALF OF SETH IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. SIXTEEN ON US PRETTY THE
MICROPHONE HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED WILL MOVE ON TO THE-
TELECONFERENCE LINE MODERATOR
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE SEVENTY TWO
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
AND FOR THOSE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SEVENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. IN ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT.
IF YOU. CURRENTLY WITH ABOUT
FIFTEEN IN OUR QUEUE. F. WE'LL
START WITH LINE TWO OH FIVE. BOB. ONE TWO OH FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WITH THE LINE EIGHTY NINE. YES PLEASE INTRODUCE YOURSELF. HELLO MY NAME IS ABILITIES I'M
NOT NOT JUST OFF ON THOSE WHO
FEED CALIFORNIA MOTRIN POLICY
CENTER AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
REGISTER OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
SB NINE SEVEN TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANKS
IS ONE NINETY. MIKE MARTINEZ
SENIOR DEPUTY COMMISSIONER OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE. FOR INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA PROUD
CO SPONSOR IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SEVENTY TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU
. WINE TWO THIRTY EIGHT. BEYOND
THE BUMPER OF POLICY DIRECTOR
FOR SMALL BUSINESS MAJORITY WE
ARE AND FROM SUPPORT ABOUT THE
NINE SEVENTY TWO THAT'LL HELP ON
NORTH EIGHT THANK YOU. WHAT LINE
WIND TO NINE. HI GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS A SPECIAL KERR WAS
EQUALLY COMEDIC WE ARE MEMBERS
OF THE LOS ANGELES REMEMBER
CAMPAIGN AND STRONG SUPPORT
RIGHT IN NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
. NINE NINETY FOUR. AFTERNOON
NUMBER AND COMMITTEE NAME IS AN
EMAIL I'M I ORDER WITH THE FOUR
ONE CANNOT OVER TO THAT AND FROM
SUPPORT OF SB NINETY. THANK YOU
THAT'S WHAT. LINE TWO FOUR.
AMERICA MANY COMPANIES CAR
CONNECT WITH THE AND THE
CAMPAIGN WITH THE POKEMON OF THE
KIND OF FOR THE CALLED AS WE
KNOW THIRTY TWO THE POINT OF THE
MATCH OFFICE FOR THE NIGHT WITH
A NURSE FROM COLLECTOR. AT OKAY
ON MY TWO THANK YOU YOUR NAY OR
IS A POSITION WE HAD SOMEONE TO
WITNESSES SO EIGHT YOU EXCELLENT. NUMBER TWENTY THREE. MONTEREY
ON BEHALF OF THE IMMIGRANT RIGHT
FOR HIM I DON'T REALLY NEARLY
TWENTY CAN SAFELY FOR AND ORGAN
IN YOU DON'T BE STRONGLY AT NICE
TWO THANK YOU THANKS FOR THIS.
NINE ONE TWO. BUT MY FRIEND IS
FOR WINDOW DELIGHTFUL THE ALL
YOUR LIFE IT SEVEN MILLION SEVEN
A LITTLE. CRISIS NEXT WITH.
NUMBER EIGHT SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
NAME IS TODAY ARM THE OTHER END
OR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
REINVESTMENT AND I'M AND- STRONG
THAT THE BANK OF TWO THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. WHINY ONE. HELLO
MY NAME IS DEBBIE NINE THAN IN
THE USE OF NINETEEN AND
AUTHORITY AND I SUPPORT. SB
SEVEN TWO THANK YOU NEXT. NUMBER. ONE NINETY. THE NUMBER OF THE
MONACO MONACO BERMAN ASSEMBLY
CARE IN THAT REGARD I ALMOST
GOING ISRAEL PUT ANOTHER LAYER
TO PRESIDENT BY THAT I KEPT
ACCESS EXCELLENT THIS. NUMBER
ONE FOR. THE FOURTEENTH PLEASE
AT. D. ALL OF THE LINES. FOR
FINAL JOKE THE AMERICAN DENTAL
NINE OWNERS AND CEO DETECTION
THERAPEUTIC SERVICES RANCHO
MIRAGE CALIFORNIA AND I AM IN
FULL SUPPORT OF THE NINE NINE
NINE OKAY WE'RE ON NINE SEVENTY
TWO AT THIS POINT WE'LL GET THE
NINE NINE NINE LATER BUT THANK
YOU SO MUCH OF PLEASE CALL BACK
FOR NINE NINE NINE. SIX WITNESS
FOR SB NINE IN FAVOR OF SB NINE
SEVENTY TWO. THE NEXT IN LINE.
TO TWENTY TWO. THIS IS SANDEL
GREENLEE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF.
THE SPORTSCOPE SB SEVENTY THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT. TO TWO
TWENTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS BILLY FONG DIRECTED
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
IN SOLITARY WITH THE TREE FALL
AFTER BIRTH IN SUPPORT FOR ITS
BE NICE SEVENTY TWO THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. NUMBER TWO
NINETEEN. THIRTEEN NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE NUMBER TWO
OH EIGHT. NUMBER TWO OH EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WANT TO NUMBER
TWO OH FIVE. FOR THREE TO FIVE
YEAR LINES OPEN. CALL. DELIGNE.
TO FORTY SIX. TWO FORTY SIX
DOLLARS. YES SIGNAL MY NAME IS
AT THE TOP OF THAT I AM AN
ORGANIZER IN THE INLAND EMPIRE
AND I AM CALLING IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR AT THE NINE SEVEN
SIX. AND SEVENTY TWO THANK YOU.
THE COMMISSION NEXT IT WILL BE
NUMBER ONE SIXTY SIX. NUMBER ONE
SIX SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE'LL
GO TO NUMBER TWO FORTY EIGHT. HI
MY NAME IS KATHY BANNING MSU
NASSAR UCLA SCHOOL OF LAW AND I
SUPPORT IT UNITED SEVEN TWO
THANK YOU THANKS WITH THIS.
DICKS'S LINE TO THIRTY THREE.
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GIVE US.
MOVIELINE TWO FORTY FOUR. TWENTY
FORTY FOUR PLEASE GOOD. THE
NUMBER TWO OH SEVEN. ONTO A
SEVENTIES ERA. HELLO HELLO. OKAY
YES WE CAN YOU PLEASE INTRODUCE
YOURSELF SORRY TRANSACTION. THE
LITTLE LINE TO FIFTY TWO. THE
ENVIRONMENT OR ON BEHALF OF THE
TYPE WE NEED DEVELOPMENT CENTER
IN LOS ANGELES THE STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
SURE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
TEXAS. TWO TWO FIFTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD.WE WILL DO NUMBER TWO
TWENTY NINE. IN THE RAMS HAVE
BEEN THE FUNDING THAT I'M GLAD
TO KNOW THAT IDEALLY LIKE YOURS. FOR YOU KNOW A- WONDERFUL BUT
DON ARE ONLY IF IT. REMAINS A
FAVORITE OF MAY FROM IT UP LOT
OF THE BOX. MEDIA THE VETERAN
FROM ABOUT A MONTH SOME OF. THE
THINGS THAT THAT I. FOR OTHER.
LOCOMOTIVES OKAY AFTER.
SATI'S EXPLAIN THIS. NUMBER ONE
FORTY SEVEN. ONE FOUR SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NUMBER TWO
FIFTY FOUR. GOOD TIMING ON THE
INTERNET THE STATE MONDAY LET
SESSION TO MEET UP WITH THE
CONSULTANT WE SUPPORT THIRTIES
NIGHTS. I THANK YOU CRISIS NEXT
WITNESS. NUMBER TWO- OH FIVE.
TWO OH FIVE THREE ZERO AS. THE.
THE MOVE THE NUMBER TO FIFTY
SEVEN. TWO FIVE SEVEN ZERO.
PRESS THE NUMBER TWO FIFTY FIVE. HI MY NAME IS JESSICA I AM
OUT- I WORK WITH THE INCLUSION
FOR IMMIGRANT JUSTICE I AM. MY
SUPPORT FOR IT SEE TO. THANKS
FOR THIS. NUMBER. TWO TWENTY
NINE. NUMBER TWO TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MODERATOR- WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE SEVENTY
TWO WE HAVE TO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- ONE IN PERSON ONE WAY
SO WE'LL BEGIN WITH JUST MILLER
WITH. US FOR MENTAL ILLNESS HAVE
FINANCE. I'LL GIVE YOU TWO
MINUTES. OF THE TIME THE NEXT
WITH SL WELCOME. DOCTOR MEMBERS
MILLER HIM BUT OF THE NUMBER
HEALTH MINISTER. THANK YOU FOR
THIS HEARING- AND FOR I TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SOLIDARITY THE
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICES THAT YOUR
STATEMENT IN THE BEGINNING THAT
IS REALLY IMPORTANT AND
IMPORTANT TO US- I WANTED TO.
SAY GRATEFUL WE STILL OPPOSED TO
IT HI WE WILL IN OPPOSITION I
LISTEN MENDED AND IF YOU DO WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR WE WANT TO
THANK THE SPA. THE FIRST. KAMALA
TO. PEANUT BIG BIG IS BEEN A LOT
MOVING AND WE HAD A LOT OF INTER
AND HE'S BEEN CIVIL AND VERY
POSITIVE SO I MUST STATE THAT UP
FRONT THAT THANK YOU FOR
EVERYBODY INVOLVED ALL PEOPLE
HAVE TO THE FIVE IT'S A GOOD
SCHOOLS WE NOT. ONE POSEN IS
AMENDED BUT I TO STRESS THAT THE
INVITE HEALTH DIRECTOR AS YOU
FOOD INSPECTORS. A HUNDRED TEN
SUPPORT THE CHANGE IN THE
PENALTY PROVISION WE AGREED WITH
A LOT OF BILL A FEW YEARS AGO
AND WE AGREE THAT FOR SOME
RELATIVELY MINOR TRANSGRESSION
LIKE ST PHANE IT SHOULDN'T BE
MORE THAN A MISTER TO PENALTIES.
HOWEVER THERE ARE PENALTIES ON
THE CAP. THE FIELD WARRANT CIVIL
EVEN CRIMINAL ACTION IN A VERY
VERY RARE CASE SO WE'D LIKE TO
WORK WITH YOU AUTHORED TO
CLARIFY THOSE PROVISIONS. BUT
FIRST OF ALL WE COMPLETELY AGREE
THAT PROVISION ABOUT HAVING IT
THIS SHOULD. FOR THESE
VIOLATIONS. I HAVE A COUPLE OF
THE ISSUES THAT ON FULLY
RESOLVED WE DID HEAR THAT YOU
AMENDMENTS WOULD ADDRESS THE CAP
ON THE MEAT BECAUSE WE DID DRESS
HE WILL ADDRESS. OUR FOOD. APPS
WHAT WE STRUGGLING WITH A MEMBER
AND WHAT WE HAVE BUT EVERY CAN
WORK FOR THAT ON. IS THE
RECOGNIZE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
OBSTACLES FOR THE PEOPLE IS THE
NEED FOR COMMISSARIES. BUT WE
CANNOT OPEN UP IN THE HOME
RESTAURANTS FOR THIS TYPE OF
THING MINUTES OKAY SO JUST TO
JUST TO RECAP VERY QUICKLY
BEFORE HEATHER COMES ON WE
WANTED TO THANK AUTHOR WE WANT
TO STRESS WE STILL HAVE A NUMBER
OF ISSUES. THAT WE END UP.
COMMITTED TO MAKE. SEVERAL OF
MEN MAY AS WE MOVE FORWARD SAID
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WILL NOW BRING ON HAVE THEIR
PLAN- LOW CO CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAIL FOOD SAFETY
COMMITTEE ON TO THE LINE SO
SHE'S GONNA BE COMING ON
TELECOM- THE MINUTE- SO. HI
THERE BONOMO COULD PLEASE CIRCLE
CA LINE. HELLO MY NAME IS
HEATHER ALONE AND CAL RETAIL
SAFETY COALITION COALITION IS
COMPRISED OF MEMBERS WHO WORK IN
THE RETAIL FOOD INDUSTRY SUCH AS
MOBILE FOOD VENDORS TEMPORARY
EVENT THAT. HELLO IT WAS FORMED
IN NINETEEN NINETY THREE TO WORK
WHAT ON ISSUES IMPACT ALL FACTOR
THE INDUSTRY SB NINE TWO ONE OF
THE ISSUES AND THE COALESCE IS
HERE TODAY TO EXPRESS OPPOSITE
LEFT MAN LEFT THE FOLLOWING. AND
THEN. ACTIONABLE FISCAL EIGHTY
THREE THIRTY FOOT HAVE PUBLIC
AND EQUITABLE BIT PRACTICES FOR
ALL TO BUSINESSES INCLUDING
VENDORS AND THEN THE DEATH OF A
CALM COMMITTEE TO CONNIE FOR THE
MANY THE BUSINESS DOCTOR AFTER
THE PANDEMIC ENGINE THIRTY EIGHT
CALIFORNIA CAN THERE OVER
HUNDRED AND- THOUSAND. RETAIL
FOOD PATIENT THERE ARE A HUNDRED
AND FORTY SIX THOUSAND
OPPORTUNITY FOR STREET VENDORS.
BUT THESE PATIENTS BE CALM.
MODEL HELP BOTH SIDES VENDORS
AND THE LOCAL MARK OR RESTAURANT
THEIR NEIGHBOR THE OPERATING
STATE SIXTH BUSINESS. REMOVE ALL
RELATED MIGRATED HOME UP. TODAY
ONLY NINE HAVE IT ME BECAUSE OF
WHAT YOU'RE CAN TO. EXPANDING
NICOLAU THIS WILL DETER CHURCH
PERMIT THE GOOD THE AND HAVE A
EFFECT ON THE WHOLE KITCHEN.
RESTORE LAND FOR COTTAGE OPERATE
ARE FROM NEWMAN LIMIT WHAT WOULD
CREATE BE A PART OF THAT GROUP
BLOCK.
DOCTORS LIKE FOURTEEN THE
COALITION REPORT IS RATTLING ARE
WORK LAB ORDER. BUT AUTHORS
SPONSORED AN ADVOCATE THANK YOU
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO A THREE NINE
SEVENTY TWO HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED. ST ON APPROACHING ABOUT
OWN MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES FOR ANY WITNESSES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB.
SEVEN TWO. FOR THE OF YOU THAT
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK NOT BE TO
NINE SEVEN TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
CURRENTLY THERE ARE TWO IN OUR
QUEUE. WE'LL GO TO NUMBER TWO
SIXTY FOUR. HELLO MY NAME IS
RIGHT NOT THE ONE I'M CALLING
FROM I'M NOT GONNA CALIFORNIA
I'M CALLING TO SUPPORT THAT NINE
THIRTY TWO OKAY THANK YOU- WE
ARE NOW TAKING PPOSITION
TESTIMONY BUT I KNOW SOMETIMES
WHEN THE LINES GET. ONE THE
WRONG BUDGET BUT A NEXT. THANK
IS. ONE SEVENTY SIX. ONE SEVENTY
SIX IS GOOD. MOVE THE NUMBER TO
TWENTY ONE. YES THE FIDELITY OF
ONE REPRESENTING THE HEALTH
OFFICE IS THAT THE LOCATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE OPPOSE AN
ALERT FROM IMPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOUTHANKS WITH THIS. NEXT
IS TO THIRTEEN. EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT. OKAY FOR PROGRESS ATTY IF
THE COURT BACK ELECTED CALDERON
WHAT ARE YOU TRYING TO PUT THEM
YEAH OKAY THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. THANKS TO NUMBER TWO SEVENTY.
THANK THE NEW ON CALLING ON OF
THE CALIFORNIA THE. AND WITH THE
BELT FOUR TO. SEEING HOW THE-
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
. IT IS NUMBER TWO SIXTY ONE.
NUMBER TWO SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH THE FIGURE ON RAIL
ONLINE OPPOSITION THERE THANK
YOU. GIVE NEXT WITNESS. MR THIS
TIME THERE'S NO FURTHER
INTERVIEW I THANK YOU MODERATOR
WILL BRING YOU BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS CENTER
WIENER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD- THIS IS NOT. A LINE OF-
PIECES LEGISLATION TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE SUPPORTING. OUR
STREET VENDORS AND THAT PEOPLE
HAVE A PATHWAY TO- EARN A LIVING
OFF OF THEIR SKILLS AND WE KNOW
THAT SO MANY OF OUR- STREET.
VENDORS ARE- JUST TO SAY UP WITH
THE STATE. I HAVE DELICIOUS
PRODUCTS. AND AND SO ON THE
SUPER SUPPORT OF MAKING SURE
PATHWAYS FOR PEOPLE- PENCE HE TO
SUPPORT- THE VIN NUMBERS BY TEN
CENTER LARA ALSO THE WAY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER- MEDICAL AND
OTHERS AS WELL TO HELP- OUR ARE
- THIS REALLY IMPORTANT I
INDUSTRY AND CAN AND I SUPPORT
THIS BILL AND THE VOTING FOR IT
TODAY I DO JUST WANT NOTE. THERE
ARE NO IN SAN- THIS IS TRUE IN
SOME OTHER. CITIES LIKE SAM.
PRINCESS CRUZ DIEGO. THERE HAVE
BEEN SOME CHALLENGES- IN TERMS
OF- SOME STREET VENDORS WHO I
THINK OR- HI THIS IS. THE BEST
IN LARGE OF STREET VENDORS ARE
TERRIFIC ACTORS OR ENTITIES TO
PROVIDE DELICIOUS SAFE. FOOD WHO
WERE WHO WERE TRYING TO JUST YOU
KNOW BE GOOD MEMBERS OF THE
COMMUNITY LARGE MAJORITY OF
STREET VENDORS I KNOW SOME FOLKS
WHO HAVE COST PROBLEMS- AND IT'S
A MINORITY FOR SURE A SMALL
MINORITY BUT AS WE KNOW
SOMETIMES A SMALL MINORITY CAN.
BE IMPACTFUL- AND SO I KNOW THAT
ON OUR CITY IN SAN FRANCISCO
LIKE A FISHERMAN'S WHARF IN
UNION SQUARE HAS BEEN
STRUGGLING. TO TRY TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE TO STREET VENDORS
THERE CITY ONCE ST- BUT THAT
EVERYTHING IS HAPPENING AT A
FAIRLY AN ORDERLY WAY. TERMS OF. I'M I TAX AND IT HARD TO
STRETCH A BALANCE- AND I KNOW
WHO I'D LIKE TO ONLY SPEAK FOR
SERVICES I KNOW REALLY DOES
WANTING TO STRIKE THAT NOT TO
GET RID OF STREET VENDORS ARE TO
SHUT IT DOWN OR TO MAKE IT HARD-
MAKE SURE THAT- YOU KNOW WE'RE
REALLY SUPPORTING LARGE MAJORITY
OF THREE BUT THEY WERE REALLY
GOOD ACTORS- WELL HAVING WAYS OF
ADDRESSING SOME OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT ARE HAPPENING AND I DON'T.
I DON'T ANYONE KNOW WHAT THE
EXACT RIGHT ANSWER IS WE JUST.
ASSEMBLY ALLAM WE WILL THEN TALK
AND I JUST HOPE SEE THE TWO TO
HAVE THOSE KIND. TO FIND TO
THREATEN NEEDLE THANK YOU AND IF
I MAKE MR THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THAT TO MY ATTENTION AND I DO
HAVE A LETTER HERE FROM. A
MULTITUDE OF SEACOLE HOLDERS
FROM SAN FRANCISCO AND I LOOK
FOR TO WORKING WITH THEM WE
HAVEN'T- YET MET BUT I DID SEE
THEIR THEIR LETTER WHICH
INCLUDES- A LOT OF ISSUES
RELATED TO WHAT THEY MENTION IS
LIKE LARGE MONOPOLIES WHICH WERE
TAKEN. ISSUE I KNOW THAT WOULD
BE MORE OF A LOCAL ISSUE
SEPARATE FROM THIS BILL THIS
BILL SPECIFICALLY LOOKS AT
MODERNIZING THE FOOD RETAIL FOOD
CODE TO GET- FOLKS THAT ARE- NOT
IN COMPLIANCE NOW TO GET THEM
THE PERMITS AND TO ALSO ENSURE
THAT WERE THE GOOD ACTORS AND WE
- MANY OF THEM. THEY ARE NOT BE
. I SPEND RIGHT UP ABSOLUTELY
THAT'S WHY TWO TWO OF US ALLEN
AND THE VARIOUS. I'M SURE WE CAN
FIGURE SOMETHING OUT ENOUGH WHY
I'M SUPPORTING YOUR BILL IS SO
I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH BILLS A MOVE AYE
SIR WIENER SAID RUBIO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THE HOUSE WANT TO
THINK THE AUTHOR- PROUD CO
AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE AND I
THINK THAT. IT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE RECOGNIZE THAT
WE'RE ASKING IN ALL THESE
CENTERS TO WORK WITHIN THE LAW
BUT YET WE MAKE IT SO DIFFICULT
FOR THEM. PERMET IN A IN A WORLD
OF FEET AND POSSIBLY THEIR
BUSINESS AS ONE OF THE SPEAKERS
. THEY WERE ASKED TO THROW THE
FOOD AWAY ANOTHER ONE WAS
ARRESTED I MEAN WE I THINK IT'S
IN OUR BEST INTEREST ALL OF US
AS A COMMUNITY TO KNOW WHO THESE
VENDORS ARE AND MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE WORKING WITHIN THE
FRAMEWORK OF PUBLIC HEALTH
GUIDELINES BUT AGAIN IT'S- IN
THE- THESE VENDORS HAVE BEEN
PART. OF OUR COMMUNITY SAID
LISTEN ARE OUR LATINO
COMMUNITIES AND TO AND AGAIN I
YOU KNOW WE ALL USE- BUT WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT AGAIN THEY'RE
OPERATING WITHIN THE LAW AND%
THAT BY WORKING BECAUSE TO MAKE
. WE THE ABILITY THERE'S A OF
RED TAPE AND JUST TRYING TO DO
THE RIGHT THING BUT IF WE DON'T
HELP THEM EXPEDITE THE PART
THAT'S IN AND HELP THEM YOU KNOW
SPEAK WITH PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. THEN THERE WERE-
CREATE. YOU KNOW THE FRONT DESK
TO BE UNDER SOUTH I CAN I'M A
PRO AUTHOR A AND IT'S I GOT WE
DON'T NEED. COSTS IN. TIME NICE
. BOTH PLEASE. OR DID AT THE
SENATE FINAL THE LOS LLANOS
NICHOLS HILLS DOES COOKIES.
POPPED UP WE ARE LOS GLASSES
LOSS AND MODOC ON SILO ABOUT THE
CYCLE OTHER TYPE OF OTHER EIGHTY
SEVEN WHISKEY GET IT GET IN-
DEMOCRAT THEN A LOT LATE IS MOST
BECAUSE HE CVO CAN LIST MEASLES
ASSIST ANY GETTING MOST CANNOT
CLUB  THINK.
WHICH OTHER ASSETS AND I'LL TURN
IT OVER TO THAT AND I WILL ALSO
JUST OPENING THE MEASURE THANK
YOU THANKS SERVICE GROW. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR IDEA SHE TO
STORIES THAT WERE THERE I DO
BELIEVE THAT- YOU KNOW YOU CAN A
BIT JOB CREATOR OR WRITER. BUT
IT ISN'T TOOLS THAT ARE IN THE
STREET VENDOR ECKHARDT'S ARE-
ENTREPRENEURS AND
ENTREPRENEURIAL AND THEY USE
THIS TO HAPPEN IF IT THEIR
FAMILIES. AND REYES THEIR
CHILDREN AND IBM I APPRECIATE
THAT. THE CARD- I THINK PEOPLE
THAT OWN THEIR OWN BUSINESS
REGARDLESS IF IT'S IF IT'S A IF
IT'S A- BUSINESS THAT IS A BRICK
AND MORTAR BUSINESS OR A
BUSINESS THAT IS WHAT RETIRED.
STREET VENDORS I THINK THE- THIS
STANDARD ESTIMATE HOW MANY HOURS
. AND OPERATE YOUR OWN BUSINESS.
I REALLY I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU'RE TAKING THE INITIATIVE TO
MODERNIZE A LAW FIRM THAT
DIDN'T- YOU KNOW WHEN YOU HAVE
AN UP REYES AND NOT APPRAISING
BUT AN INCREASE IN VENDORS
OPERATE THROUGHOUT THE SPEECH
SPECIFICALLY LARGE POP HE IS-
AND HAVE A LARGE. AND IT.
THERE'S NOT LAWS THERE THAT-
DIRECTLY FIT THAT THAT INDUSTRY
RATES ITS BRICK AND MORTAR AND
SO I GET IT ON THAT PIECE AS
WELL YOU CAN'T REALLY HOLD A
STREET VENDOR ITEND THIS GAME.
HE WOULD HAVE HER IS OBVIOUSLY
NOT PLAYED A LECTURE FOR OR NOT
THERE'S JUST DIFFERENT THINGS
RIGHT DIFFERENT. DIFFERENT
THINGS SO I APPRECIATE YOU BEING
ABLE TO DO THAT I DO CONCERNS
THESE ARE MY CONCERNS. AT THE
COPS. AND HOME COMMERCE ISSUES
RIGHT SO RIGHT NOW- THE LOVELY
WHO TESTIFIED AT THE BEGINNING
SAID THAT SHE I THINK SHE SAID
IT WAS LIKE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
FOR IT TO. WHERE THEY CENTER
SINKS AND THEY HAD A DIFFERENT A
DIFFERENT REQUIREMENTS IN ORDER
TO PREPARE FOOD FOR THE PUBLIC
WHEN YOU BUY THE FOOD. M. AND
THIS IS THE BILL MY
UNDERSTANDING AND IF I'M WRONG
PLEASE CORRECT ME BUT MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT THIS
INCREASE IN COMMISSARIES IS THIS
ALLOW- THE HEALTH AGENCIES AND
OPERATORS TO- BACK IN HOME
SERIES JUST UP NOW. WELL IT. ALL
THEM- YOU HOME- COMMISSARY IF
THEY WANTED TO MAKE ONLY UTILIZE
A- FREE ONE TO BUT THE ISSUE IS
WITH SEEN- FROM MANY THE- STAFF
THERE. SENSITIVE AND THAT YOU
KNOW THE CONSENT BORROW. AND I
THINK ONE OF LOCAL. OFFICE
PRESENTATION THERE'S A HIGH
THIRTY SIXTY OF THAT. THINGS
STILL IT. FOR THE- AND WOULD BE
. A YOU KNOW MORE OF A AND
ACCESS SORT OF OPPORTUNITY THEM
. TO PROVIDE PREPARE THAT. WHEN
I TO THE CON MOBILE FACILITY
EVERY- EVERY BUSINESS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA STRUGGLES TO
COMPLY WITH- AND REACHABLE
ACCESSIBLE. YEAH THE REQUIRED BY
THIS BODY THE QUESTION I ASK YOU
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT IS. IF YOU
GO TWENTY IN THE SERIES INSTEAD
OF ONE THAT IS INSPECTED BY THE
STATE OR LOCAL INSPECTORS MAYBE
ITS LOCAL INSPECTORS STATE
INSPECTORS. WHEN IN COMMENTARY
THIS BILL THE NIGHT- THE LOCAL
OR STATE AUTHORITY TO INSPECT
THEIR IN HOME COMMISSARIES I CAN
ASK THAT. EIGHT I CAN ASK A- OUR
pMY- AND FROM PUBLIC COUNSEL WHO
CAN ADDED. GROUP SPOT WHO IS I'M
SORRY IS IT A FROM THE HEALTH-
OKAY SIR HEAD- IS EASIER TO SOME
HOME OR ARE YOU ALLOWED TO GROW
THIS IS A- STORY. AGAIN THAT'S
IT PRETTY GOOD QUESTION CHECK. A
DIFFICULT HAVING WITH BILL THAT
IS UNDER THE CURRENT ROLE WE DO
INSPECT THE MICHOS THESE IN HOME
RATE WHAT WE WANTED TO BE. THREE
TO THE NUMBER OF OTHER
ACTIVITIES IN THESE ME BECAUSE
BECAUSE FROM OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
PERSPECTIVE THEY REALLY STRESSED
OUT THE DAY COULD BE STRESSED
OUT IF YOU IN THE THIRD FLOOR OF
AN APARTMENT SURE HOW YOU CAN.
OF CALL- WHERE CAN YOU STORE
THEM HOW CAN YOU CLEAN THE
MESSAGES SO THAT'S A FUNDAMENTAL
CONCERN AS WE MOVE FORWARD IF WE
CAN ENSURE THAT THERE IS AN
ABILITY TO ONLY PERMIT THOSE
MEET CODES ON THOSE ARE CALLED
THE CITIES THAT ARE SAFE. WE
WOULD LIKE TO WORK WITH
COMMITTEE TO CRAFT THAT LANGUAGE
AND I THINK WE MAY BE ABLE TO
GET THERE BUT RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
TO IN THAT WATER L. COMMENTS BE
SAFE AT THIS POINT ARE ON THE
PHONE HOW IN PART. TODAY HAVE A
LOT. PM THIS IS I THINK TO GET
WITH ADEQUATE PROTECTION THANK
YOU THANK YOU SOMEONE AND I
THINK BEEN SOME ISSUES YES APPLE
WE HAVE YOUR DOG FROM HEALTH LAW
WHO WOULD LIKE TO ADD ADDITIONAL
THANK YOU FOR PROGRESS AND THE
ONLY THING THAT I WOULD ADD IS
THE STILL NOT. FIVE HOME MR
EIGHT CALDERON. F. AND- EAGLE
PROGRAM BUT A TRUE DOT. PROGRAM
THOSE ARE. PROGRAMS ALLEGE HAS
PUT PLACE SAFEGUARD. FOR ON. AND
WHO WANT TO USE THOSE PRO AND SO
S. B. NINE SEVENTY DOLLARS. IS
THAT IT OPENS THOSE UP TO
SIDEWALK VENDORS AS LONG AS THEY
FOLLOW ALL OF THE EXISTING
STANDARDS THAT ARE ALREADY IN
PLACE INCLUDING INSTRUCTIONS
MENTIONED. I NOTICED THAT THERE
IS THE CODE MAKES A DISTINCTION
BETWEEN CALLED- ACTUALLY
HAZARDOUS FOOD AND NON
POTENTIALLY HAZARDOUS FOODS OR
DISTINCTION BETWEEN MORE
COMPLICATED FOOD PREPARATION AND
SOME OF THOSE LESS COMPLICATED
FOOD PREPARATIONS THAT ARE. WAS
LESS HEALTH CONCERNS AND RISKS
PENCIL COTTAGE FOOD IS GENERALLY
ALREADY LIMITED TO THOSE VERY
SAFE MON POTENTIALLY HAZARDOUS
FOODS AND THAT WOULD REMAIN THE
SAME SO ANY SIDEWALK VENDOR
MAKING USE OF THE PROGRAM WOULD.
IS ALREADY APPROVED. READ ODD
NON. FIRST AND THEN WHEN IT
COMES TO THE METER PROGRAMS
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
THEY'VE BEEN RAISING VERY
IMPORTANT CONCERNS AND
CONSIDERATIONS AND SO. ADMINS
THAT WERE WERE CIRCULATED
EARLIER ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND
LIMIT THE VENDOR'S ABILITY TO
EXCEED THOSE CAPS. IF THEY'RE
DOING THE SPECIFIC TYPE OF NON
POTENTIALLY HAZARDOUS FOOD
PREPARATION. AND IF THEY'RE
DOING SOMETHING THAT QUALIFIES
AS POTENTIALLY HAZARDOUS FOOD
THAT WOULD INVOKE OVERSIGHT FROM
THE COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH THEY WERE. OKAY STAY
RIGHT HERE. SO JUST SO I
UNDERSTAND IT AND I APOLOGIZE
I'M TO THE AUTHOR FOR NOT
TREATING THE PRESSURE WAS JUST
SO I UNDERSTAND IT BECAUSE LIKE
I SAID I DO I DO SUPPORT THE
IDEA OF ENTREPRENEURSHIP I
REALLY DO I THINK IT'S I THINK
IT'S AN AND IT. I MEAN AS YOU
LIKE IT FOR THEM TO GO TO
COLLEGE ON ENTREPRENEURSHIP SO I
GET IT WHETHER IT'S A VERY SMALL
BUSINESS OR LARGE BUSINESS MIKE
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT. I
WANT TO MAKE THAT. IN HOME TO AN
IN HOME COMMISSARY VERSUS PAYING
FOR COMMISSARY BECAUSE THERE ARE
COMMISSAIRES AVAILABLE SOMETIMES
ARE A LONG WAYS AWAY YOU KNOW-
MY DAUGHTER BUT THE DUTCH
FRONTIER IN HISTORY OF ALL THE
WAY LA TO GET LOBSTER RIGHT SO I
KNOW. THOSE WITH SMALL BUSINESS
. SO- IF THEY GO TO THE IF THE-
PUBLIC HEALTH THE COUNTY PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICE THEY CAN STILL GO
INTO THE IN HOME COMMISSARIES
AND DO AN INSPECTION FOR SAFETY
TO THE PUBLIC TO MAKE SURE
THINGS ARE DONE CORRECTLY
CORRECT CORRECT UNDER ME GO
UNDER MICAH WHICH IS ALREADY
EXISTING PROGRAM. OKAY AND- AS
WELL AND AS THE OPPOSITION BUT
AT. OPPOSE THIS YEAH. EXPANDS
AND HAS FIFTY CARTS AND SHE
LIVES IN A THIRD LEVEL APARTMENT
EXAMPLE RATE IS THAT STILL
SOMETHING THAT THEY CAN INSPECT
AND ADDRESS FOR CLEANING
PURPOSES I'M JUST WORRIED ABOUT
IWANT THEM TO BE SUCCESSFUL
EVERY ENTREPRENEUR TO BE
SUCCESSFUL BUT I WANT TO.
OVERSIGHT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
BECAUSE WE ALL HAVE TO DO THAT
AND SO THAT'S WHAT I'M ASKING
YOU TO ASSURE ME HAVE ABSOLUTELY
WILL ENSURE THAT GOAL. OKAY
THANK YOU. SORRY THANK YOU
OTHERS ARE GREAT QUESTIONS I
APPRECIATE DOUG FOR THE
TECHNICAL SENSITIVE THIS IS A
VERY COMPLICATED BILL OBVIOUSLY
THAT A LOT OF- AT THREE TO. JUST
LOT THE- NEW IS THAT THE BILL IN
MY- BUT AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE. THE DISK HELLO HEALTH
OFFICERS AND WITH A MINUTE. IS
THAT HAVE COME IS BIG WANT TO
GET YOUR CALLS AS WELL AS MY
GOAL WHICH IS TO ENSURE MICRO.
NEWARS.
TWO PRINTERS I DIDN'T CATCH THAT
PHRASE WE NEED FIRST INTRODUCED
THIS LANGUAGE I APOLOGIZE. AND
THAT'S A PERFECT- TITLE FOR
THEM. BUT LIKE I SAID IT MIGHT
MY CONCERT LIKE ICE IBM. I WAS
READY TO OPPOSE THE BILL WE WITH
YOUR COMMITTEE THE BRIEFING BUT
AFTER LISTEN TESTIMONY REMAINS.
YOU KNOW BEING IN ITS A VERY
OKAY BILL AND YOU'RE CHANGING
AND ERROR CODE OR ESTABLISHING
ENTIRELY CODE SIX. MINUTE STAFF
TO BUILD I DO- AND NOT THAT YOU
NEED MY VOTE BUT I DO I DO
SUPPORT WHAT YOU'RE DOING. THANK. BUT I STILL NEEDS TO BE SOME
TYPE OF. OVERSEE FOR. PROTECTION
NO THAT ANYBODY. 95% OR TO DO
THE RIGHT THING 95% ALL
BUSINESS. DO THE RIGHT THING AND
THEN YOU HAVE THIS ONE BUSINESS
THAT DOES SOMETHING THAT
EVERYBODY FOCUSES ON WHAT THAT
BUSINESS DID. YOU TO WRITE. A
NIGHTMARE FOR EVERY OTHER
BUSINESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THAT. THIS BODY
OPERATES AND SO I DON'T WANT TO
BE THAT I DON'T I DON'T TO BE A
PART OF THAT. I LIKE THE IDEA OF
CURRENT TRIP. I REALLY DO- AM I
A CREEP EXCEPT. IT WILL GENERATE
TAX REVENUE. HELPS PROVIDE FOR
PRO. THERE'S A HOLD. OF HUGE. TO
THIS. BUT WE STILL HAVE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE PUBLIC IS
PROTECTED AS WELL AS FOR ME
WHICH IS PERFECT. AND GREAT.
THANK YOU. GROW BY APPRECIATE
THE COMMENTS AND ABSOLUTELY
WE'RE TRYING TO GET TO THAT GOAL
SO THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. K.
BECAUSE I HAVE A FEW COMMENTS-
SO OF ALL AGAIN YOU SO MUCH IT'S
ALWAYS FOR WORKING WITH-
COMMITTEE STAFF AND- AND OF
COURSE SPONSORS AND- ALSO
WORKING AND WORK AT THE
OPPOSITION- THIS IN MANY WAYS
THE WORK IN PROGRESS BUT YOU
TOOK MANY AMENDMENTS- TO DROP.
YOUR CONTINUED YEAH. I'M IN MANY
WAYS CEREBRAL- I WAS HAVING THE
SAME KIND OF COVERAGE WITH THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSORS PRIORS WE
WERE CRAFTING THE AMENDMENTS-
THAT ARE BEFORE YOU TODAY-
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY- I MEAN I
WOULD LIKE TO SHARE YOUR GOAL OF
LET'S TRY TO BRING THE STREET
VENDORS- UNDER THE SYSTEM. WITH
THE PERMITS AND SO FORTH. BUT
ALSO THE PERMIT ITSELF HAS TO
MEAN SOMETHING RIGHT IT IS THIS
IS YEAH- SO I LOVE THE LICIOUS
FOOD. I JUST DON'T GET SICK FROM
IT I HAVE SEEN PATIENTS GOT SICK
FROM IT AND IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE A LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD FOR ALL THIS THE MOST
IMPORTANT OF COURSE PUBLIC
SAFETY I KNOW YOU SHARE THIS. AT
THE END SO I KNOW THIS IS BY.
I'M GOING DIALOGUE WILL POINT
OUT THAT- YOU KNOW YOU TO
KALONYMUS. WILL BE. THE PACK
CARE. CAP BACK ON. WE'RE HAVING
SOME CONVERSATIONS ABOUT SO FOR
EXAMPLE- I DON'T WANT A
SITUATION WHERE SOMEONE HAS A
MAKERS AND THEY'RE RUNNING.
ACTUALLY FIVE FOOD CARTS OUT AN
ERROR RATE- SO BECAUSE IF YOU
DON'T HAVE TO BE COMMERCIAL
FACILITIES THAT ARE. IN YOUR
TEMPERATURE AND WE GET ALL THE
DETAILS. AND THAT MAY NOT BE
SAFE HOWEVER. THAT ONE AND THE
EXTENSION OF THAT- BECAUSE AND
THAT. IT OKAY RIGHT SO WHAT WE
WANTED. THIS FOR THE
ENTREPRENEUR. AND SO FORTH- IN
THAT SAME TIME YOU KNOW WE DON'T
WANT OF COURSE CREATE A PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUE AND- IN TERMS OF-
FOOD SAFETY SO. I KNOW YOU'RE
WORKING ON THIS I REALLY
APPRECIATE TAKE A MINUTE AND
OTHERS FOR THEIR WORK TO DO SO
FOR EXAMPLE- I AGREE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES BUT
SOME POINT WHEN SOMEONE'S.
UNFORTUNATELY BEING A PERSISTENT
THAT'S THAT FIVE OR THREE OR 21%
THAT JUST YOU KNOW. BOOKS LIKE
THAT YOU'VE BEEN TELLING THEM
AND- FINING THEM AND THEY JUST
DON'T SEEM TO GET IT MAYBE YOU
DO GET IT AND THAT'S BECAUSE THE
BUSINESS. THEN WERE WORD DETERS
ACROSS PAL AT. GET A REP. FORD
SEPT POINT SOMEONE WHO CLEAR IS
PETERLEE VIOLATE OVER OVER AGAIN
AND NUMEROUS EFFORTS AT
EDUCATION WARNINGS AND SO FORTH
WE CAN LET TO CONTINUE SIR FUND
FOOD RIGHT AND ENDANGERING THE
PUBLIC SO I KNOW YOU'LL BE
WORKING ON THAT SIDE OF THE
GOVERNMENT TOLD ALSO TESTIFIED
LIKE YOU KNOW. HOW TO DO IT IN A
WAY THAT AGAIN- DON'T DOESN'T
ENDANGER- IMMIGRANTS DID INDEED
. SURE DON'T HAVE A SEAT FOR
PUBLIC TO. ENJOY DELICIOUS FOOD
AND- AND- NOT REGRET IT THE NEXT
DAY- THIS. IS OF WHAT YOU SAID
SIR I'M SORRY SIR YOU SEEN
THERE'S ONLY ADMINISTRATIVE- AND
ACTION TAKEN IF SOMEBODY
BLATANTLY DISREGARDS THE LAW AND
DOESN'T COME. JEFF THIS THAT NO
HE'S JUST LIKE THE REST FOR
RESTAURANT THE IN BRICK AND
MORTAR. DID SOMETHING. AND
THERE'S ALWAYS IT MINUTES OF
TRAINING WHICH REQUIRED RATED
RIGHT YES THERE'S ADMINISTRATIVE
PENALTIES CORRECT IT ON STREET.
YES BUT NOT. WELL ARE THEY ARE
DOLLARS IN FOR THE FIRST
VIOLATION EIGHTY TO A HUNDRED
DOLLARS FOR THE FIRST VIOLATION
AND THEN GOES UPWARDS FROM THERE
OKAY SO AND SO YOU ARE GOING TO
ADDRESS IF THERE IS THAT 5% OR
WHATEVER THE NUMBER IS WILL WORK
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT THAT BUT
AGAIN I DON'T WANT THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF OTHER COME INTO ASIDE
FROM JUST THE RETEST THE RETAIL.
HEALTH AND FOOD CODE NUMBER
AFTER MORE LOCAL ISSUES I DON'T
I'M GONNA DRESS AND I DON'T WANT
TO CONFLATE THE TREND AND MAKE
THAT ALL OF THE STREET FOOD
VENDOR ISSUE BECAUSE I THINK
THAT IT IS. WORKING THE CITY
LIKE SAN SAN FRANCISCO TO
ADDRESS THOSE OKAY TO MAKE THEM
COMPLETELY FROM THIS BILL JUST
LOOKING AT AGAIN MODERNIZING THE
RETAIL HELP. I JUST HAVE A.
MINUTE PENALTIES FOR. YOU FOR.
AND YOUR- RIGHT NOW I THINK IT
UP. REYES CELL AGAIN I KNOW
THAT- AND WE HEARD THE- STATE
YOUR WORKING WITH. A MENTAL
OFFICER I WANT THAT ONE OF A
KIND OF THAT YOU BROUGHT IT UP
ALSO BY DOES ONE BRING IT UP IS
THAT- CERTAINLY I'VE HEARD. FROM
PEOPLE CONCERNED ABOUT-
SOMETHING ELSE THAT DID ISSUES
IN TERMS OF WHAT'S HAPPENING
ZANUCK APPEARED OTHER OTHER
AREAS- AND WE NEED. BUT YOUR
BILL FOCUS IN MY MIND ON THE
FOOD SAFETY PART RIGHT AND
SAYING THAT WE WANT TO BRING
PEOPLE IMMIGRANTS OTHER PEOPLE.
IN UNDER THE PERMITTED SYSTEM
AROUND FOOD SAFETY WORKING WITH
PUBLIC HEALTH. SO WELL CERTAINLY
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
ADDRESS THESE OTHER ISSUES. I
GUESS I WOULD SAY IS I HOPE AND-
I KNOW THAT SURROUND AND WE'RE
NOT HEARING HIS BILL HERE TODAY
BUT- ACTUALLY THE ISSUES THAT.
YOU WANT THE DRIPS REALLY ON
HEALTH COMMITTEE ISSUES PER SE.
SO I THEY ARE ON THE DRESS WE
NEED TO. THE ISSUES BUT- IT'S
NOT REALLY THE ROUND THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND I THINK YOUR BILL
IN MY MIND IS TO ADDRESS. THE
HEALTH CODE ISSUES AND WE SHOULD
PERHAPS THINK ABOUT OTHER PEOPLE
WHAT INTRODUCED LEGISLATION TO
ADDRESS THE OTHER ISSUES. THAT
SHOULD BE TO DEFICIT I THOUGHT
RELATED BUT THEY'RE SEPARATE
IT'S NOT REALLY I MEAN. IT'S IT
HAS TO DO WITH IT. FIFTY IS I'M
SORRY APPRECIATE SO IN MY MIND-
THIS BILL SHOULD CONTINUE BEFORE
I CONTINUE TO CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE OPPOSITION I KNOW YOU FIXER
COMMITTED TO SAYING THAT LET'S
LOOK AT WHAT THINGS- NEED TO
HAVE- PERHAPS STRONGER. TUNES IN
TERMS OF CODE AND SO FORTH-
VERSUS THE PARTS THAT WE CAN
JUST LEAVE ADMINISTRATIVE HAVING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS RIGHT
AGAINST THE FOR THE REPEAT.
REPEATED OFFENDERS RELATED TO
FOOD SAFETY- THAT'S GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT SO THAT WE CAN DON'T
HAVE PERSISTENTLY HAVE UNSAFE
FOOD IN THE- AREA- THAT UP BY A
FEW PEOPLE NOW DAPHNE WE WANT TO
LOOK AT HOW TO PROVIDE PEOPLE
EVERY OPPORTUNITY FOR SOMEONE TO
BE ABLE TO. SERVE FOOD STREET
HAS IT THAT BUT AT THE L. SAFELY
SO WE'LLLOOK AT THE PENNY ON
THE NATURE FOOD AND SO FORTH SO
BUILDING ON THE WORK THAT YOU
FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS HAVE DONE AS
WELL. SO AGAIN REALLY APPRECIATE
THE WORK I THINK IT'S AN ONGOING
PEACE WORKS RPG TAKING AND THEN
IT'S BY DUKE'S HOPE TO SEE
FURTHER PROGRESS- AS IT MOVES
TOWARD THE FLOOR BUT I KNOW
THAT- THAT- THAT YOU'RE
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT THE
SPONSORS. AND AND FRANKLY- YOU
KNOW THE TIMING WISE IT'S
HEARING TIMING AND SO FORTH THAT
I THINK WELL WE SHOULD REALLY
PROGRESS WITHIN STATE YOU'RE
ACCEPTING TO. AND LOOKING
FORWARD TO THAT CATCHING WORK IN
EVERY STATE THIS. IS EVERYONE
SAID IT'S A BILL OF MOVING. AT
ALL AND REYES SURE YOU POINT US
ALL TOGETHER SO- WITH THAT-
ENSURE THAT THERE'S- A DIALOGUE
WITH THE CITY'S AGAIN JUST SANTA
MONICA AND SAN FRANCISCO AS OF
YET HAVE BEEN. BROUGHT UP THE
LARGEST ISSUES BUT ALSO WITH THE
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS READ WE-
APPRECIATE WE REALLY RESPECT
THEIR WORK ONE AND SHOULD. WE
GET IT RIGHT. BUT THIS BEEN AS
NO. ON GOING ISSUE FOR TOO LONG.
WHERE STREET FOOD VENDORS JUST
TRYING TO BE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS AND THIS THIS ECONOMY AND
WE NEED TO INCLUDE. THREE AND
THERE. I GUESS WE ALL- THE
BENEFIT FROM THEIR INCREDIBLE
FOOD- AND THEY ARE HERE AND
THEY'RE PART OF OUR ECONOMY AND
WE NEED TO ENSURE THAT THEIR
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE BOTTOM PART
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
OKAY THANK YOU WAS THERE A
SECOND I FORGOT. OKAY WELL
CENTER AND- FIVE TO PAY AS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
COMING APPROPRIATIONS A SECOND
ADVICE CENTER EGGMAN CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. PAN RIGHT
HAND BY MELINDA'S EGGMAN EGGMAN
HI GONZALEZ AND SALAS I GROVE
AYE GROVE AYE HER TADO LEYVA
LIMON HI LIMÓN I. ROTH RUBIO.
WIENER WIENER AYE. SIX OKAY FOR
BILLS CURRENTLY SIX ZERO HOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
ALL RIGHT I SEE SENATE FORTINO
HERE THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE
WE'VE HAD A DISCUSSION SORGHUM
ITEM EIGHT NINE SEVENTY FOUR BY
CENTER PORTANTINO WELCOME.
CANDIDACY MEMBERS. THANK YOU A
DOCTOR PAN AND MEMBERS I'D LIKE
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THAT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OUTSIDE IN THE
ANALYSIS I'D ALSO LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA FOR B.
TODAY TO CALL PRESENT WITH ME IS
A JOINED UP THERE ON N. B. NINE
SEVEN FOUR WE WILL. COVERAGE
NECESSARY. SIX IMAGING WITHOUT
IMPOSING COST SHARING THIS
INCLUDES DIAGNOSTIC BREAST
IMAGING AFTER AN ABNORMAL MAP.
THE RESULT AS WELL AS DIAGNOSTIC
BREAST IMAGING FOR WOMEN WITH
GENETIC RISK FACTORS ASSOCIATED
WITH BREAST CANCER- THE BILL WAS
SUGGESTED TO ME. BY A
CONSTITUENT WILL ALSO BE HERE TO
SHARE SOME TESTIMONY- SO I'M
EXCITED TO IT CAME FROM SOMEONE
IF I JUST WITH THE- WE IN
FRIENDS WHO. DID BY THIS ISSUE
TO WE'RE HERE TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS BREAST CANCER IS THE
SECOND LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH
AMONG WOMEN HOWEVER EARLY
DETECTION IN BREAST CANCER
DRASTICALLY INCREASES THE RATES
OF SURVIVAL. WHILE MAMMOGRAPHY
SCREENING DETECTS 8290% OF
BREAST CANCERS IN WOMEN WHO HAVE
NOT YET MANIFESTED PHYSICAL
SYMPTOMS SUCH TRAININGS CANNOT
ALWAYS ADEQUATELY. RIGHT ENTER.
SEE THAT MURDER IS ALSO CANCER
WHO HAVE A GENERIC WRITTEN
GENETIC RISK FACTOR ASSOCIATED
WITH BREAST CANCER INCLUDING
CAMRY FAMILY HISTORY ARE KNOWN
GENETIC MUTATIONS OFTEN NEED TO
UNDERGO FOLLOW UP TESTING TO
ENSURE THAT THE ABNORMALITY IS
NOT CANCEROUS HOWEVER WOMEN ARE
REQUIRED TO PAY OUT OF POCKET
FOR THE FOLLOW UP TESTING THAT
CAN COST HUNDREDS TO THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS SUCH BECAUSE MANY
WOMEN FRANK DELAY OR AVOID THESE
APPOINTMENTS UNFORTUNATELY THE
LONGER IT TAKES TO DETECT BREAST
CANCER THE HIGHER THE CHANCE OF
UNSUCCESSFUL TREATMENT. EARLY
DETECTION CRITICAL WITH ME TODAY
I HAVE- OBVIOUSLY SENATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA WHOSE CAN
OFFER SOME COMMENTS AND THEN WE
HAVE DOCTOR LARISSA WROUGHT FROM
THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBSTETRICS AND GYNECOLOGY AND
GUINEY PATAKI IN WHO IS THE ONE
WHO BROUGHT THE ISSUE TO MY-
ATTENTION AND THEY'RE BOTH YOUR
TESTIFIED. THAT RESPECT BUT WHAT
HE SAID HELLO SUMMER. THANK YOU
I WILL BE BRIEF WAS EXCITED WHEN
I SAW THIS CALL RICA COME
THROUGH. MY DESK NOT BECAUSE ON
THE CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
AND WE TALK ABOUT IMPROVING
ACCESS FOR WOMEN'S HEALTH
REGULARLY. BUT I HAVE THE
STRUGGLE EVERY YEAR WITH MY
PROVIDER AS I GO AND I TOLD MY
BREASTS ARE TOO DENSE AND I GOT
A LETTER TELLING ME THAT WELL I
HAD A MAMMOGRAM I SHOULD
PROBABLY DO SOMETHING ELSE. AND
IT BETWEEN IS THE NEXT OPTION
BUT THEN. I HAVE TO. BUY WITH.
MY FROM. TWO BILLION. MAKE THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR ME TO SEE A
SPECIALIST THANK THE MEN. AND
THEY DO HAVE THE STRUGGLES OF DO
I HAVE TIME FOR THIS. AND I HAVE
TO REMIND MYSELF THAT I NEED TO
MAKE I AM EXCITED. TO BE PART OF
THIS THAT'S A TO SIX. EVER OUT
THERE. AND SO BUT IT FEELS A
LITTLE RIDICULOUS I KNOW I HAVE
TO PLAY THIS GAME EVERY YEAR
WITH MY PROVIDER WHEN THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT RUNS IN MY
FAMILY. HAVE A HISTORY MONSELL I
THINK THE CONSTITUENT FROM IS
THE PRINTING. THIS VOTE. IF IT
THAT TIME ALREADY. HE SEEMS TO.
I AND I WANTED THE SENATOR ON
THE COMMITTEE THE WORK ON THIS
AND WITH. ASK NAY BUT WHEN IT'S
APPROPRIATE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CENTER- FIRST. SO NOW WE'RE
GOING TO THE WITNESS INSTEAD. I
BELIEVE THERE ARE TWO ONES ON
THE PHONE ONCE IN. SO WHICH ONE
DID YOU WANT TO TAKE FOR.
REPORTER WICHITA YOU WANT. I SO
I HAVE A MY LIST I KERN HAVE
THAT THROUGHOUT FIRST OKAY IF
THAT- BUT I'LL TAKE WHATEVER
ORDER YOU WISH SO- MODERATOR
CAME PLEASE BE ON THE LINE DR
LAURA SURRATT FROM AMERICAN
COLLEGE OF OBSTETRICS AND
GYNECOLOGY AND SOME MINOR YOU
EACH HAVE. TWO MINUTES TOTAL FOR
MINUTES BETWEEN YOURSELVES. AND
IF YOU GO OVER IT TAKES TIME
AWAY FROM THE PATIENT WHO'S HERE
SO PLEASE DON'T DO THAT. I'LL
GIVE YOU TO MAKE A CALL IT TWO
MINUTES. DR LARA DOCTORAL AROUND
. YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES PLEASE
BEGIN. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
MISTER KAREN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DR LAURA STURROCK AND I'M AN
OBGYN IN PRIVATE PRACTICE FOR
THIRTY TWO YEARS IN PASADENA. I
AM ALSO THE NEED. COLLEGE OF
OBGYN DISTRICT NINE REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA AND WE ARE SPONSORS
OF SB NINE SEVENTY FOUR. THANK
YOU FOR HEARING ME TODAY. I WANT
TO BEGIN WITH A BRIEF EXAMPLE OF
ONE OF MY PATIENTS. MARIA THE
FIFTY TWO YEAR OLD WOMAN WHO
FOLLOWING HER ANNUAL MAMMOGRAM
WAS TOLD SHE HAD INCREASED
BREAST CANCER RISK YOUR FAMILY
HISTORY AND SHOULD HAVE AN MRI.
SHE DID THIS BUT THEN RECEIVED
AN EIGHT HUNDRED DOLLAR BILL AS
HER INSURANCE DID NOT COVER THE
SIX. SHE TOLD ME SHE WOULD NOT
HAVE DONE THAT MRI IF SHE HAD
KNOWN IT WOULD BE. OUT OF POCKET
EXPENSE. THE COST OF COMPLETING
BREAST CANCER SCREENING SHOULD
NOT BE A BARRIER TO APPROPRIATE
SCREENING. DURATION LIKE THIS
OCCUR ALMOST DAILY IN MY
PRACTICE. UNDER THE ACA
SCREENING MAMMOGRAM IS COVERED
BUT IN ABOUT 10% OF CASES THE
IMAGING OF ABNORMAL OR DEEMED
INCOMPLETE FOR INTERPRETATION.
AND ADDITIONAL STUDIES ARE
REQUIRED. THIS CREATES A HEAVY
BURDEN ON THE PATIENT SPOKE
EMOTIONALLY AND FINANCIALLY WHEN
SHE MUST PAY OUT OF POCKET FOR
THESE ADULTS I THINK. FIFTEEN
SEVENTY FOUR WHAT COVERAGE FOR
HAVE ASKED. WITHOUT BECAUSE SHE
- IT WILL ALL COVER IMAGING
INDICATED WHEN RISK BASED ON
FAMILY HISTORY OR GENETIC
MUTATIONS X. TRAINING THAT.
ENABLES EARLY DIAGNOSIS AND THIS
RESULTS IN DECREASED CANCER
MORTALITY IN WOMEN OF AVERAGE
RISK. ALL BACKED FOR FALSE
POSITIVE OR INCONCLUSIVE RESULTS
NEXT THE STAFF TO TAKE FURTHER
IMAGING CAUSING ANXIETY STRESS
AND FINANCIAL BURDEN SB NINE
SEVENTY FOUR WOULD ELIMINATE THE
COST SHARING BURDENS AND REDUCE
THE PREPARED CARE TO COMPLETE
SCREENING PROCESS. AFTER
CONSIDER AND SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SEVENTY FOUR BUT THE HEALTH OF
WOMEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU- WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT WITNESS- GUY AND- G. C. CAN
HOPEFULLY PUT AN END TO THE SKIN
OKAY WELCOME THANK YOU HI THANK
YOU DR PAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DIANA POSSESS YOU
KNOW I'M A RESIDENT OF GLENDALE
CALIFORNIA. SB NINE SEVEN FOUR.
THE END OF FOR WITH ALLEGE.
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO SAVE LIVES
WITH EARLY BREAST CANCER
DETECTION WITH DIAGNOSTIC
IMAGING HELPING NOT JUST WOMEN
WHO ARE AFFECTED BY FAMILY
FRIENDS AROUND THE- WHEN A WOMAN
. SHE HAS TO HAVE A MORE
ADVANCED SCREENING THAT'S SCARY
AND STRESSFUL. I KNOW BECAUSE I
WENT THROUGH THIS MYSELF I WENT
FOR MY OWN SCREENING BECAUSE OF
THE RAMPANT AMOUNT OF BREAST
CANCER. AROUND ME INCLUDING MY
MOTHER AND TO GET MY OWN FRIENDS
. IN ADDITION TO THINGS THAT
HAVE TESTING. THING NEXT. BILL
AND THEN THE BURDEN OF HOW DO I
PAY FOR THIS IS AWFUL AND
UNNECESSARY. WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA
CAN NOW KNOW THAT YOU TOOK THE
TIME TO MAKE SURE THEY ONLY HAVE
TO GO AND MAKE AN APPOINTMENT.
TO GET THEIR NECESSARY
MAMMOGRAMS WITHOUT WORRYING
ABOUT HOW TO PAY FOR IT OR HAVE
TO WAIT TO SAVE UP FOR THAT
DIAGNOSTIC IMAGING WITH CRUCIAL
TIME PASSING. THE EIGHTY AND-
PHONE OF. NICE THIS WITH MY-
BROWN ME IS AN ALARM FROM MY OWN
ALL GIRL HIGH SCHOOL I CAN'T
EVEN BEGIN TO TELL YOU THE
AMOUNT OF SUPPORT THAT I
RECEIVED THANK YOU TO SENATOR
PORTANTINO AND TO ALL THOSE WHO
HAVE SUPPORTED THIS MEASURE ON
BEHALF OF ALL THE WOMEN IN
CALIFORNIA. BACK TO RISK YEAH-
I'VE THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
VERY MUCH THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TO SHARE YOUR PERSONAL
STORY. WELL NOW WE WANT TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OF SB NINE SEVENTY FOURTH ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED PLEASE COME UP
THE MICROPHONE NAME OR IS. BE A
PLASTICS THIS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE BRANDON MARCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. I
SEE NO OTHER WITNESSES
APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO SHOULD TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB. NINE SEVENTY
FOUR. OKAY IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
ZERO. OUR FIRST WILL COME FROM
LINE ONE FORTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NUMBER
ONE. HELLO THIS YES PLEASE
INTRODUCE YOURSELF NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION. HI MY
NAME IS REALIZED IN REMEMBER
MANGER TO RALLY FOR YOUR
OPPONENT AND I WE'RE ACTUALLY
WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
I CAN DISAGREE OKAY THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR HELP. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WHAT. WELCOME
WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR NOW MOVES TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- WE HAVE
PRESTIN YOUNG FROM THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE-
YOU WILL SET IT TO IT THIS IS
YOUR PERMITTED UP TO FOUR
MINUTES BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO
USE THE ENTIRE TIME YOU DON'T
WISH. I DON'T THINK I WILL THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PRESTON
YOUNG FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE. THE OPPOSITION THAT
WE OFFER TODAY- IT WITH RESPECT
OF COURSE IS IN LINE WITH WHAT
WE HEARD EARLIER IN S. B. E. A
FIFTY THREE SB. NINE SEVENTY
FOUR IS- CERTAINLY A VERY WELL
INTENTIONED BILL UNFORTUNATELY
DOES COME- ALONG WITH A COST
INCREASE FOR EMPLOYER AND
EMPLOYEE PREMIUMS SO. LOOKING AT
THE CALIFORNIA. AND NOW. THIS
PARTICULAR BILL IT HAD A FIFTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR ESTIMATE
WHEN IT CAME TO PREMIUM
INCREASES IF THE BILL WENT INTO
EFFECT. IN REGARDS TO EMPLOYEE
PREMIUMS THOSE WOULD RISE OVER
TWENTY THREE MILLION DOLLARS SO.
LOOKING AT THE BILL AND
ISOLATION IS ONE THING BUT
LOOKING AT IT- CUMULATIVELY WITH
THE OTHER MANDATE BILLS THAT
HAVE COME ALONG THIS YEAR
ESPECIALLY JUST WITH THE MANDATE
WE HEARD EARLIER- JUST MANDATES
WE HEARD TODAY WOULD BE AN
EIGHTY TWO MILLION DOLLAR
PREMIUM INCREASE FOR EMPLOYERS
IF THEY ALL WENT THROUGH AS
DOES. SO THAT'S THE CONCERN. IS
THE COST OF CASH THE COME ALONG
WITH THIS ESPECIALLY TO THE
NUMBERS I CITED EARLIER A- JOB
BASED ON. ONLY CAN HELP YOU WITH
OVER TWENTY TWO DOLLARS ANNUAL
SO WE LOOK AT HEALTH CARE COST
DRIVERS WE HAVE TO BE COGNIZANT
ABOUT WHATTO DOING THAT SO
AGAIN IT'S A RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION IT'S A VERY WELL
INTENTIONED BILL- BUT THAT'S THE
REASON FOR THE OPPOSITION TODAY
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
CONSIDERATION. THANKS VERY MUCH
. HUNDRED SEEN ON CUPERTINO
MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO
WOULD TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB NINE SEVENTY FOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION. ONCE
AGAIN PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SHOW OPPOSITION.
FIRST GO TO LINE TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. VISITOR
MY APOLOGIES IN SUPPORT THIS IS
BOB ACKERMAN WITH A CALIFORNIA
RADIOLOGICAL SOCIETY THANK YOU
OKAY THANK YOU. SIX WITNESS. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q. ALL RIGHT
THANKS FOR MUCH WILL NOW BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. OKAY SEEING NONE ANYONE
WANT TO MOVE THE BILL. OKAY
CEREMONIES STUFF. ALL RIGHT-
THOSE- SIR PORTANTINO AGAIN AS A
PREVIEW BRING THIS BILL THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR WORKING OUR
COMMITTEE STAFF AND TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS I WILL TAKE NOTE- YOU
KNOW GIVEN THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS THE AMENDMENTS ACTUALLY
SAY THAT THEY HAVE TO BE
CONSISTENT MUCH NATIONAL
GUIDELINES. SO IT'S NOT AN OPEN
ENDED- THING- I THINK WE ALSO
TALKED ABOUT THE NETWORK. THE
PLAN. THE STORE IN TERMS OF
SHARE TRIED DIRECT TO IN NETWORK
SO AGAIN THERE ARE TOOLS FOR THE
PLANS TO- THE TO HELP REDUCE THE
COST BUT ULTIMATELY OF COURSE
AND I THINK THIS APPLIES ONLY TO
YOUR BILL BUT SOME THE OTHER
BILLS WE HEARD AND IF YOU HAVE
HEALTH INSURANCE AND IT DOESN'T
PROVIDE YOU HEALTHCARE.
ESPECIALLY THE WITH EVIDENCE
SPACE THAN WHAT ARE YOU BILL.
AND I KNOW THE HELP PORTRAY HARD
TO BE SURE PEOPLE DO HAVE YOU
KNOW CAN. CAN GET ACCESS TO CARE
SO CERTAINLY WE WANT PEOPLE TO
GET EVIDENCE BASED CARE AND-
THAT AND I CAN'T IMAGINE SAYING
THAT. SOMEONE GETTING IT IS THAT
THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH YOU KNOW
IT IS AN EXCESS EXPENDITURE
UNDER PREMIUMS OTHERWISE WHY WE
PAID FOR IT. SO WITH THAT- OF
COURSE DURING YOUR BILL WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU DR
PAN FOR THE SENATE COURSED.
EARLY DETECTION. MEANS THE
TREATMENT WILL BE COMMENSURATE
WITH THAT EARLY DETECTION IF YOU
IF YOU DON'T DISCOVER THE
PROBLEM AND YOU HAVE MORE
INVASIVE SURGERIES AND OTHER PER
. SIX A DRIVER FOR INEC AND SO I
WOULD SUBMIT THAT YOU KNOW THIS
OVER THE LIFE CYCLE OF THE ISSUE
WOULD WILL ACTUALLY SAVE
SIGNIFICANT COSTS AS WELL AS
SAVING THE LIVES WHICH IS THE
MOST IMPORTANT PARTS SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE OKAY- SO IT'S BEEN
MOVED THAT SO THE MOTION IS- DO
PASSES AMENDED AND REFERRED TO
THE COMMITTEE APPROPRIATIONS
IT'S BEEN SECONDED BY SEVERAL
AMOUNT SINCE OWN PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL HAND I CAN'T. THIS SALAS HI
GONZALEZ I GROWTH FOR TADO LEYVA
THE MOON THANK LIMON I ROTH ROTH
BY RUBIO WIENER. OKAY SO THE
CURRENT VOTERS FIVE ZERO WILL
KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS RIGHT LET'S NOW MOVE ON
TO ITEM NUMBER NINE SB NINE
EIGHTY SEVEN. YOU KNOW. THANK
YOU A DOCTOR PAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE MEMONS-
AND THANK YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH MY STAFF AND THE
SPONSORS ON GETTING THE BILL TO
THIS POINT- TODAY I'M PRESENTING
SP NINE EIGHTY SEVEN THE
CALIFORNIA CANCER CARE EQUITY
ACT WHICH WOULD MAKE MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES WHO ARE BEEN DISK
DIAGNOSED WITH A COMPLEX CANCER
ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE AN ACCESS
THE SERVICE OF AN NCI DESIGNATED
CANCER CENTER. FORTUNATELY THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT DISPARITIES IN
CANCER PATIENT ACCESS TO
SPECIALIZED CARE SB NINE EIGHTY
SEVEN ALLOWS PATIENTS TO ACCESS
THE EXPERTS OF THE LATEST
ADVANCEMENTS IN CANCER CARE TO
PROVIDE THE MOST OPTIMAL CARE
FOR PATIENTS THESE TREATMENTS
INCLUDE GENOMIC TESTING
PRECISION MEDICINE BASED CARE
SUBSPECIALTY EXPERTISE AND
CLINICAL TRIALS NINETY SEVEN THE
CALIFORNIA CANCER EQUITY ACT
WILL IMPROVE CANCER CARE ACCESS
AND ULTIMATELY IMPROVE CANCER
CARE OUTCOMES FOR MANY FROM
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE DOCTOR HARLAN.
LEVAN PRESIDENT OF THE US
STRATEGY IN BUSINESS VENTURES
FIRST TO BE OF HOPE AND ON THE
PHONE I HAVE AUTUMN OGDEN
DIRECTOR OF STATE LEGISLATION
FOR THE AMERICAN CANCER SOCIETY
. THANK YOU SIR PORTANTINO SO-
WILL BEGIN WITH A DOCTOR HARLAN
LEVINE FROM THE CITY OF HOPE YOU
HAVE TWO MINUTES- TOTAL FORM IS
BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU SO YOU GO
OVER. SHE HAS LESS TIME AND I
WILL GIVE YOU TWO MINUTE CALL IF
WE WILL GET TWO MINUTES A
WELCOME. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT SHERMAN PANDA
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BEFORE
COMING TO CITY OF HOPE
COMPREHENSIVE CANCER CENTER AND
AFTER YEARS OF COMMUNITY
PRACTICE INTERNAL MEDICINE MY
CAREER FOCUSED ON VALUE BASED
CARE AND POPULATION HEALTH
MANAGEMENT ALTERNATELY SERVING
IN EXECUTIVE ROLES AT
UNITEDHEALTH GROUP AND ANTHEM TO
HELP CONTROL COSTS AND IMPROVE
OUTCOMES. THESE ROLES I
WITNESSED CHARACTERS UNIQUENESS
DUE TO ITS PACE OF INNOVATION
THE GROWING PROMISED AND
COMPLEXITY OF PRECISION
MEDICINE. AND THE FACT THAT THE
BEST CHANCE OF CURE IS THE FIRST
CHANCE SECURE. I CAME T SEE THE
CANCER CARE IS INDEED DIFFERENT
. WE DON'T MODIFY OUR CURRENT
SYSTEM TO EMBRACE THE DOES THIS
DIFFERENCE LIVES WILL BE
UNNECESSARILY LOST. THIS YEAR
MORE THAN A HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA'S WILL HEAR
THE TERRIFYING WORDS YOU HAVE
CANCER. THANKFULLY OVER THE LAST
THIRTY YEARS MORTALITY RATES
HAVE DECREASED BY THIRTY ONE
PERCENT. BUT NOT MANY CONNECTS
ACCESS THIS AMAZING INNOVATION
DRIVING THESE IMPROVEMENTS. AND
INDEED THE GAP IS WIDENING FEWER
THAN HALF A CALIFORNIA CANCER
PATIENTS RECEIVE CAROLINE WITH
NATIONAL GUIDELINES TODAY. THIS
TUITION IS WORSE FOR. SOMEONE TO
SERVE COMMUNITIES. THE STUDY
PUBLISHED BY THE UC DAVIS CENTER
OF POPULATION HEALTH SHOWS
MEDICARE PATIENTS DO WORSE THAN
THOSE WITH OTHER TYPES OF
INSURANCE AND IN SOME CASES DO
WORSE. THAN THOSE WITH NO
INSURANCE AT ALL. MOREOVER
MEDICARE PATIENTS. CELESTE BE
MINCED CLINICAL TRIALS OR CARE
FROM SUBSPECIALISTS LIKE THOSE
AVAILABLE AT THE NATIONAL CANCER
INSTITUTE DESIGNATED
COMPREHENSIVE CANCER CENTERS.
THE CALIFORNIA. CANCER CARE
EQUITY ACT WOULD CHANGE THAT AND
REMOVED A KEY BARRIER THAT
PREVENTS CALIFORNIA MINORITIES
AND THOSE FROM UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES FROM ACCESSING
APPROPRIATE CANCER CARE. SOME
WILL ARGUE THAT THIS IS
DISRUPTIVE TO THE STATUS QUO AND
INCONVENIENT FOR THE HEALTH
PLANS THIS. SURGICALLY AFTER TO
ADDRESS. I DEFINED IN RELATIVELY
SMALL LIST OF CONDITIONS WHERE
OUTCOMES ARE THE MOST VARIABLE A
MATTER OF LIFE AND DEATH. AND
ARE BOTH ADDRESSABLE AND
AFFORDABLE THIS TYPE OF COVERAGE
MODEL ALREADY EXISTS THE MEDIC
CAL FOR OTHER LIFE THREATENING
NEEDS LIKE BONE MARROW
TRANSPLANT AN ORGAN TRANSPLANT
AND OTHER RARE GENETIC
DISORDERS. WE DO NOT BELIEVE.
THAT WE SHOULD ALLOW THE
NIRVANA. FOR THE BUSINESS OF
MEDICINE TO STAND IN THE WAY OF
ALLOWING ACCESS TO THE RIGHT
EXPERTISE FOR A SMALL NUMBER OF
VULNERABLE CANCER PATIENTS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE PASSAGE.
AND ASK FOR YOUR I. ABOUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH
TALKED LEVINE- WATER PLEASE
BRING ON THE LINE- AUTUMN OGDEN
SMITH- FROM THE AMERICAN CANCER
SOCIETY CANCER ACTION NETWORK
YOU HAVE A MINUTE. AND FORTY
SECONDS. MEMBERS AUTOMOTIVE NEXT
WEEK THE AMERICAN CANCER SCIETY
CANCER ACTION NETWORK HERE IS
THE PRODUCT CODE SPONSOR. SENATE
BILL NINE EIGHTY SEVEN WILL
IMPROVE ACCESS TO CANCER CARE
FOR THOSE WHO NEED IT THE MOST.
AMAZING ADVANCES IN CANCER CARE
CREATING MORE EFFECTIVE
TREATMENTS. AND CURES FOR
PATIENTS AFFECTED BY CANCER.
HOWEVER MANY CANCER PATIENTS
WITH COMPLEX THERE ARE NO SEATS.
ARE NOT GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BENEFIT. FROM THE KNOWLEDGE AND
LEVEL OF CARE. THERE IS NO
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS TO CARE
FOR MEDI CAL PATIENTS. AND
MEDICAL PATIENTS HAVE A LESS
THAN FAVORABLE FIVE YEAR
OUTCOME. ALTHOUGH MOST CANCER
PATIENTS RECEIVE QUALITY CARE IN
COMMUNITY SETTINGS. MANY CASES
PATIENTS WITH COMPLEX CANCER
DIAGNOSES REQUIRED THE
EXPERTISE. ON THE LATEST
ADVANCEMENTS IN CANCER CARE TO
PROVIDE THE MOST OPTIMAL CARE.
CLINICAL TRIALS. CONTROL AND THE
CARE CAN PATIENTS. NPR
DESIGNATED CENTERS PROVIDE STATE
OF THE ART RESEARCH AND CARE
THAT WILL IMPROVE THE SURVIVAL
OUTCOMES FOR THESE PATIENTS. OUR
CURRENT ONE SIZE FITS MOST
SYSTEM PREVENT YOU MANY. CANCER
PATIENTS REMAIN. OPTIMAL CARE
AND YOU MANY OF OUR POOR AND
UNDER RESOURCE CALIFORNIANS DO
NOT HAVE ACCESS TO THE CARE THAT
THEY NEED. SB NINETY SEVEN WILL
BRIDGE THE HEALTH EQUITY GAP BY
ENSURING MEDICAL PATIENTS
RECEIVE THE SAME QUALITY OF CARE
AT NON MEDICARE PATIENTS. FOR
THESE REASONS I URGE YOUR VOTE
ON SB NINETY EIGHTY SEVEN TODAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES A SUPPORT
SB NINETY SEVEN HERE ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED- NAME OR THE POSITION.
OKAY FIELD GRAVES ABOUT COME.
STROKES THANK YOU IT. JENNIFER
SNYDER MAY HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. CENOVUS GOING FOR THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHICH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
EIGHTY SEVEN NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. OKAY PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SHOW SUPPORT. OUR FIRST CONCERN
LINE TO THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ALEX CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHRONIC
CARE COALITION WE'RE VERY PROUD
TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
MEASURE AND WOULD ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
OUR NEXT WILL COMBINED. OH NINE
ONE HUNDRED NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THAT CAN LEAD THE WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY INTO COURT THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS. ONE MOMENT PLEASE
THEY'RE STILL GETTING THEIR LINE
NUMBER OKAY.
ALL RIGHT ONE MOMENT HERE PLEASE. AND OUR FINAL VOTE COMES FROM
NINE TO NINETY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THERE IT'S OKEY WALLER
SAID ON BEHALF OF EVEN MATCH THE
NATIONAL MARROW DONOR PROGRAM
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
OUR SUPPORT FOR THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANKS WITNESS.
WE HAVE NO FURTHER IN Q. RIGHT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB NINE EIGHTY
SEVEN AND A HALF BUDGET HAMPTON
FROM THE CAP CAN HEALTH PLANS
HERE IN PERSON- WILL GIVE YOU
ACTUALLY THEY HAVE TO IN THIS IS
SO YOU CAN HAVE UP TO FOUR
MINUTES IF. YOU WISH. THANK YOU
CARE I'D FORTUNATELY WILL NOT
WILL NOT NEED THAT MUCH TIME SO
I APPRECIATE IT- GOOD AFTERNOON
SIR MEMBERS DID HAMPTON CAL. TO
STATION PLANS ARE AVAILABLE HERE
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL-
CURRENTLY IN PRINT. HOW DO I
THINK THE AUTHORED THE SPONSORS
IN THE COMMITTEE STAFFER OR
WORKING WITH US WITH ITS VERY
PROACTIVE CONVERSATIONS ON THE
BILL THUS FAR- WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE INTENT OF THE
BILL AND AGREED THAT ENSURING
ACCESS. TO A DISTRICT. SIR
TREATMENT IS CRITICAL- WE DID
HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH THE
CURRENT FORM OF THE BILL-
BELIEVING IT COULD
UNINTENTIONALLY TO SIGNIFICANT.
DISRUPTIONS IN PATIENT CARE-
HOWEVER- WE ARE STILL REVIEWING
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL AND AT FIRST BLUSH THEY DO
SEEM TO ADDRESS MANY OF OUR-
INITIAL CONCERNS. THANK THE
AUTHOR THE SPONSORS AND THE CASE
FOR WORKING WITH US- AND HOPE
THAT WE CAN KEEP THAT POSITIVE
MOMENTUM GOING FORWARD AT TO
ADDRESS OUR MANY CONCERNS. THANK
YOU THANKS VERY MUCH ALL RIGHT.
ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION SB NINE EIGHTY
SEVEN HERE ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED.
SEEN ON APPROACHING A MICROPHONE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN. OKAY ONCE
AGAIN PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
. ONE ZERO. FOLLOWING A FEW
MOMENTS WE HAVE KNOWN IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME OKAY- WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE CENTER
GROVE. I THINK YOU MISTER SHARON
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO GO
FIRST SO I CAN POP BACK INTO
RULES AND- IN BACK AND FORTH. AT
CENTERPOINT CHARACTER LIKE THE
BILL I MEAN I DO I- MY OFFICE
THIS PAST TWO WEEKS IS HELP TO
PEOPLE- THAT NEED MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE AND GET THROUGH THEIR
INTERVIEW AND SLICK SPECIFICALLY
JUST FOR CANCER- INDIVIDUALS
THAT ARE EITHER SOMETHING- THAT
DON'T HAVE INSURANCE FOR REASON.
AND YOU KNOW IT WAS HEART
WRENCHING STORIES SO I GET I DO
UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE TRYING
TO GO WITH IT MY ONLY CONCERN
AGAIN BEING FISCALLY
CONSERVATIVE WELL IS THAT
MANDATING THAT THESE NATIONALLY
RECOGNIZED ORGANIZATIONS ARE
BROUGHT IN. AT THE MEDICAL
FACILITY. OR THE MEDICARE
PAYMENT SYSTEM. I'M PROBABLY
USING THE WRONG WORDS IS THAT
THERE'S NO COST NEGOTIATION
RIGHT IF THEY NEGOTIATED. THAT I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S NO COST TO GO
SOLUTION SO I GUESS ARE THEY
GOING TO BE UNDER THE MEDICAL
FEES THAT ARE ESTABLISHED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IS OR IS
THERE GOING TO BE. THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO SET THE STANDARD AND SET
THEIR OWN FEES SCHEDULE OR WILL
THEY BE UNDER MEDICARE FEES
THAT'S THE ONLY QUESTION I HAVE.
I BELIEVE. I'M SORRY YOUR
MICROPHONE I SAID I BELIEVE
THEY'LL BE UNDER THE MEDIC CAL
FEE STRUCTURE THEY WILL YES SO
EVEN IS NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED AS
KIDS OKAY YES HELLO YEAH YEAH
THEY'LL BE GLAD TO MOVE THE BILL
AND I HAVE TO GO BACK TO RULES
OKAY BILLS AND MOVE A CENTER
GROVE. OTHER QUICK. OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. OKAY ALL
RIGHT- SO- SCENE THOUGH OTHERS-
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH MY STAFF- AND- AND
PRESHEAF- YOU KNOW DRESSING MANY
OF THE CONCERNS THAT WERE THAT
WERE RAISED- BY. NIANTIC WILSON
THE CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION- THIS IS. WHAT COMES
THE HEALTH CARE COVERAGE AND-
AND MEDIKAL- YEAH PART OF IT IS
LIKE WHAT YOU DO PEOPLE WHO
HAVE- RARE CONDITIONS REQUIRE
REALLY HIGHLY SPECIALIZED CARE
RIGHT SO WITH OUR MEDICAL
PROGRAM WE HAVE SENSE ECONOMY BY
COUNTY OR MAYBE COOPER COUNTIES.
ETCETERA AND EVEN WITH
COMMERCIAL PLANS DEPENDING ON
THE AREA RIGHT HOW HOW BROAD
THEY ARE NOW DO WE SURE PEOPLE
HAVE ACCESS TO CARE.
I THINK WE'VE NEGOTIATED THAT
THERE'S A- A GROUP THAT'S GOT ME
LOOKING AT WHICH ONE THE RARE
CANCERS THAT BEST FIT THIS THAT
PEOPLE MOST BENEFIT. I DO WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND YOU POINTED
OUT THAT- THERE'S THAT STUDY
FROM UC DAVIS- THAT SHOCKINGLY
SHOWS THAT- MEDI CAL PATIENTS
ACTUALLY- GOT. TO THE CANCER
OUTCOMES WERE AS BAD AS PEOPLE
ARE UNINSURED AND MUCH WORSE
THAN PEOPLE WHO WERE-
COMMERCIALLY COVERED NOW THERE'S
SOME. TAKE THE STUDY HAD SET UP
BUT- WE NEED TO DO BETTER I MEAN
MEDICAL IS OUR PROGRAM IS OUR
STATE PROGRAM WE DO SURE MUCH
BETTER CARE AND THIS. THIS IS A
STEP FORWARD IN DOING THAT- YOU
KNOW I THINK WHAT ISSUES THAT- I
GUESS I WOULD JUST MENTION BUT
AGAIN I YOU. WAS PRIVATE. YOUR
IS LIKE TO WE JUST CARD ALL THE
IF. BUT INTO ALL THESE BY
MANAGED CARE PLAN BUT- I I'VE
BUT I ALSO. THAT THAT'S THE WAY
WE PAY FOR THINGS AND- SO HOW
DOES A PLAN BUILDING A RISK. IN
THAT CASE SO WITHOUT GETTING
OVERLY TECHNICAL- SO I THINK
THERE'S PERCENT POTENTIALLY
POLICY DEBATE ABOUT THAT BUT-
THAT WOULD BE- CAL. FORGIVENESS
HEY WE'RE INTEREST HAVING THAT
OF. NOT I DON'T THINK IT'S JUST
TIME. WILL JUST DEAL THE WAY
YOU'RE PROPOSING IT AND THEN AND
YOUR SPONSORS AND BUILD IT INTO
THE MANAGED CARE PLANS- BUT IT I
THINK IT IS REALLY ESSENTIAL
THAT THEY HAVE ACCESS AND AS YOU
POINTED OUT THE RATES ARE SET TO
THE MEDICAL RATES- HOPE. THAT-
THE PEOPLE TO GET ACCESS TO THIS
CARE. SO AGAIN. YOU BRING THIS
BILL FORD- THE STRIPES AND SOME
ADDITIONAL WORK TO DO BUT- WE I
THINK WE- ADDRESS A LOT OF
ISSUES IN THE AMENDMENTS. AND
AND REALLY APPRECIATE. YOUR WORK
THERE SO WITH THAT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. YEAH I JUST THINK
YOU DARK THANK YOU DON'T. OUR
STAFF AND MICE. HERE'S SOME. THE
BOTTOM IS THE INSTITUTES- HAVE
THE TOOLS TO HELP. AND FAMILY
SHOULD BE ABLE TO ACCESS THEM I
MEAN THAT'S WHAT IT COMES DOWN
TO AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE OKAY THANK YOU- SO
THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO THE COMING
APPROPRIATIONS THAT SECONDED BY
CENTER GROVE- CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. WITH CAN I CAN BY
MELINDA'S EGGMAN. EGGMAN I
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I GREW HER
TADO LEYVA LEÓN. LIMON I ROTH.
RUBIO WIENER. OKAY THE GARBAGE
FOUR ZERO ALL THE ROLE OPEN FOR
A THE NEXT ITEM- IT WILL BE A
CENTER HERTZBERG HERE SO WE'RE
GOING TO SKIP UP. YOU GET THE
WORD AYE I'D SPOKEN WITH CENTER
CORTESE GAVE ME A COURTESY TO
LIVE TO GO BEFORE HIM OKAY
THAT'S THAT YEAH YOU'RE YOU'RE
HERE- SO WE'RE GOING TO. MOVE ON
SO WE'RE GOING TO SKIP ITEM TEN
FOR NOW UNTIL SENATE FOR TV
SHOWS UP FOR NOW WE'VE GOT. AN
NUMBER ELEVEN SP TEN FOURTEEN BY
CENTER HERTZBERG WELCOME. THANK
YOU SO MUCH RESEARCH SHERMAN
MEMBERS- LET ME BEGIN BY
THANKING STAFF. CHALLENGING
ISSUE TAKES A LOT OF HOMEWORK
AND ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR BEGINNING YOUR STAFF
FOR DOING HOMEWORK ON THIS AND
MAKING THE BILL BETTER I REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. IT'S A LOT WORK
IN YOUR EXPERTISE. SO LET ME
START OUT. LET ME START OUT BY
FRAMING THE ISSUE AS I SEE IT.
THE RATE OF HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
AMONG CALIFORNIANS HAS RISEN AS
WE ALL KNOW TO HISTORIC LEVELS
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD THING.
THANKS TO THE ROBUST
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE AFFORDABLE
CARE ACT AND IT'S WILL STATE
POLICY MEANING AREAS TO MEDIC
CAL IN ROMANS WE CAN PROUDLY SAY
THAT WE LEAD THE NATION. IN
PROVIDING UNIVERSAL ACCESS. BUT
HERE'S THE RUB MEMBERS MISTER
CHAIRMAN HERE'S THE RUB.
UNIVERSAL COVERAGE IS
MEANINGLESS UNIVERSAL COVERAGE
IS MEANINGLESS IF IT DOES NOT
TRANSLATE INTO TANGIBLE BENEFITS
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. FEDERALLY QUALIFIED
HEALTH CENTERS OR OUR COMMUNITY
CLINICS AS WE KNOW THEM ARE
CENTRAL TO OUR MISSION IN
DELIVERING QUALITY CARE TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THEY'RE THE
BACKBONE THE COR STRUCTURE OF
CALIFORNIA'S SAFETY NET AND
OFFER SERVICES TO ALL PATIENTS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR ABILITY TO
PAY. CALIFORNIA HAS MORE THAN
EIGHT HUNDRED FEDERICO THE FIGHT
HEALTH CENTERS OPERATED BY OVER
A HUNDRED EIGHTY PUBLIC AND NOT
FOR PROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
PROVIDE PRIMARY CARE AND I
STRESS PRIMARY CARE BECAUSE YOU
KNOW DOCTOR HOW IMPORTANT THAT
IS DENTAL CARE AND BENEFITS AT
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES TO
MEDICALLY UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES UNINSURED
INDIVIDUALS AND MEDICARE AND OUR
MEDICARE POPULATION. FEDERALLY
QUALIFIED HEALTH CENTERS SERVE
NEARLY SIX MILLION CALIFORNIANS
PER YEAR. AND MEDICARE
RECIPIENTS MAKE UP SIXTY POINT
3% OF ALL PATIENTS AND IN FACT
CLINICS PROVIDE CARE TO ONE
THIRD OF ALL MEDICARE PROGRAM
PARTICIPANTS IN OUR STATE THEY
ARE AS I SAID THE FRONT LINE.
WITH THE CONTINUED GROWTH FOR
SAFETY NET THANKS TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF THIS LEGISLATURE
THIS COMMITTEE AND NEWS. THE
NUMBER ONLY GOING TO GROW AND
CLINICS ARE UNDER IMMENSE
PRESSURE TO RAPIDLY INCREASE OUR
CAPACITY TO MEET THAT DEMAND.
YET UNSURPRISINGLY MEMBERS
CLINICS ARE SEVERELY UNDER
RESOURCED ESPECIALLY COMPARED TO
PROVIDERS OUTSIDE OF THE SAFETY
NET. ALEX FACE CRIPPLING
WORKFORCE SHORTAGES AT
INCREASINGLY HIGH TURNOVER RATES
AMONG THEIR CARE GIVERS. IN FACT
THE CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION WHOSE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL REPORTS TO US HERE IN
THE LEGISLATURE A MEDIAN
TURNOVER RATE OF EIGHTEEN POINT
2% IN THE TO TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SURVEY. LET ME TELL YOU WHAT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE JUST THE YEAR
BEFORE THE TURNOVER RATE WAS
SEVEN POINT 6% SEVEN POINT 6% A
YEAR LATER THE TURNOVER RATE
EIGHTEEN POINT. HOW LISA STOP
THESE CRITICAL CLINICS WITH SUCH
AN EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGE THIS
IS A TIME WHEN CLINICS NEED. TO
ONLY RETAIN THEIR WORKERS BUT
ALSO NEED TO BE STAFFED UP TO
MEETING INCREASING DEMAND FOR
CARE AS I SUGGESTED. THE NUMBER
ONE BERRY TO COMPLEMENT IN
RETENTION IS COMPETITION WITH
OTHER HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS FOR
WORKERS. CLINIC SALARIES ARE
MUCH LOWER AS WE ALL KNOW THAN
THOSE PAID BY COMPETING
PROVIDERS AND WORKERS ARE
INCREASINGLY DISSATISFIED WITH
THE EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGES OF
THE FRONTLINE WORKPLACE
CONDITIONS. SO GIVEN THAT WHAT
DOES THIS MEAN WHAT DOES IT MEAN
WHAT SHOULD WE DO AS A
LEGISLATURE WHAT IT MEANS OR
CRACK THAT CLINICS ARE AT A
CROSSROADS WHERE IT IS
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT TO HIRE
AND RETAIN STAFF TO SERVE
PATIENTS AND MISSIONS TO. TAKE
CARE OF FOLKS. IT ADEQUATE
CLINICAL STAFFING MEANS LONGER
WAIT TIMES AND DIMINISH CARE NOT
ACCEPTABLE. WHICH MEANS PATIENTS
ARE SLIPPING THROUGH THE CRACKS
WE CAN'T TOLERATE THAT ALL OF
THESE CHALLENGES JUST SET US
FURTHER BACK. IN OUR MISSION TO
ACHIEVE GREATER HEALTH EQUITY.
THE LADIES HAVE A DEVASTATING
AND LONG TERM AND LONG LASTING
IMPACT ON OUR COMMUNITIES WHO
CAN LEAST SHOULDER THAT BURDEN.
SO HOW DOES THE BILL THAT'S
BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE TODAY.
SOLVE THIS ISSUE THE MEASURE
PRESENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE LONG STANDING WORK
FORCE SHORTAGES ND ENSURE THAT
WE CAN DELIVER QUALITY CARE FOR
OUR MOST VULNERABLE. THIS BILL
S. B. TEN FOURTEEN CREATES AN
OPTIONAL NEW SUPPLEMENTAL
PROGRAM A NEW TOOL IF YOU WILL.
FOR CLINICS TO TAP INTO
DESPERATELY NEEDED RESOURCES.
ALLOCATED FUNDS WILL ALLOW
CLINICS TO HIRE AND RETAIN CARE
GIVERS INCREASED TRAINING AND
INCREASED CAPITAL INVESTMENTS
FUNDS WILL BE USED TO PAY CLINIC
WORKERS A MINIMUM OF TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR. THAT SOUNDS
LIKE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A
FIFTEEN DOLLAR AN HOUR MINIMUM
WAGE IS A LOT OF MONEY BUT LET
ME TELL YOU COMPLEMENT NOT
CHANGED COUNTY. IN ORDER TO FOR
HIS. A MINIMUM WAGE IF THE NINE
DOLLARS AN HOUR. BY ORDERS OF
MAGNITUDE IT'S IMPORTANT BUT
FUNDAMENTALLY DOESN'T ADDRESS
THE ISSUES BUT IT IS A BIG STEP
FORWARD. SO THIS MEASURE SB TEN
FOURTEEN. ENCOURAGES
COLLABORATIONS BETWEEN CLINICS
WORKERS AND PATIENTS FOR
RECRUITMENT AND TRAINING
PROGRAMS. THESE PARTNERSHIPS
WILL FOCUS ON CREATING PATHWAYS
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR HEALTH CARE
CAREERS IN CLINICS PROVIDING
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES AND
PAYING COMPETITIVE WAGES AND
BENEFITS IMPORTANTLY THIS BILL
ALSO INCLUDES APPROPRIATE
GUARDRAILS. TO ENSURE THE FUNDS
DIRECTED IMPROVING CARE
INVESTING AT THE CLINIC HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE. THE RISK A
SHOULD ASK PARK IS PART OF THIS
MEASURE OF FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE STATE OVER THE
NEXT THREE YEARS RUNNING
PARALLEL TO THIS THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS THE LETTER HAS
FORTY TWO MEMBERS OF THIS
LEGISLATURE OF BOTH HOUSES IN
SUPPORT OF THAT BUDGET REQUEST.
AND WITH THIS INVESTMENT THE
STATE WILL BE ABLE TO LEVERAGE
AN ADDITION. SIX HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN FEDERAL FUNDING. THIS
MEANS WILL BRING A TOTAL OF A
BILLION DOLLARS IN NEW REVENUE
TO SUPPORT OUR CLINICS AND
ACCESS TO CARE. AND I STRESS
THIS BECAUSE AS WE LOOK AT THE
ANALYSIS OF HOW MUCH MONEY WE
PAY IN CALIFORNIA TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HOW MUCH WE
CONTRIBUTE THIS IS ONE OF THE
PLACES THAT WE CAN. GET SOME OF
OUR OWN TAX DOLLARS BACK THAT
ARE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS PAY
GETS FORTY IN FAIRNESS IN THE
PROCESS. THE LIKELY FROM CLINICS
OPPOSING IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE THE REAL PROBLEM WITH
THE CLINIC BUDGET SHORTFALL IS
DUE TO LOW MEDICARE
REIMBURSEMENT RATES AND WE'VE
HEARD YOU TALK ABOUT THAT MISTER
CHAIRMAN MANY TO. AND I DON'T
DOUBT THAT THIS IS THE CASE
MEDICARE WAS UNDERFUNDED IT
EVERY STEP OF THE WAY. THERE IS
NO QUESTION YOU KNOW THAT BETTER
THAN ANYBODY. BUT THAT'S EXACTLY
WHY WE SHOULD BE THINKING OF
EVERY CREATED INVENTIVE
IMAGINATIVE INTELLIGENT
APPROPRIATE WAY TO BRING NEW
RESOURCES AND TO LEVERAGE
FEDERAL DOLLARS TO PROVIDE
CLINICS WITH THESE SUPPLEMENTAL
DOLLARS. THIS BILL. SUCH
CREATIVE MECHANISM. BY
STRENGTHENING THE CLINICS
WORKFORCE IMPROVING WAGES AND
BENEFITS MEMBERS WE STRENGTHEN
CLINICS CAPACITY IMPROVE CARE
FOR OUR MOST VULNERABLE AND DO
WHAT'S CORE TO OUR MISSION HERE
AS A GOVERNMENT IS TO TAKE CARE
OF FOLKS. AND TO MAKE SURE
THEY'RE TAKING CARE OF IN A
THOUGHTFUL AND INTELLIGENT WAY.
HE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
IS ALICIA WALKER A MEDICAL
ASSISTANT. ON EVEN CLINICA. N.
CARLOS OF LUCK GOT IT ALL OF
LIKELY CUT REAL MODEL ALSO IS
OUR STATE IS ON SHE SHOULD BE
HALF OF THIS YEAR YOU. THE
SPONSOR THIS MEASURE THE
PROVIDING TECHNICAL SUPPORT
ANYBODY MIGHT HAVE TO ASK THAT I
COULDN'T OTHERWISE ANSWER FROM
THE MARK THAT I'VE BEEN. AND
CERTAINLY I JUST WANT YOU KNOW
MISTER CHAIRMAN JUST AS A
SIDEBAR I HAD TO MAKE A LIST OF
ALL THE ACRONYMS IN THIS TO
UNDERSTAND THEM ALL BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MANY OF THEM. AND BUT
I'M LEARNING WHAT EIGHT PM IS IN
PBS'S IN YOU KNOW ALL THE OTHER
GREAT SEE IN THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS ARE SORRY YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN. AND A OFFER TO TURN
THIS OVER TO THE WITNESSES AND I
DO AND I PRESENTATION. THANK YOU
CENTER HERTZBERG AND THAT SAID-
SO IT. WHO.
THAT SELFIE SHADED OKAY SO- ALL
RIGHT- SO WE HAVE OUR TWO
WITNESSES- YOU EACH HAVE UP
THEIR TWO MINUTES APIECE TOTAL
FORM IS BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU
SO OF. TWO MINUTES ALSO A TWO
MINUTES SO YOU KNOW YOU'RE
STARTING TO EAT INTO THE OTHER
PERSON'S TIME BUT WELCOME. AND-
THAT LISA WALKER FROM LIFELONG
EVEN CLINICALLY WELCOME THANK
YOU. CAN YOU. HELLO NAME IS
ALICIA WALKER AND I'M A MEDICAL
ASSISTANT- AND LIFELONG MEDICAL
CARE I TAKE VITALS DROP BLOOD
AND I EVEN HANDLE REFERRALS AND
APPOINTMENTSTHAT ARE SMALLER
CLINICS OUR PATIENTS ARE
MAJORITY BLACK AND HISPANIC AND
FROM THE COMMUNITY WHERE I LIVE
I EVEN RAN INTO. SOMETIMES I
LIKE I'M MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN
MY OWN COMMUNITY I'VE BEEN A
MEDICAL ASSISTANT SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWO AND I LOVE THE WORK
THAT I DO WE PROVIDE HIGH
QUALITY MEDICAL DENTAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES OF
ALL PEOPLE IN ALL AGES
REGARDLESS OF THE ABILITY TO
PAY. BUT IT'S A STRUGGLE BECAUSE
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH STAFF WE
ARE PULLED IN TWENTY DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS PATIENTS WAIT LONGER
AND DON'T GET THE FULL CARE THEY
DESERVE TOO MANY GREAT MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE LEAD BECAUSE EVEN
THOUGH WE ARE WORKING AT
LIFELONG THE HEY IS THIS TOO LOW
TO TAKE CARE OF OUR FAMILIES
THAT'S WHY I HAD TO LEAVE. IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT I WAS MAKING.
M. S. IN FAR LEFT INTO A GOOD
JOB IN SAMPLE. I'VE BEEN MOVED
TO ANOTHER JOB AT SIX AT
STANFORD HEALTH CARE WHERE I WAS
PAID OVER THIRTY DOLLARS AN
HOUR. IT WAS WHAT I NEEDED TO
TAKE CARE OF MY FAMILY BUT I
ENDED UP SPENDING FOUR TO FIVE
HOURS A DAY DRIVING TO AND FROM
WORK. I HAD TWO YOUNG CHILDREN
AND THE COMMUTE MEANT THAT THAT
WASN'T GOING TO BE THERE FOR
THEM LIKE I NEEDED TO BE. SO I
LEFT STANFORD AND CAME BACK TO
LIFE FONG THAT MEANT THAT I WILL
WENT FROM THIRTY DOLLARS AN HOUR
TO NINETEEN. FOR THIS ANGEL. SO
TO MAKE ENOUGH SUPPORT MY FAMILY
I WAS WORKING A SECOND FULL TIME
JOB AT NIGHT AT UPS. SO MANY OF
US LOVE OUR JOBS AND THE WORK
THAT WE DO. BUT WE END UP
LEAVING. IN THE END IT HURTS THE
PATIENTS. WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
STAFF. WE HAVE NEW STAFF WHO
DON'T ALWAYS HAVE THE EXPERIENCE
OR LONG TERM CONNECTION WITH OUR
PATIENTS I ASK YOU TO SUPPORT SB
TEN FOURTEEN TO MAKE SURE THAT
OUR COMMUNITY CLINICS ARE ABLE
TO RETAIN. AND TRAIN MORE HEALTH
CARE WORKERS THANK YOU. THANKS
VERY MUCH EXONERATE RIGHT ON
TIME- WERE NEXT UP WITH CARLOS A
VETERINARIAN- FROM LIKE LOOK AT
CLINICA ROMERO. WHAT COMPANY
DOES. GOOD AFTERNOON BUT SOME
PEOPLE CALL ME CUDDLES BUCKET-
COUPLE. CALDERON OKAY A GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS CARLOS LOOK
AT ARNOLD. I'M I'M THE CEO OF
CLINICA MOSTLY ALL OF CUT OUT OF
METAL. A FEDERAL QUALIFY HAS
CENTER IN THE ANGELES COUNTY. WE
SERVE BY MATT PRIMARILY LEAGUE
ONE OF THE YOU KNOW HE WITHOUT
IN THE BECAUSE WESLEY AREA-
EASTERLY. F. LIKELY GOVERNMENTAL
CERTIFICATE OF CONFORMITY
BILLING HE SAID. I DON'T TO
INCLUDE YOU TO SUPPORT TEN
FOURTEEN FOR THE COMMUNITY
PLEASE LIKELY COMMERCIAL METAL
CAN CONTINUE TO CLOSE
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS TO CARE.
INCREASE OXIDATIVE POLICE
SUPPORT THE FIRST PHASE TO SERVE
THEIR COMMUNITIES. BY- MARC SIX
FIFTH CRUCES ARE SERVING ON THE
NUMBER OF. MANY OF HAVE COME AND
CHRONIC BUT WE ARE SORRY TO COPE
EXTRA. PLEASE HOLD RESULTED IN
CHALLENGES. DURING A RETAINER
HEALTH WORK. THE PANDEMIC HEALTH
THE HEALTHCARE WAR MAKE IT
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT FOR FQHCS
TO COMPETE WITH LARGER
HEALTHCARE THIRTY OFFER HIGHER
SALARIES ARE PATIENT IS SAID TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE BEST CARE
POSSIBLE. BUT DOLLARS IMPOSSIBLE
SHE WITHOUT NEW REVENUE FOR
RECOVERY FROM THE BOND IN THE
COMING BASS IN WORKFORCE.
BECAUSE CLINICALLY THANK POWER
MAKES THE- ON THE OPRAH TO
ADDRESS LONG STANDING INEQUITIES
TO ACCESS CARE. CALIFORNIA LEADS
THE NATION WITH THE EXPANSION OF
MEDICAL INSURANCE UNIVERSAL
HEALTHCARE OXES IS BEATING
FOURTEEN SUPPORT FOR FQHCS TO
RISE TO THE CHALLENGES
REGARDLESS OF THE CLINIC'S ICE
OR WHETHER THEY ARE EAGLE FUNGAL
RURAL AREAS. FOR THESE REASONS
ALONG ORDER KOLEKSI ALL SOME
PRESENCE OF CENTERS FROM ACROSS
THE STATE ARE YOU TO PASS SB.
FOURTEEN THANK YOU SHERMAN FANS
AND MEMBERS THIS COMMITTEE BUT A
MUCH THANK YOU MUCH. I WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE WITNESS A STEP OF
ITS TEN FOR ZERO TWELVE. THESE
COME UP THE MICROPHONE. BUDGET
SO ON BEHALF OF THAT YEAH YOU
CALIFORNIA POT COSPONSOR THE
BILL AND ALSO ST JOHN'S
COMMUNITY HEALTH AND FQHC DOWN
IN SOUTH LOS ANGELES AND STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. HI MY NAME
IS TINA DIP I'M- COMMITTEE HELD
ADVOCATES A LOOKING FOR- ASIAN
HEALTH SERVICES VIDEO OAKLAND
AND ALSO TEN TWENTY ONE MEMBERS
AND I'M STRONGLY SUPPORT FOR IT
THE SP TEN FOURTEEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WELCOME HELLO MY NAME
IS FRANK ABOUT THIS- MARKET
WORKER LECTIN CONTEST IN
OAKLAND- WHICH SERVES IN THREE
DIFFERENT COMES IN THE BAY AREA-
LOCAL TO WIN US- YOU KNOW MEMBER
AND I'M HERE SPEAKING IN A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF THAT TENT
I'M FOR THANK YOU. GOOD EVENING
I AM BRANDON DAWKINS I AM THE
VICE PRESIDENT OF ORGANIZING FOR
SEIU LOCAL TWO TO ONE. AND I AM
HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
FOURTEEN. MICHELBACH MANAGER AT
ASIAN HEALTH SERVICES IN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND I'M IN SUPPORT OF
TEN ON TEN FOURTEEN THANK YOU.
WELCOME LUIS CORONEL I WORK FOR
WHAT'S HEALTHCARE- INTAKE
SPECIALIST- OF LOS ANGELES AND
I'M IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
FOURTEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU. HI
MY NAME IS CYNTHIA BROUGHT THEM
ONE OF THE MEDICAL COORDINATORS
AT THE LOS ANGELES GAME THAT'S
BEEN CENTER- WE'RE IN HOLLYWOOD.
WHAT'S HOLLYWOOD. SOUTH LA IN
BOYLE HEIGHTS- MY EMPLOYER IS
ALSO IN SUPPORT OF S. B. I THINK
THANK YOU. WELCOME. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS STAR
SANDERS I'M A SUBSTANCE ABUSE
COUNSELOR AT LOTS HEALTHCARE
CORPORATION IN LOS ANGELES AND I
WANT TO SAY A PLEA TO THOSE IN
POWER TO MAKE A CHANGE THE
SUPPORTIVE FOURTEEN OUR GOAL IS
YOUR GOAL HEALTH SECRET
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU THANK.
PHYSICIAN THANK YOU- NAME IS
CARLOS JUNIOR- OF ADMINISTRATOR
. WEST OAKLAND HAVE CENTER IN
OAKLAND AND I'M A MEMBER OF THE
ACA YOU NUMBERS SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. TEN FOURTEEN THANK YOU
. BOB. STACEY LOPEZ EKG TECH OUT
OF DIGNITY HELD HER SACRAMENTO I
AM HERE FOR SUPPORT OF SB TEN
FOURTEEN THANK YOU. WELCOME
HELLO I'M SHARON BROOKS BOYS AT
THE PATIENT THAT ACCESS IS OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM I AM HERE IN
SUPPORT OF TEN FOURTEEN THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU. DO YOU.
HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SEVEN AS THE- FIREMAN. CARETAKER
I WORK WITH NUMEROUS DIFFERENT
FACILITIES AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT SB TEN FOURTEEN I THANK
YOU. HELLO GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS SHANTI JONES AND I AM A
PRENATAL COORDINATOR SLASH
REFERRAL SPECIALIST MY CLINIC IS
BROOKSIDE LIFELONG IN SAN PABLO
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT- SB ONE
FOURTEEN. THANK YOU. HI MY NAME
IS NATALIA CALLIN I'M A PATIENT
CARE COORDINATOR AND- SAN PABLO.
AND I'M HERE TO SUPPORT S. B.
TEN FOURTEEN THANK YOU. HI MY
NAME IS AS IT WOULD BE NO SIR.
HEY I'M A MEDICAL ASSISTANT AT
THE CLINIC A REMAIN THE SAME OR
LESS CARE I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. THIRTEEN FOURTEEN THANK
YOU. WELCOME ARE YOU GUYS DOING
MY NAME'S GERRY POUR MY REACH
COORDINATOR AT ST JOHN'S
COMMUNITY HEALTH AND SEIU MEMBER
AND I'M HERE FOR SUPPORT FOR S.
B. TEN FOURTEEN THANK YOU.
WELCOME. MY LAST THOUGHT OF THIS
MAY NUMBER S. POWER LIKE IT
YOU'LL YOUR TO SEE WHAT WE
THOUGH THIS SALUTE AND LIKELY
MAKE A HOME WHEN HE THAT ENABLED
THEM BADLY. EVEY ONE MORE THAN
STOLE. YEP FOR YOUR LIFE SEVEN
ESCAPE DORSEY. REDRESS IS CRISIS
. WELCOME HELLO MARCUS WILSON
WORK THEN SURGERY SINGLE MEDICAL
CENTER STOCKTON I'M IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. TEN FOURTEEN THANK YOU
THINK. WELCOME. HELLO ALL MY
NAME IS STILL UNDER CROSS LIAM
EMERGENCY ROOM TECHNICIAN AT
KAISER SOUTH SACRAMENTO AND I
TWO I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE
S. B. TEN FOURTEEN. OKAY THE
CHRIS MYERS REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL I THANK YOU. OKAY SEEN ON
ALSO APPROACHING THE MICROPHONE
HERE ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO SHOULD TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN FOURTEEN
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION. AND
FOR THOSE OF YOU THAT WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN
FOURTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
IN ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT.
RELATED TO IN OUR QUEUE OKAY.
SERVER NUMBER ONE FORTY NINE.
THE AFTERNOON OR GOOD EVENING-
CARE AND NUMBERS JENNIFER MALLEY
THE CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE
TEMPLATE THANK YOU X. ONE S.
THERE TO BE NUMBER TWO SIXTY
NINE ZERO AT. HELLO NICOLAS
CORVETTE FROM UNITED HEALTHCARE
WORKER COMMITTEE ORGANIZER. ONE
ZERO ONE THANK YOU THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. MELENDEZ YOU CAN
SUPPORT OF S. C. TEN FOURTEEN
PLEASE THAT'S ONE ZERO. IT IS
THE. SURE THE TIME WE HAVE NO
OTHERS INTERVIEW OKAY THANK YOU
MODERATOR WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO SB
TEN FOURTEEN WE HAVE TO
REGISTERED- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- BELIEVE ARE BOTH
HERE IN PERSON. AND WITH ANY
MARTINEZ PASS FROM CALIFORNIA
PRIMARY CARE ASSOCIATION I HAVE-
TWO MINUTES TO GET THE OF FOUR
MINUTES YOUR GIRLS HERSELF
WELCOME. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS ANDY MARTINEZ PATTERSON AND
I'M THE SENIOR VICE PRESIDENT AT
THE CALIFORNIA PRIMARY CARE
ASSOCIATION AND THEIR AFFILIATE
CALIFORNIA HELP US ADVOCATES.
CBCA REPRESENTS THIRTEEN HUNDRED
COMMUNITY HEALTH CENTERS THAT
PROVIDE COMPREHENSIVE HIGH
QUALITY CARE TO SEVEN POINT TWO
MILLION PEOPLE. WE APPRECIATE
THE DIALOGUE SPURRED BY THIS
PROPOSAL MIKE THE AUTHOR REMAIN
COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING OUR
STATE'S HEALTH CARE WORKFORCE
CHALLENGES. AND ALL OF THOSE WHO
JUST CAME TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT
ALL OF OUR STAFF A COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS CBCA SUPPORT
QUEUE WE DO FOR OUR STAFF. AND
ALL OF OUR EMPLOYEES COULDN'T DO
IT WITHOUT YOU. BUT WE'RE HERE
TODAY BECAUSE WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH THE
CURRENT BILL AND ARE OPPOSED
UNLESS AMENDED AT THIS TIME. SB
TEN FOURTEEN APPEARS TO PROPOSE
A SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT INTERNET
FOR COMMUNITY CENTERS BUTTE FOR
SPECIFIC WORK FORCE PURPOSES.
OVER THE LAST TWO YEARS HE BCAAS
BEEN PARTNERING WITH THE STATE
AND THE LEGISLATURE TO DEVELOP A
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENT PROGRAM. TO
SUPPORT HEALTH CENTERS HAVE
EXPERIENCED A LOSS OF THREE
FORTY B. SAVINGS DUE TO THE MATH
CALIFORNIA'S YOU TRANSITION.
VISIBLE THIS WAS A CLINICS APPLY
IT FIVE THAT THEY ARE PROVIDING
A- LEVELS GAUGE MEANT. INTEGRATE
PART IN HEALTH CARE. AND MANAGE
THE ARRAY OF BENEFICIARY HEALTH
COMPLEXITIES. THIS IS STILL
ONGOING AND HAS BEEN EXTREMELY
TOUGH BE. BREAK. WELL GOVERNOR
SUPPLE. PROGRAMS FROM OUR UNDER
. OF SEVEN CAME PROGRAMS CMS
EXPECTS MEDICARE DOLLARS RESULT
IN NEW OR- BENEFITS. TO MEDICAID
BENEFICIARIES. THERE IS NO
MENTION OF WHAT NEW SERVICES
WILL GROUP BE REQUIRED IN SB TEN
FOURTEEN. INSTEAD IT APPEARS
INTENT OF SB TEN FOURTEEN IS TO
PAY FOR SALARY INCREASES.
HOWEVER SALARY COSTS ARE ALREADY
INCLUDED IN HOW CAN HEALTH
CENTERS GET PAID WHICH IS KNOWN
AS THE PPS RATE. THE HEALTH
CENTER RECEIVES A PAYMENT TWICE
FOR THE SAME COST THE STATE WILL
RECONCILE THOSE DOLLARS BACK AND
FORCE THE HEALTH CENTERS TO GIVE
BACK THE MONEY TO THE STATE.
ADDITIONALLY WHILE SB TEN
FOURTEEN SUGGESTS THAT THIS
PROGRAM IS VOLUNTARY ONLY AFTER
EACH USE WHO PARTICIPATE IN A
BONA FIDE LABOR MANAGEMENT CLOCK
WHAT BRACING COMMITTEE WILL BE
ELIGIBLE TO ACCESS THE WORK
FORCE FUNDS. THEREBY GREATLY
DIMINISHING THE IMPACT. KIDS IN
OUR MEMBERS AT OUR MEMBER HEALTH-CENTERS ABSOLUTELY OUR
EXPERIENCE WORKFORCE CRISIS AND
WE NEED ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
THIS YEAR WE HAVE PROPOSED
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
. INVEST AND- I'M HERE TO HELP
CENTER. WE WERE BACK OPPOSE THE
BILL UNLESS IT'S AMENDED TO
ENSURE CMS WILL MATCH THE
PROGRAM AND THAT ALL HEALTH
CENTERS CAN PARTICIPATE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
THANKS VERY MUCH WELL NOW MOVE
ON TO OUR NEXT WITNESS IS IN
OPPOSITION- KOREAN SANCHEZ- YOU
HAVE OF THAT- IN MINUTE AND-
THIRTY FIVE SECONDS TWO MINUTES.
UNFORTUNATELY YOU MISTER MEN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
KOREAN CONSCIOUS CEO PRESIDENT
L. PERIPHERAL BODIL. SAN
FERNANDO CEBU WILL VALLEY. AB
BEEN. GIVEN THE SERENA THE PAST
THIRTY YEAR. WE SERVE A POLICY
THIRTY THOUSAND PATIENTS AND
HAVE ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND VISITS A YEAR. OUR
EXPERIENCE OVER THESE MANY YEARS
OF COURSE IS THE WORKFORCE AND
EVEN MORE SO WITH A PANDEMIC. WE
FEEL VERY B. IN THIS PROBLEM AND
CHALLENGE AND HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE LEGISLATURE THE
DEPARTMENT. OF HEALTH SERVICES
FOR THE PAST TWENTY YEARS TO
INCREASE OF THE LABOR SHORTAGE
HOWEVER THE MAIN CONCERN I HAVE
IS THAT COULD YOU PRINT EQUITY
THE ALL OF OUR CLINICS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS MONEY. THERE IS A
MANDATORY PROVISION YOU CANNOT
PARTICIPATE IN THIS IF YOU DO
NOT HAVE A LABOR MANAGEMENT
AGREEMENT. SO I FEEL STRONGLY
THAT THIS. IS NOT ALL OF BENEFIT
ALL OF US AND WE ARE MANY IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WILL
CONTINUE TO FIGHT. OF FOR LOAN
REPAYMENT PROGRAMS EVENTS
TRAINING PROGRAMS AND- FUNDING
FOR HEALTH CENTERS. SO I US
WITHOUT OF FURTHER DO THAT THERE
THIS BILL BE AMENDED BE LOOKED
AT CLOSER IT'S IT LOOKS REALLY
SIMPLE IN THE FRONT I TOTALLY
AGREE WITH THE NEED. BUT IT'S
NOT REALLY SIMPLE AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND COULD HARM
MANY OF US IN IT. DURATION UNTIL
. THANK YOU KAREN COMMITTEE.
THANKS VERY MUCH WELL THE MOVE
ONTO THIS BUSINESS IN OPPOSITION
TO SB TEN FOURTEEN- HERE IN ROOM
FOUR HUNDRED. SAYING NO ONE- THE
- ALL RIGHT SIR. THE RISE ABOVE
ALL RIGHT THERE'S NO WITNESSES
HERE IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED TO
OUR OPPOSITION ADDITIONALLY THIS
I SHOULD SAY ALL RIGHT WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO TELECONFERENCE LINE
SO- PLEASE. THE TELECONFERENCE
WE SHOULD TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO SB TEN FOURTEEN NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION. YOU'D
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION THAT
AND FOURTEEN POLICE PRESS ONE
ZERO. IN ONE ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. CURRENTLY WE HAVE FOUR IN OUR
QUEUE THANK. SERVICE NUMBER
THREE NINETEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHERRY MEMBERS OPERATING MEDINA
ON BEHALF OF ULTIMATE HELD
SERVICES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANKS THREE OH EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBER JOHN IN IRAQ ON BEHALF OF
FARMWORKERS EACH YEAR OLD
EDUCATION AND LEADERSHIP
DEVELOPMENT GILD POIGNANT THERE
WHAT MIGHT TAKE WITH IMMEDIATE
ANSWERS FASTER THAN THE AVERAGE
FOR U. ESTATE IN OPPOSITION TO A
DEFENSE FOURTEEN I THANK YOU
NEXT WEEK. THANK. FIFTEEN NUMBER
THREE FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NUMBER MANUAL MANDAL THAT
REPRESENTS DENTAL UNLESS THE
SYSTEM THE COMMUNITY WHAT THEY
WANT HELLO THANK GOODNESS EIGHT
MILLION SHARES CORPORATIONS IS
THINK BONTA WILL PERSIST S. B.
AND. WORKING Q. X. WITNESS.
TEXAS NUMBER THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON OUT ON THE POLICE ON
BEHALF OF THE NEEDLES THAT ARE
COMING UP AND CRIVELLI WE ARE
POST THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
THANKS TO NUMBER THREE OF. MARCO
RIVERA AND THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF LOCAL BUT IF YOU
LOOK ON FIFTY SURVEY OVER FIFTY
FIVE THOUSAND FARMWORKERS ACROSS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
OPPOSITION SB TEN FOURTEEN THANK
YOU THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS.
AND AGAIN KEEP IN OPPOSITION SB
TEN FOURTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. SURE THE TIME WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN OUR QUEUE OKAY
THANKS VERY MUCH- WILL BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
TO RUBIO OFFICE OKAY. GONZALEZ
SAYS THANK YOU DOCTOR CAN I JUST
WANTED TO- I KNOW I HAVE. CAN
HONESTLY I AM GOING OF COURSE
CAN BE SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL
BUT I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SURE
SINCE WE COME FROM THE SAME.
ARIANNA AND THE SAME PUNISHED ST
LOS ANGELES WITH TO JUST HAVE
THE- OFFICE. AND THE POINT THAT
THEY'RE MAKING ADDRESS BECAUSE
THERE IS THE COMMUNITY CLINIC
LETTER AND- DON'T I KNOW THAT
I'VE I'VE HEARD A LOT FROM BACK
HOME AS WELL FROM VARIOUS.
CLINICS THANK. YEAH BE HAPPY IT
SEEMS TO BREAK DOWN BECAUSE THE
CAN WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
OPPOSITION IS A COUPLE OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES. ONE IS WHAT'S
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT GOING TO
DO YOU KNOW- THE HHS RECEIVED
MASS WERE THEY GONNA DO. WITH
THE REAR. THEY HAVE BUILT.
PROGRAM INTER THEIR CONTRIBUTION
EXTRAORDINARY FLEXIBILITY. IF
YOU LOOK TO BOND. SECTION
NINETEEN OH TO BE BE OF THE
SECURITIES ACT HOUSE THE FLOOR
BILL. EIGHTY
THE ARSENAL LIKE THIRTEEN TO ONE
SAVINGS IN TERMS OF THAT THAT'S
NUMBER ONE. NUMBER TWO THERE'S A
MISUNDERSTANDING I THINK IT WAS
A GREAT DEAL OF ISSUES ABOUT
URBAN VERSUS RURAL THAT'S NOT
OUR NECK OF THE WOODS IN L. A.
COUNTY. IF THIS OPTION WAS IT'S
ALWAYS BEEN THE INTENT OF THE
BILL I KNOW WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
AMENDMENTS. TO ON THESE THESE
ARE- LABOR MANAGER CORPORATION
COMMITTEES THEIR REGIONAL IN
NATURE YOU DON'T HAVE TO HAVE
ONE SET UP OKAY IN YOUR OWN
CLINIC THE COULD BE REGIONAL FOR
THAT WILL ACTUALLY DO THE
TRAINING. SECONDLY THE AMMO YOU
THAT HAPPENED OPENLY YOU COVER.
I'M NINETY DAYS AFTER YOU GET
THE MONEY SO IT'S NOT LIKE
PUBLIC HOUSING GOVERNMENT WHICH
ALWAYS THE CASE- WILL PROMISE
YOU SOME MONEY AND THREE YEARS
LATER YOU MIGHT GET HALF RIGHT.
YOU GET THE MONEY UP FRONT YOU
GET THE CASH CASH CASH THAT THEY
WITHIN NINETY DAYS YOU HAVE TO
SET UP THE TRAINING PROGRAM THAT
WORKS WHICH REGIONAL TO DEAL
WITH THOSE ISSUES AND AVOID THE
PROBLEM IT DOESN'T DEAL WITH
CLINIC IT ONLY RELATES TO THE
TRAINING OF THE EMPLOYEES THAT
DIDN'T HELP. THE LARGER ISSUE
THAT WE'RE THAT WE'RE FACING SO
WHAT WHEN I LOOK AT THAT YOU
KNOW IN TERMS OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT COMING THROUGH WITH
THE WAIVER YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF
THE FLIGHT BILL IF BILL IN TERMS
OF THE STRUCTURE WE'VE GONE
THROUGH EACH ONE OF THESE WITH A
CLICK WITH. EACH ONE OF THESE
WITH THE SPONSORS AND EACH ONE
OF THE LETTERS THAT WE RECEIVE.
A LETTER HE- BROKEN ON THE
PARTICULAR AREAS OF THOSE WHO
JUST MISSED THE CASE. THANK
LATE. ON IT. IT IS A- OTHER
ISSUE PEOPLE ALWAYS ASK IS YOU
HAVE TO BE UNIONIZED ANSWER'S
NO. THAT IS NOT IT. THE LABOR
COMMITTEE THE LABOR MANAGEMENT
COOPERATION COMMITTEE DOES HAVE
UNION MEMBERSHIP. BUT NOBODY
WILL. BE IN YOUR NOT BECAUSE-
LOOKS THEM UP. YOU KNOW YOU JUST
HAVE TO ONE. SAY THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO PAY PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS AN HOUR PRETTY GOOD
THING AND YOU GET A BIG PILE OF
CASH. AND TO. YOU TO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS COMMITTEE FOR TRAINING
WHICH IS READ IN NATURE. THAT
AND COMMITTEE DOES NOT HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER THE INTERNAL
MANAGEMENT OF YOUR CLINIC
GOVERNANCE SO I DO THINK YOU
KNOW PART OF THE NEWNESS OF WHAT
HAPPENS IS WE ENGAGE IN THIS
PROCESS. AND TIME FOR THE BILL
TO JERK EIGHT AND IDEAS TO
GERMINATE THESE KINDS OF THINGS
HAPPEN BUT WE'VE GONE THROUGH
EACH ONE OF THE LETTERS THAT WE
RECEIVE EACH ONE OF THE PAYMENTS
THAT WAS- AND- DOUBLE WE'VE COME
UP WITH A PRETTY INTO. OF COURSE
ALWAYS WORK WITH ANYBODY BUT THE
COURT MESSAGES YOU GOT TO MAKE
SURE PEOPLE ARE PAID AND YOU GOT
TO MAKE SURE THE TRAINED AND WE
GOT TO MAKE SURE THE COMMUNITY
CLINICS OR STRONG FOR PER A
PROPER CARE. COMMUNITY IS A
SPECIAL WHAT WE'RE ON ABOUT. I
THINK THAT THERE RUBIO. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- I
JUST WANTED IT BUT ALSO COMMENT
ON THIS YOU KNOW BECAUSE IT'S
VERY IT'S A IT'S A GOOD BILL BAD
NEWS. POSSIBILITIES OF
OPPOSITION AND YOU KNOW THESE
ARE YOU KNOW ORGANIZATIONS THEY
USUALLY MOVE IN THE SAME
DIRECTION WITH THE SAME GOALS
AND YOU KNOW SUPPORTIVE OF OUR
COMMUNITY B- FOR COMMUNITIES IN
GENERAL I JUST FEEL LIKE IT'S
THERE'S A LITTLE DISCONNECT HERE
YOU KNOW AND- AND I THINK I
HEARD JOB. THE LADY FROM OUTRAGE
LIVE AUDIO TALK ABOUT THAT THEY
WERE ALREADY WORKING TOWARDS
SOMETHING. I SO CLEARLY THERE'S
A LITTLE BIT OF A AND YOU SAID
IT MISCOMMUNICATION. HOUSE BE.
SAFE ABOUT MOST PEOPLE THEY CAME
UP ARE FEELING OR- ON THE PHONE
ARE FEELING LEFT OUT OR PERHAPS
NOT INCLUDED IN THIS YEAR. AND
AGAIN IT YOU KNOW AS YOU SAID
IT'S A GOOD PROGRAM BUT I FEEL
THAT MORE CONVERSATIONS NEED TO
HAPPEN. AT TICKETS SUCH AS NO BY
EVIDENCED BY THE FACT THAT ALL
THESE GROUPS NORMALLY MOVE
TOGETHER AND THEN YOU HAVE. MOST
OF AN OPPOSING HERE TODAY SO.
THAT'S A LITTLE BIT OF A PROBLEM
FOR ME. I WILL SUPPORT IT
BECAUSE I LIKE IT SENATE BILL
BUT AFTER EVERY. ALSO LONG AND I
WOULD. GET GIVE US. CAN I READ
THE- YEAH THE CURRENT SUCH AS IN
FRONT MINE FOR MAYBE THIRTY FIVE
MAYBE FIVE A LONG TIME AND
UNBELIEVABLE IN TERMS OF WHAT
SHE DOES IN THE COMMUNITY THAT I
REPRESENT- WE HAD A MEETING
BEFORE THIS AND IT'S EXACTLY
WHAT YOU SAID PART OF JUST THE
VOLUME METRIC ACTIVITY SINCE THE
PANDEMIC OF NUMBERS OF NEW BILLS
PICK LARGER MORE COMPLEX BILLS I
DO THINK WOULD YOU SAY IS
CORRECT IN TERMS OF
COMMUNICATION. CAN HAVE TO THIS
. COMMITTEE SELF BUT THE LABOR
MANAGER COOPER KUPP CORPORATION
COMMITTEE BUT THAT IS REGIONAL
ALL MY GOD THAT'S- THAT IT IS
INVOLVED. IN THERE BOB MET THEIR
MANAGEMENT ALL THAT'S GREAT
RIGHT SO THE WORLD LOT OF
ELEMENTS EXACTLY RIGHT OF JUST
US. WHERE THERE'S SO MANY
CLINICS WHERE IT'S SUCH A BIG
ISSUE WHERE WE NEED TO CONTINUE
TO DO OUTREACH WHICH WILL
CERTAINLY DO. AND BILL THAT
LEVEL OF COMMUNICATION BECAUSE
EVERY TIME I'VE HAD
CONVERSATIONS TO EXPLAIN THAT TO
EXPLAIN THE SPECS ABILITY WITH
RESPECT TO. HHS FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CMS AND HOW THAT
WORKS AND WHAT THOSE CODE
SECTIONS ARE IN SOME OF THOSE
THAT WE WENT THROUGH WITH THE-
COMMITTEE CLINICS SOCIAIS
HAITIAN AND RESPONSE- LETTER. I
THINK WE'RE GONNA BE A LOT
CLOSER TO WHERE WE NEED TO GO.
WELL I JUST MAKE OUR COME IN I
KNOW YOU SAID IT'S A YOU KNOW
IT'S- THE INTENT IS REGIONAL BUT
I ALSO HEARD. COLORS CALLING
FROM. OUR LIMITS IF I REMEMBER
THE NAME OF THE ORGANIZATION I
THINK IT'S A- IT'S IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY- A LOT OF
FARMWORKERS. STATIONS I'M TRYING
TO REMEMBER THE NAME OF THE GOT
A CALL TO- BUT EITHER WAY I'M
JUST MAKING SURE THAT EVERYONE
HAS. THE ABILITY TO PARTICIPATE
IN AND TALK TO YOU AND LIKE I
SAID JUST. CLARIFYING SOME OF
THE I GUESS MISSING IN MASS
COMMUNICATION AND EVEN AS HE
SPOKE TO. CAREEN FROM BRIEF
LEVINE SAID IT STILL HAVING
TROUBLE WITH ITSELF JUSTIN
INDICATING SAID LITTLE BIT MORE
THE NASA FINESSING IN A LITTLE
BIT MORE. INCLUDE VIDEO ONLINE
AND YOU HAVEN'T BY. FILLING OUT
I JUST HOPE THAT YOU WILL
GETTING EVERYONE TO THE TABLE
AND CONTINUE TO REALLY DRILL
DOWN ON. THE TRACK PLAINNESS
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WE WILL
AND THE PATTERN IF YOU LOOK AT
ALL THE LETTERS THAT WOULD
SUPPORT PERCENT POSITION THERE
WAS A LARGE CHUNK OF THAT WAS.
THAT THIS PHASE. URBAN VERSUS.
OUR CLINIC. IF THE PROCESS UP
EACH IN THE- LABOR MAY. CORP
COME. AND THAT'S WHY THE
CLARIFICATION IN THE COMMITTEE.
DISCUSSION WHICH SIX STAFF WAS
VERY HELPFUL ON. THAT SAYS THEY
CAN BE REGIONAL SO. A NUMBER OF
CLINICS CAN COME INTO THAT AREA.
SO THEY DON'T HAVE TO SET UP
THEMSELVES AND BECOMES EASIER
WITH LOOK AT THIS PATTERN WITH
THE FARMER ORGANIZATIONS AND
OTHER GROUPS. THAT REALLY WAS
ABOUT THE REGIONALLY SPEECH WITH
WHICH THE COMMITTEE HAS DONE A
GREAT JOB. HELPING RIGHT. WE'LL
GET THAT OUT THANK THINK IT WAS
LIKE ABOUT US COMPASS. I WAS
TRYING TO GET RID. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THAT EXPLANATION I
APPRECIATED HER. CENTER EGGMAN.
THANK YOU. AND I DON'T NEED A
LONG EXPLANATION. I NEED A YES
OR NO. THAT'S ALL I NEED.
BECAUSE I HEAR YOU SAYING THAT
PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND AND
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE OPPOSED. ARE
YOU ARE YOU ARE GOING TO WORK
WITH EVERYBODY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN WE SAY WE'RE GONNA IMPROVE
THE CLINICS FOR EVERYBODY. THAT
EVERYBODY WILL HAVE ACCESS TO
THIS. AND HELP THOSE WHO DON'T
UNDERSTAND YOUR CURRENT. AND A
BETTER IS. MEANT TO GET YOU TO
WORK WITH PEOPLE. THAT THE HAVE
A FULL. YEAH IT DOES I JUST.
CHRISTINE JUST TELL ME THE
ANSWER DOES. THE ANSWER THE
QUESTION YES. BUT THE ONE THING
I WANT TO MAKE CLEAR WHICH I
APOLOGIZE BECAUSE BEYOND A YES
ANSWER. IS THAT THERE IS A
DISTINCTION. IT'S THIS
SUPPLEMENTAL COULD MONEY CALMS
AND THESE ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
COMMON THERE IS A TENSION. WHICH
EXISTS IN THIS BILL WHICH WE'RE
NOT GOING TO GET RID OF. IN
TERMS OF THE SPONSORS SEIU. IN
TERMS OF PARTICIPATING IN THIS
LABOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
PROCESS. AND IT'S NOT YOU'RE NOT
REQUIRED TO BE UNIONIZED THAT
WAS MENTIONED. IN A RECORD TO BE
PART OF THE UNION BUT THERE IS
SOME TENSION ABOUT THE HAS
RICHEST. YES ONE OF. WAIT THEY
DON'T GET THE EXTRA MONEY IN
TERMS THE SUPPLEMENT. SO IT'S
CLEAR THAT THERE'S FLEXIBILITY
IT'S CLEAR THAT WILL WORK
TOGETHER WITH THEM BUT THERE
WILL STILL BE TENSION. FROM SOME
GROUPS I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY
IF WE WANT TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
MISTAKE COULD HELP US HERE.
OUGHT TO CLARIFY THAT TO MAKE
SURE ANSWERS THERE BUT I DON'T
WANT TO OVERSTATE MY CASE IN
RESPONSE TO MY YES ANSWER. THAT
MAKES SENSE. NO BUT I UNDERSTAND
THANK YOU. AT SURVEILLANCE THANK
YOU SO JUST TO DOVETAIL ON TO
WHAT SENATOR EGGMAN ASKED I JUST
I THINK WE NEED MORE CLEAR
ANSWER FROM YOU BECAUSE THERE
ARE SOME VERY REAL CONCERNS
COMING FROM THE OPPOSITION THAT
THEY WILL BE LEFT OUT AND I
THINK IN YOUR COMMENT YOU WERE
SAYING YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE-
PART OF THIS GROUP ARE TRYING TO
THIS UNION BUT YOU DO HAVE TO.
HAVE CERTAIN WEIGHT WHICH WOULD
BE- EXCLUDE MANY OF THESE
CLINICS THAT WERE TALKING
BECAUSE THEY JUST WOULDN'T BE
ABLE TO PAY THAT WAGE SO. YOU
KNOW YOU CAN SAY WE DON'T HAVE
TO BE PART OF THIS GROUP BY THE
REALITY. HAVE A OTHER CHOICE. ON
ACCESS TO THE MONEY AND NOT BE
LEFT OUT IN THE COLD SO I JUST
WONDER. IF YOU COULD BE A LITTLE
MORE CLEAR IN WHAT YOU'RE
PROMISING HERE TODAY WITH
RESPECT TO WORKING WITH THE
GROUPS. WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION
WHO ARE FEELING LEFT OUT YEAH
WELL THE REALITY IS THAT FIRST
IT'S OPTIONAL SO IF YOU WANT
ACCESS TO THIS PART OF MONEY. IN
ORDER TO DO SO YOU'VE GOT TO
AGREE TO PAY TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS
AN HOUR WHICH WILL THESE PART OF
MONEY WILL FUND. DISAPPOINTED
MLLION PLUS THE SIX REMAINING
SUING THE FEDS AGREE SUCH A
BILLION DOLLARS. AND SECOND
YOU'VE GOT TO AGREE TO
PARTICIPATE IN THIS- LABOR
MANAGER. BRAYSHAW COMMITTEE. TO
DO SO IF YOU AGREE TO THOSE TWO
THINGS. YOU GET ACCESS TO THESE
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS TO PLAY THOSE
ADDITIONAL MONEY IF YOU DON'T.
AND YOU CHOOSE NOT TO. THEN
YOU'RE NOT PART YOU'RE NOT
PARTICIPATING. IN THIS- THE
PROGRAM UNDER TEN FORTY. OKAY
AND THEN ONE FINAL THING-
BECAUSE IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT- IT FOR ACCESS TO THIS
MONEY NEW SERVICES MUST BE
PROVIDED SACRAMENTO NO NO NO
OKAY SO THEN LET US FLEXIBILITY
IN THE PROGRAM SALINAS DR PAN
CAN TELL YOU BETTER THAN I CAN.
THE BILL THE PROGRM. FOR HIS.
ACTIONS WITH A PROVIDE
SUPPLEMENTAL DOLLARS- AND- CMS
ALLOWS THAT TO HAPPEN SO YOU'RE
SAYING THAT- THAT IS NOT A
REQUIREMENT TO. THESE NEW
SERVICES HELLO IT IS NOT RIGHT
FOR THE BULK REALLY THE REALITY
IS THIS MONEY WILL BE GOING. I
MEAN- MOSTLY TOWARDS- SALARY
INCREASES THE STREET IS THAT
CORRECT THAT'S CORRECT AND WE
NEED SALARY INCREASES BECAUSE
WE'RE LOSING PEOPLE. ABOUT I
MADE EARLIER ABOUT THE TURNOVER
FROM 187% 18% AND THE PRESSURE
THAT ORGANIZING SO WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE IN
COMMUNITY CLINICS ARE PROPERLY
PAID. SO THAT THEY CAN STATE
THAT THEY'RE PROPERLY TRAINED
AND THAT THEY PROVIDE THE
NECESSARY SAFETY NET WHICH IS SO
CRITICAL OKAY A DELIVERY SYSTEM
THAT'S A CLEAR- BUT ACCORDING TO
MY ANALYSIS IT SAYS IT CMS
REQUIRES. THAT SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT PROGRAMS PROVIDE FOR NEW
SERVICES FOR MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES THAT ARE NOT
ALREADY PAID FOR YOU DISAGREE
WITH THAT STATEMENT YES YOU DO.
ASSEMBLY THIS FLEXIBILITY IN CMS
AND I BELIEVE IT DOCTOR PAN
MIGHT BE BETTER IF YOU WANT TO
GIVE SOME TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
OR MAYBE THEY CAN. MAKE SURE AND
MAKE A STATEMENT ON THAT BUT I
IT'S GREAT CORRECT OKAY. FROM MR
THE CHAIR WHILE I'M NOT SURE I
THINK DOCTOR PAN HAS SOME INPUT
I DON'T KNOW THAT- THIS YOUNG
LADY SHE'S THE TECHNICAL PERSONS
ATTACKED OKAY. THAT'S WHAT THE
COURT OR SOMEBODY ANSWER THE
QUESTION PLEASE. OKAY WELL WANT
TO TAKE A CRACK FIRST CRACK AT
THE ANSWER I KNOW YOU'RE
SUPPORTING YOUR WITH THAT HAVE
AN ORDER SAID AND THEN IF WE
COULD ALSO HAVE PERHAPS THE
OPPOSITION- HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO WEIGH IN IS ONE THAT BE GREAT
GO HEAD. ABSOLUTELY UNTRUE SO
THAT'S HOW YOU CAL. SO THE WAY
THE- L. A. IN THE LANGUAGE RIGHT
NOW THERE IS FLEXIBILITY WITHIN
THEIR IT'S DESIGNED AS A
SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS BUT AND WE
KNOW THAT THERE HAVE BEEN.
MULTIPLE SUPPLEMENTAL PAYMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY CMS.
THAT FOR FEEL DIFFERENT CRITERIA
THE FACT THAT THIS SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT PROGRAM IS ATTACHED TO
QUALITY METRICS. IS ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY WE THINK THAT THIS
THIS BILL WILL ACTUALLY BE-
THOSE. CMS QUALITY METRICS WILL
BE SET BY DH CS AND SO THEY'VE
GOT A LOT OF FLEXIBILITY AND
CONTROL TO BE ABLE TO DESIGN IT
TO- WORK WITH THE FEDERAL AND
STATE RULES HAVE ANY
CONVERSATIONS BEEN HAND WITH CMS
RELATING TO THIS ISSUE WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH DHS ON THIS SO
FAR. SEN OKAY NO NOT YET NOT YET
I MEAN THAT WOULD BE HAVE NOTED
SORT OF HAVE THE CONVERSATION
PRIOR TO ALL OF THIS TO KIND OF
GET US A FEELING FOR WHERE THEY
ARE BUT THANK YOU I APPRECIATE-
THE INPUT. DID K. SEVEN MEDIA
JUST THE WAY AND LOCAL CARE. THE
OPPOSITE SO MEDICARE OF COURSE
IS A FEDERAL STATE PARTNERSHIP
SO IN ORDER TO GET THE WAIVERS
GOTTA WORK WITH CMS AND IT'S
THROUGH THE HCSO CMS'S USUALLY
NOT INTEREST TALKING EVERYBODY
THAT WE TALKED TO THE EIGHT CST
EXCESSES IN THE STOCK RIGHT-
THERE IS FLEXIBILITY BUT THERE'S
ALSO A LOT OF RULES THERE SO I
THINK PART OF WHAT WE TRIED TO
DO AND- LOOKING MY CONSOLE THE-
SAME RON HERE. IS THAT WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO WITH THE OF.
THEM IS TRY TO CREATE THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT
CONVERSATION A DH CS- TO SEE
WHAT WE CAN TRY TO DO TO PULL
DOWN THE FEDERAL FUNDS SO. IN
SOME SENSES THE ANSWER IS KIND
OF IN BETWEEN SO IT DEPENDS ON
WHAT CMS IS WILLING TO DO SO
THERE IS SOME FLEXIBILITY IN
SCOPE. THAT YOU NOTICE THAT YOU
HAD THE UP WITH. THE USER. THAT
PROPONENTS SAYS. SHE DID YOU SAY
YOU CAN GO TO SAUDI COULD IT HAS
TO BE TIED TO QUALITY
IMPROVEMENT. CELLS I THINK BOTH
BOTH OF MY BEING ACCURATE IN
THAT SENSE THAT YOU HAVE TO
SHOWS. IT CAN'T IT. CAN'T JUST
BE PASSED STATUS QUO BUT-
EXACTLY WHAT IT IS- THERE'S SOME
FLEXIBILITY THERE SO IF FOR
EXAMPLE WE KNOW THAT- BECAUSE
THE- HELP. THAT TURNOVER AND
OTHER TYPES OF THINGS MAY LEAD
TO POOR QUALITY. THAT WE CAN
STILL IMPROVEMENT IN QUALITY AND
RETENTION AND SO FORTH CERTAIN
QUALITY MEASURES CMS MAYBE OPEN
THE SAME GOOD. HE GETS MORE
FUNDING BECAUSE OF THAT WE DON'T
KNOW UNTIL THE CONVERSATIONS ARE
HAD WITH CMS SO I THINK WHAT WE
CRAFTED THE AMENDMENTS OURS TO
SAY THAT. WE'RE GOING TO CREATE
THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR-
NEGOTIATION WAY OUT THE ALSO
THAT- NO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
JOHNNY HAS TO APPLY ACROSS
CLINICS RIGHT SO IT'S- YOU CAN'T
JUST A SUBSET OF THE CLINICS
WILL HAVE TO BE AVAILABLE TO
EVERYONE. AND AND THEN AFTER
THAT THE PURPOSE OF THE
AMENDMENTS THAT THE AUTHOR IS
TAKING. ONLY BE SURE. THE
SYSTEMS UP. OKAY WELL THANK YOU
FOR THE CLARIFICATION BOTH THE
VIEW I WONDER IF- THE OPPOSITION
MIGHT WANT TO COME UP IN JUST ON
INDY IS IT OKAY INDIGNITIES COME
YEAH I WISH I COULD CITE YOU A
RULE BOOK BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN
LOOKING FOR THIS- WE'VE BEEN
TALKED. OUT UNFORTUNATELY TWO
EIGHT SEIZE IS EASY- BECAUSE OF
HOW WE ARE REGULATED THERE'S A
LOT OF OPPORTUNITY TO THAT BUT
IT'S ALSO REALLY CHALLENGING SO-
S. P. P. IS NOT RELATED TO FQHC
WE TRIED SO MANY WAYS TO MAKE
THE S. B. P. FOR THE PHARMACY
TRANSITION WORK IN THE WAY THAT
WE COULD IMAGINE IT FOR SUBSETS
OF PROVIDERS FOR TARGETING THE
DOLLARS IN A MORE SPUR SEIS WAY
WORLD IRVINE BASED NEED BASED ON
TYPES OF PROVIDERS AND THERE WAS
WE FOUND BASICALLY NO WAYS TO DO
IT- THAT THEIR PAY. A LOT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAID I AGREE
WITH EVERYBODY THAT WE SHOULD
HAVE MORE IN PRIMARY CARE CMS
BELIEVES I THINK IN SOME WAYS
ARE PAYING TOO MUCH. SO THEY
WANT EVIDENCE THAT IT'S NEW AND
IT'S FOR BENEFICIARIES AND THEY
ARE ALREADY IN THEIR MINDS
PAYING FOR SALARIES IN OUR PPS
RATES AND WE- WE AGREE. WE
CANNOT KEEP UP WITH SALARY
COSTS. THERE IS NO WAY PPS ALSO
IF SALARY COSTS BECAUSE OF
INFLATION GO UP 20% TOO BAD
FRIEND Q. EIGHT C. IS NOTHING TO
DO ABOUT YOUR PPS RATE TO MOVE
THAT THAT'S NOT A TRIGGERING
EVENT IT DOESN'T COUNT. SAM IN
THE STATE WITH THE PARTY THOSE
COSTS YOU HAVE TO FIND IT A
DIFFERENT WAY. SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENTS FROM. WITH THE- AND
DISTANT FOR HEALTH CENTERS WAS
LARGELY GOING TO SALARY COSTS.
AND EXTENDED HOURS AND
ADDITIONAL SERVICES AND WE COULD
NOT FIND A WAY TO MITIGATE IT
WITH THE S. P. P. BASED ON THE
RULES THE DH CS SAID. THEY
UNDERSTOOD CMS WOULD APPROVE OR
NOT SO WE ARE GOING BASED ON.
THE GUIDANCE THAT WE HAVE GOTTEN
FROM DTS AND WORKING SO HARD TO
TRY TO JERRY RIG PROGRAMS. AND
SALARY INCREASES FROM OUR
EXPERIENCE WE'RE NOT. AVAILABLE
THE NEW THIS IS DO HAVE. THANK
YOU MR. STILL HERE. SHE LEAVE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH- IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND I'M ASSUMING YOU
WERE LISTENING TO THE TESTIMONY
IN THE HALLWAY OKAY SO MA'AM- I
JUST WANTED TO. BUT YOU KNOW YOU
YOU HEARD SENATOR HERTZBERG TALK
ABOUT HOW IT'S NOT A REQUIREMENT
TO BE- PART OF THESE LABOR
AGREEMENTS IN THESE UNIONS THAT
THAT BUT THERE ARE SOME
CONDITIONS. TO HAVING ACCESS TO
THE MONEY ONE WOULD BE OF COURSE
TO PAY THE TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS
AN HOUR IN WAGE AND I WONDER IF
YOU COULD WEIGH IN ON WHAT. WHAT
TYPE OF THE FACT THAT WOULD HAVE
ON THE CLINICS- YOU KNOW THAT
AREN'T PART OF THESE- UNIONS IN
THE ONES PERHAPS YOU'RE HERE
REPRESENTING TODAY YEAH THANK
YOU ACTUALLY CAN I JUST ONE
PROPOSAL FOR YOUR SUPPORT BY
GOVERNMENT IT COMMITTEES AT
SELF. PASSED THE GAVEL ON TO MY
VOICE OKAY BACK TO CANS GOING TO
GO OUT ON BOATS IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE HE WILL BE BACK I
PROMISE OKAY. OKAY SIMI'S
INTEREST PLEASE GO HEAD SO THE
IMPACT- IS FOR. MANY OF US
THROUGH THE PANDEMIC. DID
REVISIONS THAT UPGRADES OF TO UP
OUR MINIMUM WAGE WHICH YOU KNOW
IS NOT ONLY THE INITIAL INCREASE
BUT ITS ONGOING. BUT ONCE GOT
PEOPLE ABOVE THE MINIMUM WAGE
YOU HAVE TO BUMP UP I MEAN
THERE'S A WHOLE. KIND OF DOMINO
EFFECT THAT TAKES PLACE. SO WE
I'M AN EXECUTIVE SHOULD HAVE
TAKE ALL THAT IN CONTEXT SO WE
DO THAT RIPPLE EFFECT WHICH WE
DID IN THIS LAST RUN AFTER OF
CODE THAT- THERE'S A POSSIBILITY
LAYOFFS. BECAUSE YOU CN
MAINTAIN THAT YOU CAN'T SUSTAIN
THAT. WE HAVE LIMITED BUDGETS
WITH LIMITED PERSPECTIVE
PAYMENTS FROM THE FEDS AND SO.
WE FILL IT COULD RICOCHET BACK
IN THE PEOPLE WILL LOSE JOBS
RENDON GAME WHERE MANY PEOPLE
ARE GONNA LOSE JOBS. AND WE'RE
ALREADY SHORT STAFFED WITH THIS
. OKAY I SEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR I JUST TO MAKE SURE
HAVING FULL CONTEXT YOUR YOU
KNOW BECAUSE THE INTENT OF THE
BILL IS I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE
TRYING TO THAT'S A GOOD THING
BUT IT'S CLEAR. THAT THERE ARE
SOME PROBLEMS WITH HOW THIS GETS
IMPLEMENTED IN WHO IS INCLUDES
THE THANK YOU MISS SANCHEZ I
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THANK
RESIDENTS THAT MENTOR. I'M SORRY
REGISTER YES OF COURSE BECAUSE
THE ARGUMENT IS A CIRCULAR
ARGUMENT. RIGHT WE HAVE LAOS
WILL LOSE IN FRONT LINE WORKERS
WHO ARE EXHAUSTED WORKING IN THE
CLINICS THE STORIES ARE
EXTRAORDINARY WE WANT TO OFFER
HIM A LIVING WAGE SO THEY CAN
WORK IN THE CLINICS. AND SO.
UPPERMOST PART OF MONEY THERE'S
TWO SOURCES ONE IS FROM THE
STATE ONCE IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT I COULD TALK ABOUT
THAT IN A SECOND WE'RE GOING TO
RAISE THEIR WAGES TO THE STATE
AND SO THE ARGUMENT IS WELL
WE'RE GOING TO KEEP THEM AT LOW
WAGES SO THEY CAN'T STAY SO WE
CAN KEEP EXECUTIVES AND HIGHER
WAGES I MEAN AT SOME POINT THE
ARGUMENT GETS RIDICULOUS SO YES
THIS IS A REALLY IMPACTFUL AND
IT'S ONLY IT'S BASICALLY JUST
YOU KNOW THE AGREEMENT TO PAY
WORKERS TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS AN
HOUR WITHIN THREE MONTHS OF
RECEIVING THE SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT. BECAUSE THE WAY THIS IS
WRITTEN IT'S NOT LIKE OH YOU GOT
APPLY FOR SOMETHING WAY DOWN THE
LINE AND CLOSELY GET PAID BACK
YOU GET THE CASH AND THEN YOU'VE
GOT TO PAY THEM AFTER. THEN
PURCHASED. FINALLY MANAGING
COOPERATION COMMITTEE WHICH WILL
BE REGIONAL IN NATURE. SO THAT'S
NUMBER ONE. NUMBER TWO OUR DATA
SHOWS SIGNS THAT PEOPLE OF
DIFFERENT POINTS OF VIEW. BUT
BASICALLY OREGON DID THIS INTER
UNDER THE- SAID THE QUOTE I GOT
IT THE STATURE I GAVE YOU UDER
THE SOCIAL SECURITY
ADMINISTRATION STATURE THEY GAVE
YOU. THEY WERE ABLE TO DO IT
NINETY DAYS. AT THE ARGUMENT
ISN'T JUST ABOUT WAGES. THE
ARGUMENT IS ABOUT QUALITY OF
CARE. THE ARGUMENT THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND WE HAVE
SOMEBODY HHS WAS A CALIFORNIAN
WHO UNDERSTANDS THE CHALLENGES
OF CALIFORNIA. IS THAT THE
SYSTEM IS BREAKING. THAT THE
PRESSURE IS KILLING US THAT.
THERE'S AN IN A PRIMARY CARE
WORKERS AND WE'RE TRYING TO FIX
IT AND SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT
OREGON THEY DID THE SAME THING
NEW YORK. NEW YORK HAD A
SITUATION WHERE THEY WERE ABLE
IMPLEMENTED A SIMILAR PROGRAM
THAT ADDRESSED PRIMARY CARE
NEEDS OF THEIR MEDICARE
POPULATIONS OREGON DID THE SAME
THING. THAT WE DO HAVE
PRECEDENCE OF OTHER
JURISDICTION'S DOING THIS WITH
CMS BECAUSE IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
THE WAGES. THERE'S A CAUSAL
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN WAGES AND
THE SYSTEM WORKING. AND SO WE
FEEL COMFORTABLE WE FEEL
CONFIDENT REGARDLESS FLEXIBILITY
IN IT AND THAT WE'VE GOT AN
EMERGENCY SITUATION ON THE ONE
HAND THE GOVERNMENT LEGISLATURES
INCREASING IT. THE OTHER HAND AS
I SAW. THE ROB IS THE FRONT LINE
CLINICS THAT ARE REALLY MUCH
MORE COST EFFECTIVE IN TERMS OF
THE INSTEAD OF THE ER. AND WE'RE
TRYING TO OFFER UP A SOLUTION
THAT'S INTELLIGENT. AND THERE'S
NO NEED TO MAKE THIS THING WORK
SO I UNDERSTAND THE ARGUMENT
EITHER SIDE BUT IT'S A LITTLE.
WELL- I APPRECIATE YOUR CANDOR
ALWAYS HAS- HE'S ALWAYS- I CRIED
FOR ME PERSONALLY I THINK YOU
ARE- YOU KNOW ORIGINALLY I
THOUGHT MAYBE YOU WERE JUST KIND
OF TEETERING ON THE LINE I THINK
PERHAPS A YOU MAY HAVE. GONE A
LITTLE FURTHER THAN THAT AND IT
MAKES ME UNCOMFORTABLE WITH WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO SO I'M NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY BUT I WONDER IF
THERE'S ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WHO HAD ANY INPUT
BEFORE WE- TAKE ABOUT. THIS
CONTEST THANK YOU AND I
APPRECIATE THAT ADDITIONAL
CONTEXT TO BE TONIGHT I THINK
YOU KNOW YOU HAVE STATED THAT
YOU'LL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH.
THESE COMMUNITY CLINICS I THINK
THAT IS WHAT WE'RE HEARING LOUD
AND CLEAR FROM THIS- THIS BODY
IS THAT WE'LL START TO SEE SOME
MOVEMENT IN AND HOPEFULLY. SOME
BETTER UNDERSTANDING BECAUSE I
CAN UNDERSTAND WHERE THESE
COMMUNITY CLINICS AND WE'VE GOT
THEM ALL BACK HOME. WRETCH
THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC LIKE NO
OTHER AND I KNOW I'M PREACHING
TO THE CHOIR FELT THIS BUT- I
FEEL FOR THEM- I REALLY DO AND
THEY'RE JUST REALLY TRYING TO
RECOVER AT THIS POINT- SO. DEEP
CONCERN I KNOW YOU'LL CONTINUE
WORKING ON- THAT- I WILL SUPPORT
TODAY BUT- YOU KNOW WOULD LOVE
TO. CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOUR
SCORES ON ON- FOLKS BACK HOME
THAT NEED HELP. THE ESTIMATE IS
SEVENTY PERCENT- SENATOR OF
THESE CLAIMS WILL BE IMPACTED BY
THIS ADDITIONAL MONEY HELPING
70% DOES HELP EVERYBODY BUT IT'S
GONNA BE PRETTY SIGNIFICANT.
OKAY WITH THAT SAID YOU DIDN'T
HAVE ANYTHING SETTLEMENT DID YOU
. OKAY SO THEN- WE'VE HEARD ALL
OF THE TESTS WE WOULD YOU CARE
CLOSE. THE STATUS LOOK I JUST
THINK THAT THIS IS IMPORTANT I
THINK THAT IS WE- DEAL WITH THE
CHALLENGES WITH HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEMS PRIMARY CARE IN
THE COMMUNITIES THE FRONTLINE
WORKERS THIS IS A CREATIVE AND
IMAGINATIVE WAY. TO IMPACT THE
PROCESS IS A WAY TO ACCESS
FEDERAL DOLLARS I THINK IN A
PRETTY CREATIVE WAY AND- TO
WRITE THING TO DO ESCRIBO.
ALREADY THANK YOU SO MUCH-
SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE FOR WOMEN IN MOTION. OKAY WE
ARE MOTION MY CENTER. CENTER ONE
YES I THOUGHT I OKAY THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED RE REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. PAN MELENDEZ NO
ONE DOESN'T KNOW EGGMAN AND
SALAS HI GONZALEZ HI GROVE HER
TADO LEYVA LIMON. LIMON HI ROTH
RUBIO WIENER. OKAY THAT IS TWO
ONE FOR NOW WILL KEEP IT ON
COURSE FOR THE OTHER MEMBERS
THANK YOU SO CURRENTLY A PROJECT
MANAGER. WELCOME ALL RIGHT NEXT
UP TO BAT IS SENATOR CORTESE.
WITH S. B. NINE NINE NINE-
CENTER CORTESE WILL BEGIN WHEN
YOU'RE READY. THINK ABOUT YOUR
OKAY HELLO SENATORS AND PLEASED
TO PRESENT SB NINE NINE NINE
COSPONSORED BY SUMMIT ESTATE
RECOVERY CENTER IN THE
CALIFORNIA CONSORTIUM OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS AND WITH SUPPORT
FROM OVER FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS I
THANK THE CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING WITH ME ON THIS BILL
I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY STATING FOR
THE RECORD THAT I'M ACCEPTING
THE CHAIRS AMENDMENTS TO REMOVE
SUBDIVISIONS- L. AND M. FROM THE
BILL. IT IS L. NOT HIGH CORRECT
. HARD TO TELL IN THE IN THE
TYPE SAID HERE THANK YOU. THOSE
ARE THE ONES I AM ACCEPTING- S.
B. NINE NINETY NINE WHICH FOR
THE CALIFORNIA SUFFERING FROM
MENTAL HEALTH. AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS ARE ABLE TO RECEIVE
THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF
TREATMENT AND CARE THAT IS
NECESSARY FOR A FULL AND LASTING
RECOVERY. DESPITE EXISTING WALL
HEALTH PLANS AND DISABILITY
INSURERS ARE STILL USING
INAPPROPRIATE UTILIZATION REVIEW
PRACTICES TO AVOID PAYING FOR
CARE. AS A RESULT MEDICALLY
NECESSARY TREATMENT DAYS. THAT
ARE RECOMMENDED IN COMPLIANCE
WITH GENERALLY ACCEPTED
STANDARDS OF TREATMENT. ARE
OFTEN ARBITRARILY DENIED. SB
NINE NINE NINE WILL REMEDY THIS
BY ESTABLISHING UTILIZATION
REVIEW CRITERIA FOR HEALTH PLANS
AND DISABILITY INSURERS. THE
PROTECT PATIENT ACCESS TO BE
REVIEWED DECISIONS. SURE THAT A
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER WITH
SIMILAR EDUCATION TRAINING AND
EXPERIENCE IN THE RELEVANT
DIAGNOSIS IS CONDUCTING THE
UTILIZATION REVIEWS. BY PIPELINE
THE APPROPRIATE CLINICAL
UTILIZATION REVIEW CRITERIA
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
WE CAN SAVE LIVES BY COMPETENT
OVERDOSE DEATHS SUICIDES. I'D
LIKE TO THANK AMONG OTHERS
SENATOR WIENER'S OFFICE- FOR
ASSISTING GIVEN HIS HISTORY WITH
THIS SUBJECT MATTER THE KENNEDY
FORM IN THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE
ALL KEY STAKEHOLDERS THAT WE'VE
BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH ON
THIS BILL IN AGAIN MANY THANKS
TO CHAIR THE COMMITTEE. WITH US
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS TYLER FITZ GERALD
THE CLINICAL DIRECTOR OF SOME OF
THE C. RECOVERY CENTER AS WELL
SUSAN SILVA WHO WHO SHARE HER
OWN LIVED EXPERIENCE. THANK YOU
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK DR. THANK
YOU- CIRCLE DAISY I'M GOING TO-
PERHAPS ASTON THOSE INTO THE
COMMITTEE YOURSELF THAT
LOGISTICALLY. SO BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU ALSO ON EDUCATION COMMITTEE
AND SAID WE HAVE A MEMBER HEALTH
COMMITTEE WHOSE CHAIR THE
EDUCATION. SO I'D LIKE TO DO IF
YOU WITNESS ARE OKAY THIS FOR US
TO TAKE A VERY BRIEF RECESS FOR
YOU RIGHT OVER SO WE CAN CLOSE
THE ROLE EDUCATION THEN YOU CAN
COME BACK AND THEN ALSO WHICH
SHE CAN CONFIRM. SHE CAN COME
BACK AND SIT IN ANOTHER CITY.
THEN WILL CONTINUE WITH THE
TESTIMONY IF YOU'RE OKAY WITH
THAT AB SO IF SO ALL RIGHT SO
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A BRIEF RECESS
THOUGHT IT'D FIT SO YOU CAN COOK
EDUCATION COMMITTEE AND THEN
WILL RESUME YOUR BILL WHEN YOU
RETURN LOUIS LEVINE TO RAPE YOU
SO- HEALTH COMMITTEE WILL BE IN
RECESS- UNTIL SATURDAY RETURNS.
THANK YOU.
TO ORDER- SO CONCLUDING A
RECESS. AGAIN WE ARE NOW ON THAT
SENATE BILL NINE NINE NINE BY
CENTER CORTESE WHO IS RAISED
EVAN HIS PRESENTATIONS. SO NOW-
BRING FORTH THE- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT FOR BELIEVE ARE BOTH ON
THE PHONE LINES SO- UP THERE
OVER HERE OKAY THAT'S RIGHT
SOMEONE'S COMING UP THERE OKAY-
SO WE HAVE HELP IN PERSON GOOD.
SO WE HAVE TYLER FITZ GERALD-
WITH SUMMIT ESTATE RECOVERY AND
THEN SUSAN SILVA- YOU
CONSTITUENTS- SO YOU HAVE-
BETWEEN THE TWO OF YOU FOUR
MINUTES SO GIVE YOU TWO MINUTES
OF WHAT I CALL IT TWO MINUTES.
YOU CAN DIDYOU DON'T STOP.
REDUCE SINCE. ITSELF WELCOME AND
- PLEASE BEGIN THANK YOU. MY
NAME'S TYLER FITZ GERALD ON THE
CLINICAL DIRECTOR OF SOME OF THE
STATE RECOVERY CENTER WHICH IS
LICENSED IN CALIFORNIA TO
PROVIDE TREATMENT CONSISTENT
WITH THE ADDICTION SOCIETY. OF
ERICA SOCIETY OF ADDICTION
MEDICINE CRITERIA I'VE BEEN A
LICENSED MARRIAGE FAMILY
THERAPIST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR TWENTY TWO YEARS
I HAVE FIFTEEN YEARS OF
PROFESSIONAL AND PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE WORKING IN ADDICTION.
AND RECOVERY SERVICES. WE ALL
KNOW THE IMPACT AND DEVASTATION
THAT ADDICTION CAUSES
INDIVIDUALS AND FAMILIES. THERE
ISN'T A PERSON IN THIS ROOM ARE
IN THIS BUILDING THAT HASN'T
BEEN DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY
TOUCHED BY THE DEVASTATION OF
ADDICTION. ADDICTION DOESN'T
HAPPEN OVERNIGHT AND IT'S NOT
TREATED OVERNIGHT. WHEN SOMEONE
COMES TO US FOR TREATMENT THEY
HAVE MADE A LONG JOURNEY TO GET
THERE. THESE ARE FUNCTIONING
INDIVIDUALS IN OUR SOCIETY WHO
WORK AND PAY FOR THEIR INSURANCE
TAKE FOR EXAMPLE A FIFTY YEAR
OLD CONSUMER WHO CAME TO US LAST
YEAR. WHO HAVE BEEN SUFFERIN
WITH ALCOHOLISM AND
BENZODIAZEPINE ADDICTION FOR
MORE THAN THREE YEARS IT TOOK
MANY YEARS BEFORE THAT FOR THE
DICTION TO GET OUT OF CONTROL.
WHEN THIS PERSON CAME TO OUR
TREATMENT FACILITY. THEY WERE
ASSESSED BY AN ADDICTION MAX
MEDICINE SPECIALIST A
PSYCHIATRIST A NURSE MYSELF AND
A CASE MANAGER. THIS TEAM PUTS
TOGETHER THE TREATMENT PLAN FOR
THIS INDIVIDUAL. WE'VE AND
REPORTS THE INSURANCE COMPANY
OUR FINDINGS AND OBTAIN APPROVAL
FOR THEIR TREATMENT. DURING THIS
FIRST PERIOD THIS PARTICULAR
INDIVIDUAL SUFFERED SEVERE
WITHDRAWAL SYMPTOMS THAT ARE
LIFE THREATENING. THEY'RE UNABLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE TREATMENT
SERVICES OTHER THAN THE MEDICAL
ATTENTION THAT THEY REQUIRE TO
STAY ALIVE. WE RECEIVED
ADDITIONAL AUTHORIZATION FOR SIX
DAYS TO TREAT THIS INDIVIDUALS
DISEASE. AT THIS POINT THEY
COULD PARTICIPATE MEANINGFULLY
IN TREATMENT. IT WAS AFTER THIS
AUTHORIZATION THE INSURANCE
COMPANY DECIDED THAT THIS
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS. TAKING IN
MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE OUNCES OF
HARD ALCOHOL A DAY COULD BE
TREATED ON AN OUTPATIENT BASIS
RECEIVING NINE HOURS OF
TREATMENT BY ZOOM AT HOME ALONE
. WE APPEAL THIS CASE I WAS
REFERRED TO A PEER TO PEER
REVIEW WITH A NON INSURANCE
DOCTOR IN WAS FROM A WISCONSIN
COMPANY TO TALK ABOUT THIS CASE
I COULD TELL BY THE TONE OF THE
VOICE OF THIS DOCTOR THAT WITHIN
THREE MINUTES THIS CASE WAS
GOING TO BE DENIED. HOURS AND
HOURS GO INTO ASSESSING THESE
PEOPLE AND PROVIDING TREATMENT
AND DEVELOPING RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THEM THIS DOCTOR SAID WELL
THEY'RE NOT SUICIDAL THEREFORE
THEY DON'T NEED MORE TREATMENT.
I'M SORRY BUT SUICIDE DOES NOT
BELONG IN OUR FACILITY REQUIRES
TREATMENT ELSEWHERE FRIEDMAN IS
NOW. THESE DECISIONS ARE BEING
MADE BY DOCTORS NOT QUALIFIED NO
DISRESPECT TO PODIATRIST BUT
PODIATRISTS ARE MAKING DECISIONS
WHETHER OR NOT THESE PEOPLE NEED
ADDITIONAL TREATMENT. WE NEED TO
HAVE MORE CONVERSATIONS WITH
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN LINE WITH
SENATOR WIENER'S BILL SB EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE PASSED LAST YEAR. IN
COMPLIANCE AND PROVIDE CAN
INSURANCE CONSUMERS THE
TREATMENT THAT THEY DESERVE AND
THAT THEY ARE PAYING FOR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- NEXT WAS THE
SEASON SILVA I'M AFRAID. YEARS
ONLY LEFT YOU THIRTY FOUR
SECONDS. OKAY APOLOGIZE. THE.
WELCOME GOOD EVENING MY NAME
SUSAN SAW THAT AND I WAS AT-
SEVEN RECOVERY CENTER- I WENT
THERE SEPTEMBER EIGHTEENTH
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. MY INSURANCES
ANTHEM BLUE CROSS WHO IS MANAGED
BY- MOM MOM MOM MOM MOM THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE. THEY DID APPROVE
DAYS FOR ME TO STAY I WAS THERE
FOR TWENTY EIGHT DAYS- ANTHEM
BLUE CROSS APPROVED THE FIRST.
THE FIFTEEN DAYS. AND BUT THEY
HAVE NOT REIMBURSE ME I'VE BUILT
THEM SEVERAL TIMES AND SOME HAVE
NOT RECEIVED ANY PAYMENT- I ALSO
DID OUTPATIENT. WRAP UP OKAY ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU SO MUCH OKAY
THANK YOU AND AT THE END PROCEED
SHARING. OKAY WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE NINE-
PLEASE COME UP TO THE MICROPHONE
NAME ORGANIZATION POSITION. YEAH
OF CALIFORNIA'S ACTUALLY CALLED
ON HOW CAN WE TURN ON THE
MICROPHONE HERE BUT I THINK I
THINK WE'RE ALL SET ALSO SORRY
THE SEATS OR SOMEBODY CAN HEAR
YOU OKAY EXCELLENT THESE ARMORED
HERE SUNDAY OF CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ADDICTION MDICINE IN
SUPPORT. OKAY THANK YOU. WELCOME. LOUISA DAVIS FROM DAVIS
HEALTHCARE MANAGEMENT GROUP
SERVICES IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY LORENZINI OUTREACH ASSOCIATE
BAY AREA FROM AMERICAN ADDICTION
CENTERS IN SUPPORT ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU. WELL NOW MOVE ON TO-
WITNESSES- IN SUPPORT OF SB NINE
NINE NINE WHO ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ASSUMES A
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE
NINE NINE. YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE
NINE NINE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. IN ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT.
THE TEACHER THIS TIME WE HAVE
ABOUT ELEVEN IN OUR QUEUE OKAY.
START WITH NUMBER THREE THIRTY
EIGHT. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF PALM RENT
FREE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG
PROGRAM EXECUTIVES EXPRESSING
SUPPORT FOR SB NINE NINE NINE
WITH THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANKS FOR
THIS. NEXT TO NUMBER SEVENTY
EIGHT. HI THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING MY NAME IS SEPTEMBER
BAKER WITH CAMBRIDGE HEALTHCARE
MANAGEMENT SYSTEM AT LEAST
WRONGLY SUPPORT THEMSELVES THANK
YOU X. WITNESS. TEXAS NUMBER TWO
NINETY NINE. AFTERNOON THAT THE
BAR THANK YOU CAN BE FARMS
SUPPORT SB NEXT. THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NUMBER.
TWO TWENTY. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHERRY DAILY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CONSORTIUM OF ADDICTION PROGRAMS
AND PROFESSIONALS VERY PRACTICAL
SB NINE NINE NINE THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NUMBER
ONE OH TWO. YES SIR MY NAME IS
JIM BRADY ON THE CEO OF A TOWN
CENTER WE'RE- WE HAVE FIVE
LICENSED FACILITIES IN NORTH SAN
DIEGO COUNTY I FIRST WANT TO
POINT OUT THAT I'M CAN CAUSE SO
WE'RE JUST TAKING NAME OR IS A
SOLICITATION PLEASE. NAME IS
JAMES JIM BRADY. C. EIGHT TIMES
CENTER. IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL I
WANT TO POINT OUT THANK YOU THE
DEPARTMENT OF MATH THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU IF YOU
ACTUALLY YOU CAN SUBMIT YOUR-
MORE DETAILED COMMENTS AND
WRITING BUT WE WERE TAKEN TO THE
PRO TESTIMONY SO- BUT PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO DO SO- SO FOR THE
RECORD. THE NEXT WITNESS. NUMBER
TWO THIRTY TWO. THE FIFTEEN
DOCKERY WITH REASON WE HAVE
TREATMENT SERVICES AND
EXPERIENCE RECOVERY DETOX.
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB NINE NINE
NINE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
FIND THREE TWENTY NINE. THIS
RECOVERY HEALTHY REPRESSOR THOU
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
SENATE BILL NINE NINE NINE THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. NINE
THREE FORTY. HI MELANIE FOUND E.
L. L. FOUR THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. NUMBER THREE TWENTY SIX
. AND MY NAME IS THIRTY REPAIRS
HARDIN CEO DETECTOR. SERVICE WE
CAN RANCHO MIRAGE CALIFORNIA AND
I'M IN FULL SUPPORT OF THE. NINE
NINE NINE THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
. NUMBER THREE FORTY THREE.
TWENTY THREE FORTY THREE PLEASE
GET. MOVE ON TO NUMBER. THREE
THIRTY FOUR. HI MY NAME IS SHARE
FIRM AND I SUPPORT THE NINE NINE
NINE I WAS A RESIDENT AT. EIGHT
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT THREE
ONE LINE. PLEASE PLEASE THANK
THE CARD WELL I THINK THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. YEAH IF YOU LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
NINE NINE NINE PRESS ONE ZERO.
SICHER THIS TIME WE HAVE NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE RIGHT THANKS
VERY MUCH FOR NOW NOW MOVES TO
WITNESS OPPOSITION SB NINE NINE
NINE WE HAVE TO LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- SEVEN WATKINS AT
DISSOCIATION OF. LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES IN L.
FOLLOWED BUDGET HAMPTON FROM
SOUTH SERVICES AND HEALTH PLANS
AND I THINK YOU KNOW WHAT THE
RULES ARE SO. PLEASE BE. MISTER
CHAIRMAN PERSEPHONE. OF BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES FIRST AND FOREMOST WE
LIKE TO. THINK THE CHAIR AS WELL
AS YOUR STAFF. THE AUTHORS AND
SPONSORS FOR THE OPEN DIALOGUE
AND FORTUNATELY WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL AS IT STANDS TODAY.
GOES WITHOUT SAYING THAT MENTAL
HEALTH IS A KEY COMPONENT TO A
PERSON'S OVERALL WELL BEING. AND
HEALTH INSURANCE PROVIDERS MAKE
REMAIN STEADFAST IN OUR EFFORTS
TO PROVIDE SAFE EVIDENCE BASED
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE ON PAR
WITH MEDICAL SURGICAL CARE. I
BELIEVE THERE IS MORE THAT WE
MUST DO. TO MEET THE EVER
INCREASING TREATMENT NEEDS OF
THOSE SUFFERING FROM ADDICTION
AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND
REMAIN RESOLUTE IN OUR
COMMITMENT. UNFORTUNATELY WHILE
WE APPRECIATE THE OVER ARCHING.
CLEVENGER ROWLEY'S ENSURED.
MEDICALLY NECESSARY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES WE BELIEVE. SB
NINE NINE NINE MISSES THE MARK
AND INSTEAD SET THE PLACE THE
COMPLEX AND OVERLY BURDENSOME
UTILIZATION REVIEW PROCESS.
SPECIFICALLY SB NINE NINE NINE
SETS IN PLACE AND- A NEW PROCESS
WHICH WOULD SUBSTANTIALLY LIMIT
WHO IS ALLOWED TO CONDUCT
UTILIZATION REVIEWS WHILE WE
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
ENSURING QUALIFIED POSITIONS AND
SPECIALISTS PERFORM THESE
REVIEWS. CLOSELY FOLLOW THE
CURRENT GUIDELINES SET FORTH BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTH
CARE. UNCLEAR WHAT THE SHORTFALL
THIS CHANGES INTENDING TO
ADDRESS. THE THING LAW CLEARLY
SPECIFIES THAT NO INDIVIDUAL
OTHER THAN A LICENSED PHYSICIAN
OR LICENSED HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONAL. WHO IS COMPETENT.
ARE YOU WITH THE SPECIFIC
CLINICAL ISSUES INVOLVED IN.
SERVICES REQUESTED ME DIDN'T
HIRE MODIFIER REQUEST FOR
AUTHORIZATION. FURTHERMORE WITH
RESPECT MAY HELP SUCH. STREET S.
B. EIGHT FIVE FIVE REGULATIONS
ISSUED MOST RECENTLY THAT BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE. PUT IT. I'M READING. DIFFICULT
TO THE CHIN- ONE THE N. ROLLED.
CAN HAS TO BE AND- IS THE ISSUE
A LIST OF CRIED AND GUIDELINES
THAT WERE VIEWED AS SUMMARY OF
ANY REASONS FOR DEVIATING FROM
THOSE CRITERIA AND A SUMMARY OF
THE PLANS CLINICAL REASONS FOR
THE DECISION. ADDITIONALLY THE
DEPARTMENT HAS ALSO REQUIRED THE
PLANS TO HAVE A VERY ROBUST I'M
TRAINING PROCESS IN PLACE AND
THOSE ARE ALSO OUTLINED IN THE
MOST RECENT REGULATIONS THAT
WERE ISSUED. UNDERSTANDING THESE
REQUIREMENTS IT QUESTIONS WHY
THEY DIDN'T LIVING LANGUAGE IS
NECESSARY AS IT WILL SEEMINGLY
BRING NO ADDITIONAL VALUE TO THE
PROCESS BUT WILL CERTAINLY ADD
COSTS. SECONDLY WE ARE CONCERNED
WITH THE SECTION CARE THREE
WHICH REQUIRES INDIVIDUAL HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS PERFORMING
UTILIZATION REVIEW TO DISCLOSE
THE PERCENTAGE OF THE SERVICES
APPROVED AND DENIED BY THE
PROVIDER OVER THE PAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS. IT'S AGAIN UNCLEAR FOR
IT TO US WHAT VALUE THAT WOULD
BRING TO EITHER THE PROVIDER OR
THE PATIENT UNDERSTANDINGIT BUT
WE DO HAVE CONCERN. FOR CONCERNS
ABOUT THAT CREATING A
PREJUDICIAL SORT OF EXPERIENCE
AND MAR THE PATIENT'S EXPERIENCE
TO BELIEVE THAT UTILIZATION
MANAGEMENT IS INTENDED TO BE
PUNITIVE. SO FOR THOSE REASONS
UNFORTUNATELY REMAIN OPPOSED TO
THE BILL BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS OF IT DOES MEAN FOR
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND
NOW BRING UP BUDGET HAMPTON FROM
THE GULF ASSOCIATION HEALTH
PLANS YOU HAVE A MINUTE AND SIX
SECONDS- GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE JEFF
HAMPTON WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HEALTH PLANS- IN
INTEREST OF TIME I WILL ALIGN.
THE MAJORITY F MY COMMENTS WITH
MY- CALLING THIS WALK INS FROM
THE ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA LIFE
AND HEALTH INSURANCE COMPANIES
OUR MEMBERS ARE VERY CAP HAVE-
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL- WITH THE WITH THE
PROVISIONS THAT SHE OUTLINED IN
THE BILL. AND THAT FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED THANK.
THANK THANK YOU- WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO S. B. NINE NINE
NINE. TWELVE HUNDRED. SENILE ONE
ARE COMING PUTTING MICROPHONES
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB NINE
NINE NINE. THE TICKET UP AS- TO
THE NINE NINE NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. IN ONE
ZERO FOR OPPOSITION. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE IN OUR QUEUE
WE'LL GO TO NUMBER THREE THIRTY
SIX. SHARE MEMBERS JOHN LINGER
ON BEHALF OF AMERICA'S HEALTH
INSURANCE PLANS LIKE THE LINER
COMMENT WITHOUT BUT THANK YOU I
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. AND
AGAIN IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION SB NINE NINE NINE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. SURE AT
THE TIME THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN
OUR QUEUE OKAY THANK YOU AND SO
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE BUT
BEFORE WE START THAT ACTUALLY-
SURVEYS YOU MAY HAVE SAID YOUR
PRESENTATION BUT I'D WALKED IN
LATE THAT ARE YOU ACCEPTING THE
COMMITMENTS YES YES. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO THE TWICE EARLIER
BUT I KNOW YOU WERE HERE THANK
YOU OKAY THANK YOU TO SIGN IT-
AND THEN AGAIN YOU FOR
WORKING WITH US MCCUE COMMITTEE
STEP ON THAT. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS COMMITTEE MEMBER.
MELENDEZ THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN- IS SO SENATOR CORTESE.
D. OPPONENTS HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT. DISCLOSURES THAT WILL
CREATE A TEDIOUS AND PREJUDICIAL
DISCLOSURE PROCESS THAT WILL
LEAVE THE PATIENT. WITH THE
IMPRESSION THAT THE PRIOR
AUTHORIZATION SYSTEM IS INTENDED
TO BE PUNITIVE- WHICH IT IS NOT
WHICH WOULD CREATE A- TYPE OF
HOSTILE ENVIRONMENT THAT HARMS
THE SYSTEM AND INEVITABLY MARS
THE PATIENT'S EXPERIENCE THAT'S-
PER MY- AND ALICE. CARE TO
COMMENT ON THAT. HELLO WOOD. I
DON'T THINK THE BILL DOESN'T IN
ANY WAY SHAPE PERFORM IT SIMPLY
BILLS- ON THE EFFORT THAT'S
ALREADY BEEN PURPORTED TOPPED BY
THE LEGISLATURE TO SPEAK FIFTY
FIVE. BY SAYING- BY PREVENTING.
REVIEWERS WHO ARE KNOWLEDGEABLE
ABOUT SPECIFIC DIAGNOSES FROM
THE PERSON. APPROPRIATE KOMPLETT
DECISIONS MADE BY PROVIDERS. IN
ITS I THINK IT'S HARD TO BE
AGAINST THAT. I THINK IT'S HARD
TO BE AGAINST. PREVENTING
REVIEWERS WERE UNALTERABLE.
ABOUT SPECIFIC DIAGNOSIS IN THIS
CASE AROUND ADDICTION. SUBSTANCE
ABUSE. FROM REVERSING. DECISIONS
COMPANY DECISIONS THAT ARE MADE
BY PROVIDERS. CARS IT HERE. THE
URGENT AND URGENT RESPONSE TO
REQUESTS FOR COVERAGE AN APPEALS
AGAIN I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE
OBJECTION WOULD BE TO THE- THINK
IS REGULATORS AND ABILITY TO
REQUIRE TRANSPARENCY. WE'RE
INDUCING HIGH DENIAL RATES MAY
BE IN PLAY- I THINK THOSE ARE
PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD. OKAY
ADDITIONS TO THE GREAT WORK THAT
SB FIFTY FIVE STARTED. OKAY I
THANK YOU FOR THAT AND I WONDER
IF- MISS WATKINS COULD COME
FORWARD PLEASE AND ADDRESS. MY
CONCERNS SINCE YOU WERE IN THE
OPPOSITION. AND IF YOU COULD
PERHAPS BE GIVE ME A LITTLE MORE
EXPLANATION AS TO- IN THIS
DISCLOSURE WHAT WHAT KIND OF
QUESTIONS WHAT ARE WE TALKING
ABOUT HERE. SO KAY IN THE BILL
REQUIRES- EACH IN A GROUP THAT
EACH REVIEWER TO INCLUDE THE
PERCENTAGES- APPROVALS OR
DENIALS F ANY REVIEW AND THAT
GOES TO BOTH THE PATIENT AND TO
THE PROVIDER AND OUR QUESTIONS
SORT OF HIS AROUND WHAT VALUE
DOES THAT BRING I MEAN WHILE
SOME OF OUR PLANS DO IN HOUSE
REVIEW. OTHERS ESPECIALLY
RELATED TO VERY SPECIALTY SORT
OF DESIGNATIONS DO OUTSIDE
REVIEWS SO YOU COULD HAVE A
COMPANY THAT WE CONTRACT WITH
THAT DOES UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT
THAT DOES IT FOR MULTIPLE
BUSINESSES MULTIPLE COMPANIES
ACROSS THE NATION. SO WERE KIND
OF QUESTIONING. THERE'S ANOTHER
CONVERSATION. THERE'S HAVING OUT
AT ACCESS TO THAT INFORMATION IF
IT PROVIDES PROVIDED BY YOU OR A
REVIEW BY THEREGULATOR BUT FOR
A PROVIDER TO JESSE THAT. AND
DENIALS THE MODIFICATIONS ARE
OBVIOUSLY. THERE OFTENTIMES VERY
COMPLICATED- SOMETIMES THERE'S A
MODIFICATION BECAUSE THE DOSAGE
THAT'S PRESCRIBED WE WANT THREE
STEP THERAPY WE WANT YOU TO TRY
AND FAIL ON A LOWER DOSAGE THAT
WE BELIEVE IS MORE SAFER
EFFICACY. REASONS SO THERE'S A
LOT THAT GOES INTO THIS
DETERMINATION SO JUST TO SEE A
NUMBER WITH EXPLAINING NO I
UNDERSTAND. HOW MANY DID I OPEN
APPROVALS WE BELIEVE CREATES
THIS KIND OF. HOSTILE
ENVIRONMENT TO SUGGESTS THAT
SOMETHING IS WRONG WITH THAT
WERE WERE AN EIGHT FIVE FIVE IS
DONE A LOT THE REGULATIONS ARE
IN PROCESS. I MEAN WE'VE WE'VE
ALL MOVED TO A NONPROFIT
CLINICAL CARE GUIDELINES WHICH I
THINK THIS BILL SORT OF TRIES TO
GET OUT. SO I THINK FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE WE'RE LOOKING TO
THAT PROCESS TO LEND TOWARDS
ADDITIONAL GUIDANCE THERE'S AN
INTER RATER RELIABILITY FACTOR
OF 90% FOR THE PLANS WHICH MEANS
THAT THE NINE THAT THE PLAN HAS
TO BE RIGHT NOW. PERCENT OF TIME
. WE YOU WERE. FOR STATE AND I
MEAN THAT'S IN. HIGH PRESSURE.
AND DOESN'T ALLOW FOR A LOT OF.
WRITER WRONG AND SO WE'RE REALLY
LOOKING AT THAT IS TO HOLD THE
STANDARD FOR US. NOT OBSCURE
NUMBERS THAT MIGHT NOT REALLY
BRING ANY VALUE. OKAY SO THEN- I
JUST NEED TO KNOW THE STATEMENT
THAT. OPPONENTS HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE DISCLOSURES AND THAT
IT WOULD CREATE A TEDIOUS AND
PREJUDICIAL DISCLOSURE PROCESS
LEAVING THE PATIENT WITH THE
IMPRESSION THAT THERE'S SOME
SORT OF PUNITIVE EFFORT IT. SO
YOU SEE YOU STAND BY THAT
OPINION. THAT THE PATIENT WOULD
FEEL THAT IT WELL THE QUESTION
IS IF YOU GUYS I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW DOES THE PATIENT
YOU KNOW. HOW ARE THEY EVEN
AWARE OF THIS AND HOW WITH THE
PAY. THE DEBTS PUNITIVE THAT
BOOK AS THE BILL REQUIRES EVERY-
REVIEWER TO INCLUDE WITHIN THEIR
DENIAL OR MODIFICATION TO BOTH
THE PROVIDER AND THE PATIENT.
ASSISTANCE TO CALL NUMBER A
PERCENTAGE OF APPROVALS OR
DENIALS FOR THE LAST EIGHTEEN
MONTHS OF THEIR REVIEWS RIGHT
BUT AS A PATIENT. LOOKING AT
THAT BIG THEY RECEIVE IT SO OUR
OUR CONCERN IS THAT THE PATIENTS
GOING TO SEE IT AND MAYBE THEY
SAY TO USE THE NUMBER- A
REVIEWER SAY OVER THE LAST
EIGHTEEN MONTHS IS DONE A
HUNDRED REVIEWS. AND THERE'S
SPEND 70% WHERE THERE'S BEEN A
DIALER MODIFICATION AND 30% OF
PATIENTS GOING TO LOOK AT THAT
AND ASSUME. THAT THERE IS SOME
REASON FOR WHICH THERE IS A
PUNITIVE EXPECTATION OF WHY
THEY'RE BEING DENIED WHAT MAY
JUST BE. THAT REVIEWERS NUMBERS
DON'T TELL YOU THE BOTH VERY
AND- THE QUESTION FOR US IS IF
IT DOESN'T BRING VALUE. IT'S I
MEAN THIS IS EVER WE CONTRACT
WITH FOR UTILIZATION MANAGEMENT
STORE THEY REPORTING ON ALL THE
NUMBERS ACROSS ALL BUSINESS
LINES OR JUST FOR. AN ANTHEM OR
AN ACT NOW UNITED THOSE CHAINS
ON A DAY TO DAY BASIS BECAUSE
REVIEWS I MEAN THEY'RE
CONSTANTLY DOING REVIEWS SO.
THERE'S A LOT OF BACK AND WORK
THAT GOES INTO THAT AND THE
QUESTION IS. DOES IT BRING VALUE
TO THE PATIENT OR DOES IT SIMPLY
MAKE THEM FEEL LIKE WHEN I'M
LOOKING AT THESE NUMBERS AND I
DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT I'M JUST
BEING DENIED OKAY THANK YOU
CENTER CORTESE. WHAT IS THE
REASON THAT THOSE NUMBERS WOULD
BE PROVIDED TO A PATIENT.
BECAUSE THE WAY THINGS GO IN IN
THIS IS THAT THE PLEA FOR
TRANSPARENCY IS. SOMEBODY NEEDS
TREATMENT AND I HEARD THE
TESTIMONY FOCUSING ON- BUT
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS BUT THE
PERSON NEEDS TREATMENT. PERSON
NEEDS A PROGRAM THAT'S AKIN TO A
TWELVE STEP PROGRAM THEY NEED
INPATIENT I UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
THE REASON FOR. THE NIGHTTIME
BRIDGE. IN THE NEXT PATIENTS
DENIED COVERAGE IN THE NEXT
SESSION IS DENIED COVERAGE IN
NONE OF THAT INFORMATION IN
AGGREGATE IS PROVIDED- IN IN
TERMS OF THE PUBLIC SCRUTINY. IN
THE US WERE ASKING HER FOR
BECAUSE- IF IT'S NOT TRUE IF
IT'S NOT TRUE THAT THAT'S THE
TREND THERE SHOULDN'T BE
ANYTHING TO WORRY ABOUT THE SHOW
ACTUALLY BRING VALIDATION AND
VALUE TO. THE TO THE IN A TO THE
INSURED INDUSTRY ITSELF BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT'S HAPPENING OUT
THERE- IT'LL TELL YOU- I HAVE
BEEN. INVOLVED I'M NOT I'M NOT
I'M NOT THE WITNESS OF MY OWN
BILL BUT I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN
RECOVERY PROGRAMS FOR THIRTY
THREE YEARS SIX MONTHS AND FIVE
DAYS AND I WILL TELL YOU- THAT
THE ANECDOTAL EVIDENCE OF PEOPLE
BEING DENIED AND DENIED AND
DENIED AND DENIED. FORGET FOR
BASS. BUT LIKE THE WITNESS WHO
DID SHOW UP TODAY WHO SO FAR HAS
BEEN DENIED FOR A TWENTY EIGHT
DAY TREATMENT INPATIENT
TREATMENT- OF IS THE ALMOST
ENDEMIC IN THE SYSTEM RIGHT NOW
WE'RE JUST SIMPLY TRYING O GET
TO THAT PROBLEM IF IT IF IT
DOESN'T EXIST THIS BILL WILL
CREATE ANY PROBLEMS FOR THE
INDUSTRY IF IT DOES EXIST THE
INDUSTRY IS GOING TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE OKAY SO. LET ME PUT
A FINER POINT ON IT FOR YOU IF
YOU ARE THE PATIENT IN YOU GET
THE PAPERWORK THAT SAYS THIS
PARTICULAR FACILITY YOU KNOW
THAT THE PERCENTAGES ARE SEVENTY
THIRTY AS FAR AS APPROVAL AND-
OKAY SPEND WHAT. FOR YOU IS A
PATIENT WHAT DO YOU DO WITH THAT
INFORMATION WHAT IS THE GOAL.
FOR WHAT THE PATIENT IS SUPPOSED
TO DO WITH THAT INFORMATION I'M
TRYING TO SEE THE NEXUS HERE WHY
A PATIENT WOULD NEED THAT
INFORMATION BECAUSE THAT
INFORMATION CAN BE TRACKED. IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO BE
YOU KNOW FORMULATED AND PROVIDED
TO THE PATIENT EXTRA WORK ON
THEIR PART. SIR CAN YOU HELP ME
UNDERSTAND THAT IT WAS CERTAINLY
THE PATIENT PROVIDER GOING TO
WANT INFORMATION TO UNDERSTAND
THE DENIAL AND WITH GREAT TO
KNOW. IS GENERALLY- PREJUDICIAL
TO PATIENTS SO THAT IT THAT ARE
ARE SEEKING- VETERAN THAT
UTILIZATION REVIEW PROCESS. BUT
THE BOTTOM LINE IS A SPEECH
EIGHT FIFTY FIVE CALLS FOR
PARITY. IN AND I THINK WHAT YOU
JUST DESCRIBED PARITY AND I
THINK THAT'S WHERE. NO SB EIGHT
FIFTY FIVE IS BEING BUILT UPON
HERE BY CALLING FOR THE
TRANSPARENCY THIS REQUIRED TO
MAKE SURE SB EIGHT FIFTY FIVE IS
IT HERE TOO OKAY BUT I'M JUST.
FROM A VERY BASIC LEVEL HERE I'M
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT AGAIN
YOU AS A PATIENT YOU GET THAT
PIECE OF PAPER AND YOU SEE THE
NUMBERS. AND YOU DON'T LIKE
THEM. THEN WHAT. IT IS THE
COURSE OF ACTION FOR THE
PATIENT. WHAT WOULD BE THE
EXPECTATION HOW DOES THAT HELP
YOU AS A PATIENT OTHER THAN
KNOWING THE NUMBERS SO IF YOU
DON'T LIKE THE NUMBERS THAN WHAT
. WHETHER IT HELPS THAT PATIENT
OR NOT IT'S GOING TO HELP THE
NEXT PATIENT THE NEXT PIECE IN
THE NEXT PATIENT BECAUSE- THE
INSURER IS GOING TO BE. CALLED
OUT FOR. OF FOR VIOLATING THE
PROVISIONS OF THE AYE HILL FIVE
WHO'S GOING TO CALL THE PROVIDER
UP. IS THIS. IS THIS IS- S.
FIFTY FIVE ADDRESSES WITH
REPERCUSSIONS ARE FOR NOT
PROVIDING PARITY. OKAY. I'M
STILL NOT QUITE SEEING HOW. NOT
THAT I'M OPPOSED TO YOU KNOW THE
TRANSPARENCY THAT'S NOT WHAT I'M
GETTING I'M JUST I'M STILL NOT
QUITE SEEING HOW THAT HELPS THE
PATIENT BUT- IT WAS HELPFUL TO
HEAR- YOUR EXPLANATION AND TO
HEAR THE OPPOSITION WE AND THANK
YOU AND I. THINK THE TRAUMA TO
THE PATIENT COMES FROM WITHIN
NOT WITHOUT EXPLORATION. FROM
BEING OUT ON THE STREET. A WITH
AN ADDICTION PROBLEM BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T AFFORD TO PAY FOR THE
TREATMENT THAT THEY WERE SEEKING
I THINK THAT'S WHERE THE TRAUMA
COMES. TO HEAR THAT THE TRAUMAS
GOING TO COME FROM LEARNING WHY
THEY WERE DENIED. I THINK IT'S A
LITTLE ABSURD BUT- I RESPECT.
HIS OPINION ON THIS YEAR NO AND
I WOULD AGREE WITH YOUR POINT
THAT THE TRAUMA DOES COME FROM.
NOT BEING ABLE TO GET THE
TREATMENT NOT NECESSARILY
LOOKING AT THE NUMBERS BUT I
WANT HIM. YOU KNOW I DO WANT
SOMEONE TO MAKE SURE WE HAVE.
CONCERNING CARE WITH HOW WE ARE-
YOU KNOW IMPLEMENTING CERTAIN
REGULATIONS AND MANDATES TO IN
ORDER TO GET THESE POLICIES IN
PLACE THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTIONS.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
EMBERS. CASEY NINE CIRCLE TASTY
I THINK AND THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR WORKING WITH COMMITTEE
STAFF- CERTAINLY- APPRECIATE
THAT YOU KNOW WE ARE STILL IN
THE PROCESS IMPLEMENTING- FIFTY
FIVE- AND- BUT- I GUESS FOR ME I
ASK EVERY QUESTION- SO WHAT WE
NEED NOW IS IT IF YOU WANT
OPTIONS FOR SOMEONE WHO RECEIVES
IT AND NOW FROM THEIR HEALTH
INSURER IS THAT- THEY COULD
ACTUALLY GO IN APPEAL TO FINANCE
HEALTHCARE. GREAT AND SO SOMEONE
GETS THE NILE AND- CERTAINLY I
THINK IT'S HELPFUL FOR THEM TO
KNOW WHY- BUT- IF- ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS MAYBE IS THAT OKAY
WELL IF THEY LOOK AT IT IS IF
THEY FOUND OUT THE REVIEWER HAD
A SEVENTY THIRTY APPROVAL.
VERSUS A THIRTY SEVENTY.
APPROVAL ORDER DENYING SEVENTY
PERCENT- MAYBE THAT MIGHT INFORM
THEM AS TO WHETHER THEY WANT TO
PURSUE. A- APPEAL FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE DO YOU
THINK THAT THE THINGS THAT MIGHT
BE I MEAN IT'S NOT REALLY A
GREAT MEASURE FOR THAT BUT DO
YOU THINK THAT MIGHT. THAT MIGHT
BE SOMEONE FORMATIVE IN TERMS OF
NEXT STEPS FOR A PROVIDER AND
THEIR PATIENTS I DO THINK THAT
SUCKS WHO YOU KNOW- WELL
ARTICULATED EXPLANATION OF
WHAT'S LIKELY TO HAPPEN A SHOULD
THAT BE THE CASE IN YOUR BILL.
DESPITE MY- MY OWN ADMITTED BIAS
TOWARD WHAT I BELIEVE ARE
EXCESSIVE DENIALS- I PITCH THAT
IN MY PRESENTATION JUST A FEW
MINUTES AGO OF THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS. THAT TRANSPARENCY CAN
WORK WELL- FOR BOTH SIDES YOU
KNOW FOR FOLKS. THAT MIGHT NEED
TO USE THAT INFORMATION AS PART
OF AN APPEAL AND EXCESSIVE
DENIAL RATE- BASED ON THE
UTILIZATION REVIEW INFORMATION
THEY'VE RECEIVED JUST LIKE YOU
JUST JUST INDICATED- IT SEEMS TO
ME THAT IF IT'S FAVORABLE
TOWARD. OF THE INSURER THAT THAT
THEY WOULD USE IT TO DEFEND THE
APPEAL SO I THINK IT'S FAIR. ALL
RIGHT WELL I APPRECIATE THAT I
MEAN WE KNOW THAT'S NOT PERFECT
MEASURE AND SO FORTH AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH THE OPPOSITION SURE
THAT AGAIN APPRECIATE YOU TAKING
THEF. AND AMENDMENTS AND I
THINK A PLAGUE THAT STUDENTS
DOES LISA DRESS SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT COME UP. AS WELL-
AND- SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE
BILL- TODAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I DON'T THINK YOU AND I
WOULD SEE EVERYBODY WHO'S HAD
INPUT SO FAR INCLUDING THE
OPPOSITION INCLUDING PER
OPPOSITION- HAS IMPROVED THE
BILL MADE A BETTER BILL WILL
CONTINUE TO SEEK OUT THE KIND
OF. THE KIND OF FEEDBACK WITHOUT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE OKAY THANK YOU- ACTUALIZAR
MOTION YET OKAY IT'S MOVE I
CENTER LEYVA. THAT SO THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED
TO COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SECONDED BY CENTER LEYVA.
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
PAN HI. I MELINDA. EGGMAN EGGMAN
AIKEN SALAS. GROVE HER TADO HER
TITLE BY LEYVA LEYVA AYE LIMÓN
ROSS FIVE ROTH AYE RUBIO WIENER
. FIVE OKAY SO THE BILL
CERTAINLY FIVE ZERO HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY CENTER EGGMAN ALL
RIGHT SO WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB 1416% OR
EGGMAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND
I WILL ADJUST MY WITNESSES
BECAUSE YES WHEN WAS ONLY BE
ABLE TO FIVE THIRTY SO- BUT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR HEARING THIS BILL
THIS AFTERNOON AND FOR ME AND MY
STAFF AS WE CONTINUE TO DRILL
DOWN ON THIS ISSUE- I WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS- OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL WEEKS I PRESENTED. FIELD
TO TRY TO ADDRESS THE BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SYSTEM BOTTLENECKS TO
IMPROVE LPS DATA PREVENT
UNNECESSARY CONSERVATORSHIP STE
AND IN THE NEXT COUPLE WEEKS-
HOW PROPOSALS INTENDED TO
IMPROVE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ACT OUTCOME AND TO IMPROVE
REGIONAL BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PLANNING. PERHAPS SOME. THIS
BILL. IN A IN A VACUUM IS
HAPPENING AS WE ARE FOLLOWING IN
HIS STORE BUDGET IN IN
BEHAVIORAL INTO AND HOUSING. I
THINK IT'S SAFE TO SAY ALL OF US
ON THIS COMMITTEE AND ALL OUR
COLLEAGUES NOT ON THIS COMMITTEE
PEOPLE IN THE ADMINISTRATION ALL
RECOGNIZING THAT WE MISSED
FORCING BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CRISIS
A CRISIS THAT HAS ONLY BEEN
EXASPERATED BY TWO YEARS PLUS.
OF A GLOBAL PANDEMIC. LAST
DECEMBER I JOINED WITH ASSEMBLY
COLLEAGUES TO DISCUSS THE RECENT
AUDIT OF OUR LPS SYSTEM THERE
WERE A LOT OF GOOD AND
PRODUCTIVE IDEAS THAT CAME OUT
OF THAT HEARING. TWO MAJOR
THINGS. THAT WE TOOK AWAY OR THE
NEED TO KNOW MORE ABOUT OURS OUR
SYSTEM IS WORKING- DESPITE THE
ORDERS FINDING THERE ALSO
APPEARS TO BE A VARIATION FROM
COUNTY TO COUNTY AND HOW
DANGEROUS THIS AND GREAT
DISABILITY ARE INTERPRETED. AND
AGAIN YOU HEARD A COUPLE WEEKS
AGO- THE BILL ADDRESSING THE
LACK OF DATA- THAT THAT THAT
PASSED UNANIMOUSLY THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE. AND NOW THIS BILL
TACKLES THAT AS A PART OF IT
WHEN CARE IS NOT AVAILABLE
PEOPLE ARE OFTEN LOCKED UP. SENT
TO JAIL. LEFT TO LANGUISH AND OR
THEY DIE. WHICH GETS TO THE
POINT OF THIS BILL WE DON'T WANT
MORE PEOPLE TO BE TREATED
INVOLUNTARILY HAVE FLIES IN THE
FACE OF ALL THE OTHER WORK
INVESTMENTS THAT WE'RE DOING.
BUT THE REALITY IS PEOPLE ARE D.
COMPENSATING TO THE POINT WHERE
THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO CARE FOR
THEMSELVES. FIFTY FOUR SIXTEEN
AS PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED. WOULD
ALLOW FOR INVOLUNTARY CARE WITH
ALL OF THE EXISTING DUE PROCESS
PROTECTIONS IF SOMEONE IS SO
MENTALLY ILL THAT THEY CANNOT
PROVIDE FOR THEIR OWN MEDICAL
CARE TO THE POINT THAT THEY ARE
AT RISK OF. SUBSTANTIAL BODILY
HARM. DANGEROUS DANGEROUS
WORSENING OF ANY RELATED SERIOUS
PHYSICAL ILLNESS. OR SIGNIFICANT
PSYCHIATRIC DETERIORATION. WHY
WOULD WE NOT WANT TO PROVIDE
THAT TO PEOPLE IS THE BIGGER
QUESTION. THE OPS SYSTEM HAS
SIGNIFICANT GUARD RAILS AS WELL
AND IS NOT INTENDED AS A TOOL TO
TARGET PEOPLE IN POVERTY THE
WHOLE POINT WAS TO PREVENT THAT
. THE BEDROOMS I CAN QUOTE A
BACKGROUND PAPER- IF YOU'D LIKE
TO IN THE NOTE THAT PEOPLE
UNABLE TO PROVIDE THEIR BASIC
NEEDS AS A RESULT OF MENTAL
ILLNESS OR CHRONIC ALCOHOLISM
THEREFORE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS OR FOOD INSECURITY
DOES NOT MEET ANY. OF THIS
CRITERIA. I KNOW THIS IS A
DIFFICULT ISSUE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT FUNDAMENTAL FREEDOMS IN
OUR COUNTRY BUT WE ARE WALKING A
LINE WITH FREEDOM TO MAKE
DECISIONS WHETHER A PERSON HAS
CAPACITY OR NOT. IS DENYING
PEOPLE THEIR HEALTH THEIR
DIGNITY AND IN SOME CASES THEIR
LIVES. I WANT TO BE CLEAR
INVOLUNTARY TREATMENT HAS SHOULD
ALWAYS BE A LAST RESORT. I DON'T
SEE ANYTHING THIS BILL THAT
BUMPS INAPPROPRIATE INVOLUNTARY
CARE SOONER INTO THE CONTINUUM.
RESHOOT THAT BY HAVE FILLED SOME
PHILOSOPHICAL DISAGREEMENTS WITH
SOME OF THE OPPOSITION ON THIS.
BUT I AGREE WITH A LOT OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THEY HAVE. YES
MORE VOLUNTARY CARE BETTER
OUTCOMES. YES MORE FUNDING AND
MORE HOUSING. YES TO BETTER DATA
AND BETTER COMMUNICATION BETWEEN
SYSTEMS. BUT ALSO YES TO
ENSURING. WHEN WE CAN PROVIDE
CARE AS A LAST RESORT WHEN
SOMEONE'S MENTAL ILLNESS
PREVENTS THEM FROM PROVIDING FOR
THEIR OWN MEDICAL CARE. WITH ME
TODAY TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT IS
SEEN DIEGO MAYOR TODD GLORIA.
AND RANDALL FROM THE PSYCHIATRIC
ASSOCIATION. THANKS VERY MUCH-
SO THIS IS THE ONLY WITNESS AT
THIS POINT TIME. I THINK THERE
DOES TO RENTAL AND IN PARTICULAR
OKAY GLORIA SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AS A MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES SUPPORT
SO WE CAN BEGIN WITH THE
HONORABLE TODD GLORIA MAYOR OF
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO- GOOD
EVENING. AT SEVEN THANK YOU ALL
SO MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY IS
THAT THE COMMITTEE- IT IS GREAT
TO SEE SOME OF YOU ARE
VIRTUALLY- THEY MISS YOU ALL-
I'M HERE EXPRESSED MY STRONG
SUPPORT AS THE MAYOR OF THE CITY
STATE DIEGO AS WELL AS
REPRESENTS A BIG C. MAYORS
COALITION- STRONG SUPPORT FOR
CENTER EXISTS. AT THE FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN RIGHT AFTER. I VOTE THIS
EVENING. BIG CITY MAYORS HAVE
WORK EXCEPT. IN A FIVE. MANNER
ON HOMELESS FUNDING ISSUES FOR
YEARS. AND THIS YEAR WE HAVE
DECIDED TO JOIN CENTER ADMINS
AND SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S LEADING
ASSOCIATIONS REPRESENTING
PSYCHIATRIC CONDITIONS. TO WEIGH
IN IN SUPPORT OF REFORMING
CALIFORNIA'S OUTDATED BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH SYSTEM. WE DID SO BECAUSE
WE SEE IN OUR CITIES WHAT ALL OF
YOU SEE IN YOUR DISTRICTS.
PEOPLE CYCLING TO HOSPITALS
JAILS IN THE STREETS UNABLE TO
ACCESS THE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES THAT THEY NEED AND
DESERVE. IT'S TIME THAT WE FACE
THE PAINFUL BUT OBVIOUS TRUTH.
THEIR BEHAVIOR HEALTH SYSTEM IN
CALIFORNIA IS BROKEN AND WE MUST
FIX IT. LAST YEAR IN THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO OUR PARAMEDICS
FIREFIGHTERS AND POLICE OFFICERS
SPENT NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED
SERVICE HOURS. EACH DAY
RESPONDING TO BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
EMERGENCY CALLS FOR PEOPLE IN
CRISIS. THANK CENTER ADMIN FOR
TAKING ON THIS ISSUE WITH A
NUMBER OF SOLUTIONS TO HELP
MODERNIZE OUR BOOKING BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SYSTEM. LIKE THE SENATOR
I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE
CAN BE A CONTROVERSIAL ISSUE.
AND I PERSONALLY DO NOT TAKE
ISSUE THE CIVIL LIBERTY LIGHTLY
NOR DO ANY OF MY MALE
COLLEAGUES. BUT THIS IS A ISSUE.
MOUNTAIN MORAL IMPORTANCE SAID
LIKE TO LEADERS THE PUBLIC
EXPECTS MORE FROM US. THAN
PUTTING ACTION OFF LEADER AND
LEADING THE STATUS QUO CONTINUE
TO PRODUCE WERE SEEN RESULTS. I
RECOGNIZE THE ISSUE THIS ISSUE
REQUIRES FOR FACILITIES AND
SERVICES IN THE BUDGET TO FUND
THEM. AS WE TACKLE THOSE
CHALLENGES TO. SIXTEEN COMMENTS
IMPROVEMENTS INCLUDED THAT WOULD
MODERNIZE CONSERVE FOR THE MOST
NEED THIS BILL AS YOU KNOW WE
MODERNIZE MEDICAL HIS WILL
MEDICAL TO BE CONSIDERED A
DEGREE SAY DEAF AND OF STANDARD
BY WHICH MOST PEOPLE WOULD AGREE
THERE SHOULD BE A DUTY TO
INTERVENE TO SAVE PEOPLE'S LIVES
THIS MISTER CHAIRMAN AT THE TIME
FOR ACTION ON THIS LONG OVERDUE
ITEMS WE CANNOT AFFORD TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT SO INTO
DOLLARS AT SYSTEM THAT IS NOT
HELPING THE PEOPLE ARE ST I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IDOL AND
SAYS SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN I LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING PEOPLE TO TIME HOW DID
THAT SERVICES THAT THEY NEED. TO
SAVE THEIR OWN LIVES AND WITH
THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER TAX
MISTER HAYES- TO READ BEHAVIOR
THANK YOU SO MUCH GLORIA IT'S
ALWAYS GOOD TO HEAR FROM YOU
AGAIN- THEY'LL THEY'LL BRING UP
OF RANDALL HAGAR- BECAUSE I
THINK HE SAID THE TEAM FOR
DOCTOR CARTER FROM UC DAVIS SO-
RENTAL HAGAR PLEASE SO. HAVE-
MET. RECORDERS OKAY THANK YOU-
PAN MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AM
RANDALL AND I AM IN FOR A
CAMERON THE JURY OF THE NEW
CENTER SEE ALSO THE DIRECTOR FOR
THE PAYROLL CENTER AXLE. FINALLY
COME. RESEARCH ON FROM- RATHER
FOR- THE OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION I'M
MOBY CRISIS EMERGENCY SERVICES.
WHAT DOCTOR CARTER WANTED YOU TO
KNOW TODAY THAT AND WITH
DISORDERS LIKE SCHIZOPHRENIA.
RECRUITING BIPOLAR AND SEVERE
DEPRESSION WHICH CAN ALSO-
PRESENTS WITH PSYCHOTIC FEATURES
THERE IS. DELUSIONS AND
HALLUCINATIONS ARE THE HALLMARKS
OF PSYCHOTIC DISORDERS BUT
THAT'S ALSO THE SERVICES OF THE
FRONTAL LOBE WHICH MEANS THAT
TOGETHER WITH PSYCHOSIS THE
PRECOGS VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM
WITH DECISION MAKERS THAT CAN BE
SERIOUS DETRIMENT. TO THE
PHYSICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH. YOU
KNOW A GOOD EXAMPLE OF THIS IS A
PSYCHOTIC INDIVIDUAL WHO ALSO
USES MATH. ALSO FULLY LEADS TO
WORSENING OF THEIR PSYCHOSIS
THEY GET INVOLVED WITH PHYSICAL
NEGLECT- THERE'S MULTIPLE
PHYSICAL HEALTH PROBLEMS THAT
ARISE CARDIAC INFECTIOUS DISEASE
ARE ALL POTENTIAL HERE- AND
THERE IS A NUMBER OF ISSUE LOOMS
AND THERE ARE IN. PHARMACY
HOSPITALIZATIONS AN AWFUL LOT OF
VERY HIGHRATES THERE AND WE SEE
THESE DAYS THESE INDIVIDUALS
EVERY DAY AT THE UC DAVIS
MEDICAL CENTER. AND THEY'RE IN
THE MOST TERRIBLE PHYSICAL AND
MENTAL CONDITION AND THEY'RE
ALMOST ALWAYS ON HOUSE PRIOR TO
AS WELL AS FOLLOWING
HOSPITALIZATION. AND IT'S THIS
KIND OF. WE BELIEVE- REQUIRED.
SOME OF. AS SOME DEVIATIONS
BUSINESS AS USUAL ON WE THINK
THAT- SB FOURTEEN SIXTEEN IS
THAT SOLUTION AND WE RECOMMENDED
IN YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN SIXTEEN
HEARING ROOM FOR TWELVE HUNDRED
. SEEN ON APPROACHING THE
MICROPHONE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES WHO IS
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN. NAME
ORGANIZATION POSITION. LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
AND ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. THE
TIME WE HAVE TO IN OUR QUEUE.
FIRST GO TO LINE THREE SIXTY.
THANK YOU WITH A MEMBER WHO
BROUGHT UP THE IDEA SACRAMENTO
MAYOR DARRELL STEINBERG. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. NEXT TO NUMBER
THREE FIFTY FIVE. ALLOWED HER
AGAIN THE EVENING WITH THE FIBER
DENSITY. FOR THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. I ONCE AGAIN TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. THIS YEAR AT THE TIME WE HAVE
NO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE ALL RIGHT
THANKS VERY MUCH WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO OUR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN WE HAVE- TWO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION- WILL BEGIN WITH
MASS GALLAGHER TELL BOYCE'S
WHO'S HERE IN PERSON AND THEN WE
FOLLOWING THAT UP WITH THAT
BROUGHT THAT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ON THE PHONE LINES
SO. WELCOME TWO MINUTES MINUTES
TOTAL FOR THE TWO OF YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS
MATTHEW GALLAGHER ON BEHALF
COWBOYS IS IN CAUGHT PART OF THE
COALITION IN OPPOSITION S. B.
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN. ASSEMBLY WE
OPPOSE A BILL FOR THREE REASONS.
THE FIRST REASON IS IT GOES
AGAINST THE INTENT OF THE OPS
ACT THE LPS ACT WAS INTENDED TO
REDUCE. ONGOING OR- WICKS T.
HOSPITALIZATION FOR INDIVIDUALS
AND SB FOURTEEN SIXTEEN AS
DRAFTED. GOES AGAINST THAT IT
VASTLY EXPANDS THE DEFINITION
AND SUBJECTS INDIVIDUALS TO
RISKING THEIR INDIVIDUAL LIBERTY
AND FOR THAT REASON WE OPPOSE IT
. ALSO WHEN WE DO WE OUGHT WE
AGREE WITH THE STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT THE STATE ORDER NOT
RECOMMENDED EXPANDING THE
DEFINITION OF RAPE WE DISABLED.
THAT WAS NOT THE STATE AUDITOR'S
CONCLUSION AND WE AGREE WITH
THAT CONCLUSION THE ISSUE WAS
SERVICES AND- BE WORKING AT.
EMPHASIZE INCREASE SERVICES TO
PREVENT HOSPITALIZATION OR
CONSERVATORSHIP AND THAT WAS THE
STATE AUDITOR'S RECOMMENDATION.
AND LAST WEEK AS A LAWYER WHAT
CONCERNS ME WITH THE PROPOSED
STANDARD THAT'S BEING SUGGESTED
HERE IS AT A DECENT PACE IN OVER
BROUGHT. PROPOSED CONSERVANCY
CONCERT T. READING THE STATUTE
WILL NOT KNOW WHAT CONDUCT IS
PROHIBITED OR ALLOWED. WE
PRESUME A PROPOSED CONSERVANCY
HAS CALM INTELLIGENCE AND
INDIVIDUALS OF COMMON
TELEVISIONS READING THE STATUTE
AS AMENDED WILL BE UNLIKELY TO
UNDERSTAND FOR THOSE REASONS FOR
YOUR URGENT OF THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO. NEXT WITH THIS DEBRA
ROCKS- FROM THIS THERE IS
CALIFORNIA WHO SHOULD BE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LANCE MODERATOR
CAN PLEASE BRING DEBRA FROM
DISABILITY RIGHTS. ON. THANK YOU
DR PAN DEBORAH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA- IN THE TWITTER OVER
FROM THE MONITOR TO THE PHONE I
THOUGHT I HEARD REFERENCE TO
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS AND I DIDN'T
SEE THEM IN THE ANALYSIS THAT
WAS THERE ARE AMENDMENTS WE LOOK
FORWARD TO REVEALING THEM. AND
MY TESTIMONY IS BASED ON WHAT WE
HAD ALREADY SEEN IN THE BILL AND
PRINT- IF YOU EXPAND THE
DEFINITION OF GRAVELY DISABLED-
I'M HERE INCREASING THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE SUBJECT TO INVOLUNTARY
TREATMENT. MAKING IT EASIER TO
CONSERVE PEOPLE WHICH IS COUNTER
TO THE LINEMAN PATRICK SHORT
ACT. WHICH IS SUPPOSED TO END
INAPPROPRIATE INDEFINITE AN
INVOLUNTARY COMMITMENT OF PEOPLE
WITH MENTAL HEALTH. SEVEN THAT'S
NOT PORTED INVOLUNTARY TREATMENT
WORKS. ECSTATIC TO SHOW THAT IT
WORKS- IN OUR LETTER TO THE
COMMITTEE WITHOUT A RECENT STUDY
BY UCLA ON PEOPLE WHO ARE UNDER
HOUSE AT THE TIME OF THAT
VEHICLES. INCLUDED THAT IF THE
DEFINITION OF GRAVELY DISABLED
IS EXPANDED. HOSPITALIZATIONS
WOULD BE LONGER AND THE
INDIVIDUALS WERE MORE LIKELY TO
REMAIN ON HEALTH WHEN THEY'RE
DISCHARGED. WITH A LINE FOR THE
STATE AUDIT REPORT WHICH HARDLY
TALKS YOU CAN EXPAND IN LPS. IF
YOU HAVE TO FILL OUT THE LACK
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND WORKFORCE
TO PROVIDE THE HELP THAT PEOPLE
NEED TO BELIEVE IN UPSTREAM
INTERVENTION GETTING WITH
PERSISTENT. ENGAGEMENT AND
BUILDING TRUST WITHIN THE
VOLUNTARY TREATMENT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU WITHOUT. I
GOT AN ADDITIONAL WITH ARE APPLE
TO ASK FOUR SIXTY HERE ROOM TO
HUNDRED- NAME ORGANIZATION
POSITION. THE COMPANIES LIKE OF
A- FOUR I AM SANDRA I REPRESENT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE
PEOPLE OF THE PUBLIC AND I POST
THIS BILL NOT TO BE CONFUSED
WITH A POST. FOR THE GRATITUDE
THANK YOU. MY NAME IS MIKE FUNKY
FATHERS HALL SO FROM. THE
ORGANIZATION THE STATE'S ONLY
FUNCTION IS TO PROTECT THE
RIGHTS OF THE INDIVIDUAL. THIS
IS A VIOLATION OF RIGHTS. HI
HAVE YOU PULLED OUT SUPPOSED
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. SEE NO ONE ELSE
APPROACHING A MICROPHONE WILL
NOW GO ON TO SEE- TELECONFERENCE
LINE MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE FOR WITNESSES WHO SHOULD
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO SB
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN. ID LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
FOURTEEN SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO. ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. EARLIER FOR IN OUR
QUEUE OKAY WE'LL START WITH
NUMBER THREE FORTY NINE. GOOD
EVENING LINDA WAY WITH WESTERN
CENTER ON LAW AND POVERTY IN
OPPOSITION EXCEL AS IN FRANCE
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
. WINE THREE FIFTY SEVEN.
FISHERMEN MEMBERS ACTUALLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL- PAUL YODER
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION PSYCHIATRIST
DR- THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU-
NEXT WITNESS. ONE THREE FIFTY
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN
MEMBERS EVER SHE'D WITH THE
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA UNFORTUNATELY BUT THE
PUBLIC MUST AMENDED PETITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT S. SIGN
TO NINETY FIVE. MAJOR
INTERMEMBRANE DECISION ON MARCH-
WITH FASTER COUNTY LABORATORY
AND- STILL ACCESS ROFESSIONALS
CAN ALSO REPRESENTING HIM TO
RALLY FOR U. S. SENATE AND I'M
ASKING WHAT WE ARE ASKING YOU
FOR YOU KNOW ON THE SCALE THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
WHAT'S GOING TO BE LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
SECURE A TIME WE HAVE NO ONE
ELSE IN OUR QUEUE OKAY THANKS
VERY MUCH THIS SPRING AFFECTED
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. CASE
SEEING NONE- IT'S BEEN MOVED BY
SIR LEYVA- SIR EDMUND AGAIN
THANK YOU. FOR WORKING WITH OUR
COMMITTEE- I KNOW WE TOOK YOUR
BILL NARROWED A LITTLE BIT- BUT-
I THINK IS REFERRED FROM- GLORIA
AND CERTAINLY OF I'VE HEARD AND
HEARD. THAT ACTUALLY JUST MY
FROM MY OWN THEIR HERE
SACRAMENTO. I MEAN WE- PEOPLE
ARE STRUGGLING AND THAT INCLUDES
PEOPLE WHO ARE STRUGGLING MENTAL
HEALTH AND ON THE STREETS RIGHT
AND- CERTAINLY I AGREE WITH YOU.
AND AS YOU SAID BUT WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN THE LAST SORT- AT
THE SAME TIME I KNOW YOU'RE
GONNA BE WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION STONE ACRE YOU TO
CONTINUE TO DO AS YOU'RE-WORKING ON YOUR PACKAGE OF BILLS
INCLUDING THIS ONE- TO TRY IT
CERTAINLY WE WANT TO HOPEFULLY
BE ABLE TO TREAT EVERYONE
VOLUNTARILY- WE DEFINITELY NEED
TO EXPAND THE SERVICES ALL THE
THINGS THE OPPOSITION SAID I
DON'T DISAGREE WITH IN TERMS OF.
YES WE NEED MORE SERVICE
ETCETERA I KNOW YOU'RE WORKING
ON THAT I SEE YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE AND
TRYING TO GET THOSE RESOURCES
THAT CENTER- SO CERTAINLY I'M
SUPPORTING THE BILL TODAY AS
AMENDED AND AGAIN PREACHY TAKING
AMENDMENT WHICH- BUT- YOU.
INTEREST TIME I WILL JUST SAY
THANK YOU I AGREE WITH A LOT OF
THE OPPOSITION TO AS A STATE YES
WE NEED MORE SERVICES YES
INVOLUNTARY. OR VOLUNTARY IS
BEST- AND WE'RE WE ARE WORKING
ON THAT BUT AS YOU POINTED OUT
SOMETIMES WHEN WE GET TO THAT
END. WE NEED MORE TOOLS TO BE
ABLE TO HELP PEOPLE STAY SAFE- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
OKAY THANK YOU SO THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AMENDED REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY TEN
SECOND I CENTER LEYVA.
CONTROLLED PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. CAN HI CAN HI MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S I EGGMAN BY EGGMAN AYE
GONZALEZ. GROVE HER TADO LEYVA
LEYVA AYE LEE MON ROF BROTH FIVE
RUBIO WIENER.
THAT'S CURRENTLY SIX ZERO- WILL
PUT THE BILL ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS ALL RIGHT- I THINK THE
NEXT ONES ARE MINE SO MANY IN
THE GAVEL OVER TO AT LEAST HERE
. HELLO I'M HERE. YOU NEED THIS.
OKAY AS OUR CHAIRMAN MAKES HIS
WAY TO THE PODIUM- CENTER PAN
HAS THREE ITEMS TODAY THE LAST
THREE ON THE AGENDA AND WE WILL
START WITH S. B. TEN THIRTY
THREE I BELIEVE YES YES EVERY
YEAR READY RIGHT THANK YOU
KAMALA VICE CHAIR AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS- SB TEN THIRTY THREE
REQUIRES COMMERCIAL HEALTH PLANS
ESTABLISH STANDARDS FOR THE
COLLECTION DEMOGRAPHIC AND
HEALTH RELATED SOCIAL NEEDS DATA
FROM CALIFORNIANS ENROLLED IN
COMMERCIAL HEALTH INSURANCE. THE
STATE IMPROVEMENTS STANDARDS
ALLOW FOR STATE LEADERS CONSUMER
ADVOCATES INCREASE STAKEHOLDERS
TO IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS RACIAL
ETHNIC AND GENDER DISPARITIES
IMPROVE QUALITY CARE AND ENABLE
CALIFORNIA TRULY RESOLVE ISSUES
THE IMPACT POPULATION HEALTH
COMMITTEES A COLOR OF
HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED GROUPS
THIS BILL BUILT ON THE PORT WORK
BE. CALIFORNIA'S WELL THE
DEPARTMENT MANAGED HEALTHCARE
THROUGH ITS NEWLY FORMED HEALTH
EQUITY IN QUALITY COMMITTEE.
FIND OUT THAT THIS BILL SETS UP
REQUIREMENTS FOR HEALTH PLANS
COLLECT INFORMATION BUT ALL
PARTIES AND HEALTH SYSTEM FROM
PLANTS PROVIDERS STAFF WILL BE
INVOLVED SHOULD BE INVOLVED IN
THE PROCESS OF COLLECTING
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA IF WE WANT TO
SEE IMPROVE THE DEMOGRAPHIC
COLLECTIONS. ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL DEFIES TRAIN FUNDS THROUGH
FEES AND PENALTY FINES COLLECTED
THAT WOULD SUPPORT PLANS
INSURERS SO THEY CAN TRAIN YOUR
STAFF PART OF THE SUCCESS AND
PLANNING THE CRIME INTO THIS
BILL BE ENSURING THAT THEIR
SUPPORT. PROVIDE THE PLAN SO
THEY CAN MEET THE
RESPONSIBILITIES THAT WERE
ASKING THEM TO TAKE ON
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
NICE TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
HERE SANDERS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK. IS A
SPONSOR OF THE BILL AND JUNE
LAM- WITH- THE AT THE- AT THE
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE LOS ANGELES. THANK YOU.
R. EIGHT THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
WE WILL START WITH- WE'LL START
WITH KERRY WHO SHOULD BE ON THE
COASTLINE YES MISTER MODERATOR
IF YOU CAN PLEASE YEAH HELLO
THERE YOU ARE THANK YOU SO MUCH
GO AHEAD YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES AT
LEAST. RIGHT OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AND IN ITS KERRY SANDERS
AND I'M HERE AT THE CALIFORNIA
PAN ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK HOW TO
BE A SPONSOR OF SB TEN THIRTY
THREE AND I'LL BE BRIEF- OTHER
PROFITABLE AND NEEDING HELP THE
FERRIES AND AN ATHLETE BARTON
HIGH QUALITY DATA. IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE CALIFORNIA PASSED
SB THIRTY THREE WHICH REQUIRED
HEALTH PLANS TO PROVIDE LANGUAGE
ASSISTANCE SERVICES AND COLLECT
DEMOGRAPHIC DATA IN ORDER TO
DRAFT INEQUITIES. HOWEVER TWENTY
YEARS LATER THE COMPLETENESS OF
DATA VERY SUBSTANTIALLY BY
PRODUCT PLANNED FOR COMMERCIAL
COVERAGE LOVES LACKING FAR
BEHIND MEDI CAL MEDICARE. THE
VARIATION IN DATA QUALITY OF
STANDARDS COVER CALIFORNIA'S
ABILITY TO IDENTIFY AND FULL
PLANS ACCOUNTABLE PRODUCING
DISPARITIES IN DIABETES ASTHMA
MENTAL HEALTH. AND WORK
COMMISSION MY COVER CALIFORNIA
PRICEWATERHOUSECOOPERS FOUND
THAT MULTINATIONAL INSURERS DO
NOT HAVE BEEN PLACED ACCESS.
BRIDGES THAT THE FEDERAL BANK
CLINICAL DATA FROM ELECTRONIC
HEALTH RECORDS BELYING. INSTEAD
ON FOR. SAMPLE PROFILE AND THE
BUSINESS. WITH WHICH TO IDENTIFY
THE QUALITY AND I COULD GOAL.
MAKE THE BRIDGE THEM HA TRIED TO
A DRY THE- PARTICULARLY SMALLER
POP SUCH AS ASIA NEIGHBOR WHY
AND PACIFIC ISLANDER I THINK
THIRTY THREE ADDRESS OTHER
CONCERNS IDENTIFIED BY THE BAND
AND AN INDEPENDENT STUDY BY BLUE
SHIELD OF CALIFORNIA I REQUIRED
FOR MARSHALL HEALTH PLANS TO
MEET NATIONAL ACCREDITATION
STANDARDS HEALTHEQUITY. AND
TEMPLATE BEST PRACTICES FOR DATA
COLLECTIONS THE BILL ALSO
REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE IN EIGHTY AYE
THE DALLAS STANDARDIZED
CATEGORIES FOR COLLECTION
REPORTING A DEMOGRAPHIC AND
HEALTH RELATED SOCIAL NEEDS DATA
ANALYSIS THE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM CAN SURE PLAN
CAN PROVIDERS HAVE THE TOOLS TO
IMPROVE THEIR PRACTICES FOR ALL
THESE REASONS IT'S KIND. OF
IMPORTANT ENERGY YOUR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL. I THINK YOU SO
MUCH MISS. AND THEN. WITNESS IN
SUPPORT IS JUNE LAM JIM LAMB ARE
YOU ON THE LINE. YES I'M HERE
ALRIGHT GO AHEAD PLEASE YOU HAVE
TWO MINUTES. BY ENGINE LEMON AND
THE DEMOGRAPHIC RESEARCH PROJECT
DIRECTOR ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE LOS ANGELES.
SOMEONE WHO USES AN ADVOCATE FOR
THE TARGETED DATA ON ASIAN
AMERICAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
COMMUNITY AND HOLD THE CASE IN
PUBLIC HEALTH AND HAPPY TO
CONQUER THIS HEARING TODAY. MY
MOTHER ALWAYS SAID YOU NEED GOOD
DATA FOR RESEARCH AND
DISAGGREGATED DATA BETTER THAN
AGGREGATED YEAH BUT THE EIGHTY
SECOND UNITY WHICH IN CALIFORNIA
GREW BY NEARLY 20% BETWEEN
TWENTY TEN AND TWENTY TWENTY.
AGGREGATED DEMOGRAPHIC DATA
ACTUALLY THE BOTTOM MINORITY AND
IF YOUR AND EVEN EXPRESS.
THEMSELVES BUT WOULD PROVIDE IT
BEGIN VARIATIONS AND THE
ECONOMIC. BEING WITH ABILITY AND
UNIQUE IMMIGRATION AND REFUGEE
HUNGRY. ALL AFFECT BUT PEOPLE
LIVE WORK AND PLAY WHICH IN TURN
AND HELP. IT FOR EXAMPLE AND
CONSIDER HOW IT. AFTERTHE
SEEKING AN ADVOCATE FOR.
ALTHOUGH ONLY ONE THIRD OF ASIAN
AMERICANS ARE LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENT OVER HALF OF
VIETNAMESE AND BURMESE AMERICANS
ARE ANOTHER EXAMPLE ONLY 24%
ASIAN AMERICAN THE CALIFORNIA
ARE LOW INCOME BUT WHEN WE
DISAGGREGATE THE DATA BY
ETHNICITY BOTH. HAVE HIGHER
PROPORTIONS. BOB HOPE. FROM THAT
. WITH MORE THAN SIXTY FIFTH
PERCENT OF MULLIN. FOR L<c.cyan>G.</c>
FOUNDED I SURVEYS AND DATA
COLLECTION METHOD ARE NEXT CLICK
ON THE TV THE OVERSTAFFED OF
GROUPS AND BUSINESS SO THAT
THERE IS DATA FOR MEANINGFUL
ANALYSIS. ESPECIALLY OF THE OUT
OF FEAR OF THE I'M A HERE. AND
THEIR IMPACT ON HEALTH SB TEN
THIRTY THREE PROVIDE THE MEANS
FOR THAT SPEED THAT HE COLLECTED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TIME. SORRY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISLIM NOW WE WILL MOVE TO
SUPPORT HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNTERS ANYONE HERE WANTS TO
COME FORWARD AND SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. NICOLE
ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SO MUCH ANYONE
ELSE HERE IN ROOM FIVE HUNDRED
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. NO
OKAY THEN WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES MISTER MODERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT REMEMBERED HIS NAME
ORGANIZATION. AND POSITION ON
THE BILL ONLY. LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THESE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN ONE
ZERO FOUR SUPPORT. AT THIS TIME
WE CURRENTLY HAVE SEVEN IN OUR
QUEUE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU FIRST
ONE PLACE. LINE THREE FORTY NINE
. THE THING WENT AWAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FIND TO NINETY SEVEN. THE MAIN
REBEKAH GONZALEZ THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
LINE. EIGHTY RUBENSTEIN THE
NATIONAL MULTIPLE SCLEROSIS
SOCIETY IN SUPPORT. PINE. THREE
TWELVE. SAFELY WITH ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE DANCING
JUSTICE ASIAN LAW CAUCUS IN
EIGHT EVENTS IN OF LOS ANGELES
WERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. PINE
THREE SIXTY TWO. ONE THREE SIX
TWO IS GOOD. THE LINE THREE
SIXTY ONE. I AM EDDIE WHO I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF PATIENT
RESOURCES IN SUPPORT OF FIFTEEN
AND THIRTY THREE THANK YOU. FIND
THREE FIFTY. HI GOOD AFTERNOON-
HOLDEN POURING WITHOUT BACKUP
POINT IN SUPPORT. AS A REMINDER
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
ENTER AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO
OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE. ALL RIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'LL NOW MOVE
ON TO OPPOSITION THERE IS NO
REGISTERED OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL SAYS OR ANYONE HERE ROOM
TWELVE HUNDRED WISHES TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THE SP TEN
THIRTY THREE. SPEAK NOW OR
FOREVER HOLD YOUR PEACE NO GOING
ONCE GOING TWICE. YOU YEAH YOU A
GIVER TWO MINUTES OR SINCE
THERE'S NO LEAD OPERATIONS NAME.
THANK YOU DR PEPPER IS REAL AND
I JUST WANNA KNOW I IN THE
DETAILS OF WHAT IS ACTUALLY BE
REGISTERED FOR THE PATIENTS THAT
YOU ARE WELL- I APOLOGIZE SO
THIS ISN'T AN OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE AUTHOR THIS IS
JUST AN OPPORTUNITY EIGHT YOU
KNOW WITH YOUR FOR. I SHOULD SAY
THE CASE THAT YOU'RE OPPOSITION
THE BILL I APOLOGIZE I SHOULD
MEAN THAT CLEAR. OUT SO I DON'T
HAVE AN OPPOSING- PARTY SO.
THERE'S NO BY RIGHT BUT YOU'RE A
VACATION AS TO WHAT EXACTLY IS
GOING INTO THIS MEDICAL
REGISTRY- YOU ARE YOU CERTAINLY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO LOOK UP
THE BILL ONLINE BUT FOR THIS
PART OF THE TESTIMONY WE JUST-
IT'S- IT'S A FRIDAY. THE REGULAR
PEOPLE DON'T USUALLY GET TO
SPEAK THINKING. ONE INVESTMENT
SURE YOU DO GET TO SPEAK YOU
JUST DON'T GET THAT YOU KNOW
ASK- THE QUESTIONS WE MIGHT BE
HERE FOR WEEKS AND WEEKS IF WE
DID THAT BUT THAT'S JUST THE
PROCESS THAT'S IN PLACE SO-
EYEING AND ASSUME YOU WERE IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY M. THE ONE ELSE
TRANSPOSITION TO THE BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD NOW OKAY SO THEN WE
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MISTER MODERATORS GENTLEMAN. I'M
SORRY IT'S PAST. YOUR. ACTUALLY
ANSWER YOUR NAME AND WHO YOU
REPRESENT IN YOUR POSITION ON MY
NAME IS MIKE. AND- WITH THE
FUNKY FATHERS. AND THE SCIENCES
CL OF THE BOX I DON'T SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU SIR- OKAY
ANYONE ELSE. OKAY SO NOW WE WILL
MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES MISTER
MODERATE IF YOU'D OPEN UP FOR
ANYONE WISHING TO- SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TEN THIRTY
THREE PLEASE. LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TEN THIRTY
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. IN
ONE ZERO PROPOSITION. WE DO HAVE
ONE IN OUR QUEUE IT'LL JUST BE A
MOMENT.
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE SIXTY
THREE. HELLO. YES WE CAN HEAR
YOUR MIND HEALTH COMMITTEE-
IT'S- REGISTER OUR SUPPORT OF
PUTTING US SENATOR RICHARD
HANNON PRISON MIGHT LIKELY.
MISTER MODERATOR ARE HERE ANY
OTHER MEMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES
. THERE IS ANOTHER IN OUR QUEUE
WE'LL GO TO LINE OKAY ID FIVE.
CLICK HERE ME. YES MA'AM YES WE
CAN- YOU. GREAT SORRY ABOUT THAT
I AM. BASICALLY I AM I AM JUST
LETTING YOU GUYS KNOW I THINK
THIS MIGHT BE. MA'AM SO IT. GET
THIS PART OF THE TESTIMONY- YOUR
YOU CAN GIVE YOUR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT OR
WHO YOU REPRESENT IN YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL PLEASE. IT
IS. THE PROVISION OF THE MIND MY
POSITION ON THE L. I THINK
THAT'S THE ONLY TO BE. NONE
OTHER THAN ANY MAN NO NO MA'AM
I'M SORRY YOU. YOU COULD SAY
YOUR NAME WHO YOU REPRESENT AND
THAT YOU ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL. YOU STILL THERE. NO THEY LOST
HER. OKAY MISTER MODERATORS OR
ANYONE ELSE ON THE LINE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. OKAY
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO OTHERS
IN OUR QUEUE. OKAY THANK YOU MR
MODERATOR THAT CONCLUDES ALL OF
THE OPPOSITION TESTIMONIES WILL
BRING IT UP HERE TODAY IS FOR
DISCUSSION SENATOR WIENER HAS
MOVED THE BILL IS ANYONE WISH TO
ASK A QUESTION OR SEEN ANYTHING
NOPE. OKAY THE BILL'S BEEN MOVE
MADAM OR CENTER CAN'T WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU THAT'S
WHAT WE ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE
NOW TO MAKE NOTE THAT OF COURSE
ALL OF OUR STATE FEDERAL PRIVACY
LAWS WILL OF COURSE CONTINUE TO
BE IN PLACE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY NOW MADAM SECRETARY
IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND CALLING THE
ROLE PLEASE SHARE. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS PAN
HI CAN I AM. I MULLIN EGGMAN
EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ. GROVE HER
TADO LEYVA LEYVA EILEEN MOANED
LIMON I ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER WIENER AYE. OUR
RATE THAT BILL IS OUT EIGHT TWO
ZERO NEXT ON THE LIST IS AN ARE
WE MISSING OR NOT MISSING ANYONE
RIGHT NOW WE ARE STILL MISSING
SOME RESURFACING- OKAY SO THAT
BILL WILL BE LEFT OPEN- FOR ADD
ON'S WILL MOVE ON TO S. B.
TWELVE NINETY SIX CENTER PAM
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MADAM VICE CHAIR SENATOR SIDE
PRESENT TO YOU SENATE BILL
TWELVE NINETY SIX WHICH WILL
TAKE NECESSARY STEPS TO EMPOWER
CALIFORNIA TO RAPIDLY DETECT AND
RESPOND TO EMERGING VIRAL
THREATS TO IMPROVE OUR VIOLENCE
VIRAL SURVEILLANCE NETWORK S. B.
TWELVE NINETY SIX WILL DIRECT
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH. DEVELOP CALIFORNIA'S
CURRENT VIRUS SURVEILLANCE
CAPABILITIES AFTER. THE PARK.
STAFF IS CENTRAL VIRAL
SURVEILLANCE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
VIRAL SURVEILLANCE LABS ALL OVER
THE STATE TO MONITOR AND RESPOND
VITAL THREATS. AND FINALLY CDPH
REQUIRED TO PUBLISH THE VIRAL
GENETIC SEQUENCE OF ANY NEW
VIRAL THREATS INTENSIFIES. AS
WEBSITE SO THAT SCIENTISTS CAN
MERELY BEGIN TO USE THE VIRUS
SEQUENCES IN THEIR FIGHT
POSSIBLE TREATMENTS. WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AND I HAVE THOUGHT TO WITNESSES
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH CENTER PAN- HERE TO
WITNESSES ARE AMERICAN CRUMPLER.
AND DOCTOR LONGHURST I BELIEVE
AND THEY ARE ON THE PHONE TO MR
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
OPENING UP THE LINES FOR MEGHAN
PLEASE. MAGNETIZED IN. OKAY WHAT
ABOUT DR CHRIS LONGHURST- RIGHT
THERE WELL THE REASON I BY US
AIR HUCKLE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA DOCTOR LONG CHRIS WAS
UNABLE TO- HE WAS BOARDING A
FLIGHT ABOUT FIVE MINUTES AGO-
BUT YOU SEE IS- VERY PROBABLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH- WILL WAIT TO SEE MISTER
MATTER HAVE YOU FOUND MOST
CRUMPLER YET. SHE DIALED IN.
FINALLY THE ECONOMIST
COMPLICATED ONLINE. OKAY GREAT.
THE FIGHT. TO THE- ENEMY OF THE-
USED CARS BECAUSE THIS IS THEIR
FIVE POSSIBLE TREATMENTS. THAT I
SCRIBBLE IT YOU IF YOU WOULDN'T
MIND TURNING DOWN YOUR VOLUME.
VITTI VIDEO DELAY OKAY GO YOU
HAVE JANET MA'AM. MEGAN. YES GO
GO HEAD YOU HAD TWO MINUTES
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU-
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS MEGAN FROM
FULLER I AM A PUBLIC HEALTH
LABORATORY DIRECTOR FOR BOTH
BOARD ARNIE AND LONG BEACH CITY
PUBLIC HEALTH LABORATORIES I AM
HERE REPRESENTING HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC
HEALTH LABORATORIES IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE NINETY SIX.
BUT BOTH THAT WISH THE VIRUS
SURVEILLANCE- BURKE FINALLY
IDENTIFICATION OF A NOVEL BY
RECORD BAY AREA APPLE THIS
IMPOSE OF THE NETWORK OF TWENTY
EIGHT LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH
LABORATORIES AND OUR STATE.
TESTING PERFORMED BY LOCAL
PUBLIC HEALTH FIVE IS THE
CORNERSTONE OF PATHOGEN
SURVEILLANCE WE ARE THE FIRST
LABORATORY FUNDERS THE NEWLY
EMERGING PATHOGENS THAT ARE AN
ESSENTIAL COMPONENT FOR A
SUCCESSFUL VIRAL SURVEILLANCE
PROGRAM IS. THE GOAL OF SB
TWELVE NINETY SIX. OUR
LABORATORY TESTING FIRST
SURVEILLANCE. SUCH AS THE DATE-
BUT NOT FOR VERY AND FOR FAILING
WHOLE GENOME SEQUENCING AND THE
CDPH RESPIRATORY LABORATORY
NETWORK FOR INFLUENZA AND OTHER
RESPIRATORY PATHOGENS. THE
CULMINATING TIME THAT MAKE HAS
HIGHLIGHTED THE CRITICAL NEED TO
BOLSTER THAT THE PAST THE- FIRST
AVAILABLE PROGRAMS ARE PASSIVE
CALIFORNIANS BELIEVE THAT THE
MAILING PROGRAM. THAT IS
PROACTIVE RATHER THAN REACTIVE.
SB TWELVE NINETY SIX
ACCOMPLISHMENT THAT I FIRST
EVALUATING THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE CURRENT CAPACITY IN THE
STATE IN ORDER TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
IMPROVE AND OPTIMIZE FEDERAL
SURVEILLANCE. IN ADDITION IT'S
STILL REQUIRES AN ANALYSIS OF
THE FUNDING NECESSARY FOR
ESTABLISH AND MAINTAIN THE VA FH
WHICH IS CRITICAL TO THE SUCCESS
AND EFFECTIVENESS OF PROVIDING.
ADVICE THANK YOU OUTBREAK
INFECTIOUS DISEASE. WE HAVE FOR
SENATOR AND STAFF WORKING
WITHOUT ON THE IMPORTANT. THAT
WILL ENHANCE OUR BILL TO PROTECT
THE SAID OF CALIFORNIA FROM
FUTURE VIRAL FAT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH I APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO SUPPORT FOR
THIS BILL HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED VAN WISHES TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL PLEASE COME
FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE. NO
OKAY WE WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINES AND MIST- MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND OPENING THE PHONE
LINES FOR THOSE WSHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
TWELVE NINETY SIX. LIKE TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. TWELVE
NINETY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
. IN ONE ZERO FOUR SUPPORT.
ENTER AT THIS TIME WE HAVE KNOWN
IN OUR QUEUE OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISTER MODERATOR WE WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION THERE
IS NO LEAD OPPOSITION THAT IS
REGISTERED- SO WE'LL MOVE TO
THOSE HERE IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL YOU
MAY BECOME FOR THE MICROPHONE
AND GIVE YOUR NAME THE
ORGANIZATION REPRESENT AND-
WHEN. YOU KNOW YOUR POSITION ON
THE BILL I OPPOSE A BILL. RIGHT
HI MIKE HELLO. THREE AGAIN.
SMIKE FORTY FATHERS FATHERS
APPARENTLY YOU GUYS DON'T KNOW
HOW TO ISOLATE A VIRUS WHICH I
FIND INTERESTING BECAUSE WE'RE
COVIDIEN ALL OVER THE PLACE MY
SO I WOULD SAY I DON'T SUPPORT
THIS THANKS AGAIN NICE TO SEE
OUT OF THE BOX OF. PRECIADO THAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION- ARE I'M SORRY
WE'RE STILL IN SUPPORT YOU GOT
HAD ME THERE- NO NO I AM ON
OPPOSITION SORRY OKAY ANYONE
ELSE. YES YOU MAKE AHEAD OKAY.
THE DENIED DNA SEQUENCING. IT'S
VERY DANGEROUS SO YEAH I DON'T
POST FOR IT. OKAY SO OPPOSE WE
HAVE TO OKAY THANK YOU SO MUCH
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO DESPITE OPPOSITION
NOW. OKAY SO- WE'LL GET TO THE
PHONE LINES AND MISTER MIND OR
IF YOU WOULD OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION S. B. TWELVE NINETY
SIX. LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO S. B. TWELVE NINETY SIX THIS
PRESS ONE ZERO. ONE ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION. CURRENTLY WE HAVE
SIX IN OUR QUEUE. SERVICE LINE
THREE SIXTY FIVE. IT MAY. YES WE
CANARIA HI MY NAME IS IRONIC THE
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSED SB
CLUB AND HE SAID THANK YOU. FIND
THREE SIXTY SEVEN. HARIMAU
FASCIST POLITICIANS IN BETTER
HANDS YOU CAN GO FIRST WE WILL
NEVER TAKE YOUR SHOT YOU MAY NOT. FIND TO NINETY FIVE. HELLO YES
WE CAN- YOU. THE FISH REMARKS
FROM PROCTER COUNTY. AND I'M
REPRESENTING AS YOU KNOW TO
BRADLEY THE U. S. SENATE. AND WE
ARE ASKING FOR A VERY STRONG NO
ON THIS BILL. WE DON'T WANT TO
SELL THANK YOU. NINE ONE SEVENTY
NINE. YEAH ME. YES HI MY NAME IS
JEANETTE SELF AND I AM IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. FIND
THREE SIXTY TWO. AFTER THE TONE
OF THE GAME BUT WILLIAMS FIVE
FIFTY RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE
DEAL THANKS. FIND SEVENTY SIX.
HELLO THIS IS SEVEN THIRTY AM AT
OUR COUNTY AND I FIRMLY OPPOSE
ITSELF. FIND TWO OH EIGHT. HELLO. YES SO YOU KNOW YOU WANT IT MY
NAME IS ALMOST ENOUGH TO COOK
COUNTY AND I UP WITH THE SELF.
LINE THREE SIXTY FOUR. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES HI THREE I'VE
BEEN ON THE PLANET SIX DECADES
AND- I STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL. I AM SURE THIS TIME THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE IN OUR QUEUE OKAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER MONTEREY WILL
NOW BRING IT UP HERE TO THE DAYS
FOR DISCUSSION MEMBERS. CENTER
WIENER HAS MOVED THE BILL ISN'T
DUE ANY. THREE MEMBERS WISH TO
COMMENT NOW. OKAY SENATOR
PANFILO YES CENTER EGGMAN. I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR THIS
BILL AND I FIND IT FASCINATING
THE KIND OF VIRAL THINGS THAT
WE'RE FINDING IN BEING A LOOK AT
OUR WASTEWATER AND THINGS LIKE
THAT BEING ABLE TO DETECT AND
TRACK THINGS I THINK IT'S JUST
TAKEN THIS LEAP FORWARD TO BEING
ABLE TO BE- TO REALLY BE ABLE TO
SEE HOW THINGS ARE COMING IN ANY
INVOLVING. WITHOUT ANYWAY I JUST
THINK IT'S FANTASTIC AND THANK
YOU FOR THIS. THANK YOU. OKAY
CENTER PAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ARE STRICTLY S. WHEN I
BOUGHT IT FOR EIGHT THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS ME REFER TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS PAN. AM HI
MELINDA AND I MELINDA'S I
EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ.
THEMSELVES I GREW. FURTADO LEYVA
LEYVA IDLY MON. LIMON AYE ROTH.
ROTH FIVE RUBIO. RUBIO AYE
WIENER WIENER AYE. HELLO HELLO.
THE BILL WHICHEVER GROVE. WHAT
IS THAT CORRECT OKAY SO NINE
ZERO OKAY CLOSE ROOM OKAY THE
BILLS OUT NINE ZERO- THE FINAL
BILL AT THE DAY CENTER PAN S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE PLEASE
YOU MADAM VICE CHAIR- SENATORS-
SB THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE- CALLS
FOR COLLECTION OF DATA ABOUT
HOSPITAL'S SWITCH- MAY NOT
MESSAGE THAT ARE STILL PENDING
TO MEET THE TWENTY THIRTY
SEISMIC DEADLINES ACCORDING TO
MOST RECENT DATA THEY'RE STILL
SIX HUNDRED FIFTY BUILDINGS
SPREAD OUT ACROSS TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY ONE LICENSE HOSPITALS. TO
EITHER NEED TO BE TAKEN OUT OF
THE QUEUE CARE SERVICE ARE
REPLACED A RETROFITTED TO MEET
THE TWENTY THIRTY REQUIREMENTS
THAT'S WHAT WE KNOW WHAT WE
DON'T KNOW IS EXACTLY WHAT
SERVICES ARE PROVIDED THESE
BUILDINGS ARE HOW MUCH IT'LL
COST TO BRING THEM INTO
COMPLIANCE- CALIFORNIA.
ASSOCIATION COMMISSION DURANT
REPORT A COUPLE YEARS AGO TO
ESTIMATE THE COST OF TWENTY
THIRTY COMPLIANCE. EVEN THAT
REPORT WAS A TOTAL FIGURE FOR
ALL HOSPITALS. SO I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THIS INFORMATION AS THE
DEADLINE APPROACHES. HELPFULLY
GABRIELLE THE COP RESOLUTION SO
THAT- WE DO NOT HAVE HOSPITAL'S
CLOSING AND- SO THAT WE CAN ACT
IN A POLICY WAY. TO IT THE TO
ENSURE THAT- PEOPLE STILL HAVE
ACCESS TO SAFE HOSPITALS. BOTH
PATIENTS AND HOSPITAL WORKERS
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
VOTE. OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THAT AND THERE IS NO
REGISTERED SUPPORT. FOR THIS
BILL SO WE WILL GO TO THOSE HERE
IN ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED WHO WISH
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT BILL PLEASE
GO AHEAD. KATH NOT SINCE GOT A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
WE ARE SUPPORT IF AMENDED WE
SUPPORT THE PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL TO UNDERSTAND THE DATA SET
RELATED TO THE SERVICES IN OUR
BUILDINGS PARTICULARLY THOSE
AFFECTED. BY THE TWENTY THIRTY
REQUIREMENTS HOSPITALS HAVE
SPENT BILLIONS TO MEET THE LAST
REQUIREMENT WHICH IS TO MAKE
SURETHAT THOSE BUILDINGS REMAIN
STANDING POST EARTHQUAKE. WE
WOULD LIKE TO REFOCUS THE NEXT
REQUIREMENT- THAT REMOTE
REQUIRES OUR HOSPITALS TO BE
FULLY OPERATIONAL ON THOSE
SERVICES RELATED TO POST
PANDEMIC REQUIREMENTS. REALLY
THINKING ABOUT POST EMERGENCY
SERVICES- AND AS EMERGENCY
SERVICES NEEDED IN EIGHT OR
AFTER A DISASTER SO WE ARE
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL BUT LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING ON. MEETING
AND ARE WORKING TOWARD THAT
TWENTY THIRTY REQUIREMENT TO
MAKE SURE HOSPITALS REMAIN OPEN-
AS WE FACE THAT HUNDRED BILLION
DOLLAR PRICE TAG THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ANYONE ELSE
HERE IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL. COME FORWARD. SHE WAS AND I JUST. RIGHT SHE
WAS NOT A FEW YOU WANT TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL. SO THE
RULES ARE- THERE ARE TWO
WITNESSES TO GET TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF EACH BILL INTO
WITNESSES YOU GET TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION EACH WITNESS GETS TWO
MINUTES TYPICALLY- PEOPLE
REGISTER AHEAD OF TIME YOU KNOW
AND SO WE HAVE IDENTIFIED THE TO
THE FOR PEOPLE TO ACTUALLY WHO
WILL SPEAK. RIGHT SHE WASN'T
STEP. YOU'RE RIGHT IN THE NO NO
THE DIFFERENT I KNOW WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT BECAUSE THEY'RE
IT'S CONFUSING FOR PEOPLE OF
VERY WHAT I WANTED TO EXPLAIN
WAS- SO YOU KNOW SHE DIDN'T ASK
YOU KNOW ANY QUESTIONS OF THE
AUTHOR IT'S NOT A IT'S NOT A
DIALOGUE THAT'S- IF SOMEONE
COULD TAKE PLACE CERTAINLY
BEFORE THE HEARING. BUT IT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT TAKE. PLACE
DURING HEARING. OKAY THANK YOU-
OKAY IS THERE ANYONE ELSE HERE
IN THE ROOM AND WISHES TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. NOW
OKAY SO WE'LL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES WAS MODERATOR IS ANYONE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE
THIS PRESS ONE ZERO. IN ONE ZERO
FOUR SUPPORT. YOU HAVE ONE OR
TWO IT'LL BE JUST A MOMENT OKAY.
WE'LL GO TO LINE THREE SEVENTY
THREE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHO GO
AHEAD WE CAN. I DON'T KNOW WHOSE
TURN IT IS TO GO AHEAD IT'S YOUR
TURN. BUT. THIS IS FOR SB
THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE. BUT THEY
TOLD ME TO WAIT FOR YOU GUYS GOT
FOUR THREE SEVENTY THREE. YES
IT'S YOUR TURN SIR. HELLO WE
WILL TALK ABOUT YOU GUYS FILLING
THE BABIES AGAIN. RON COMMITTEE
SIR YEAH. ON HEARING THIS IS ON
A HOSPITABLE APOLOGIZE. OKAY
LINE- THREE TWENTY FOUR THREE
TWENTY FOUR. THREE BILLION MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS COUNTY DELGADO
ON BEHALF TO DISTRICT HOSPITAL
LEADERSHIP FORM WHAT THE BORDER
LEFT MY DISPOSITION WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATION ON THE FISH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH ANYONE AT
THE MODERATOR. AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE ARGUE. GREAT
THANK YOU SO MUCH NOW WE WILL
NEED TO OPPOSITION THERE IS NO
LEAD OPPOSITION OR NO REGISTERED
LEAD OPPOSITION SO WE WILL MOVE
IT TO THIS ROOM TWELVE HUNDRED
THOSE WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
COME FORWARD TO THE MICROPHONE-
YOUR NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND YOUR POSITION ON THE BILL
YES SIR. MELISSA YES. SENATOR DR
RICHARD PAN. COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MEMBERS OF THE STAFF. IT IS AN
HONOR TO SERVE. A FEW ON THIS
GLORIOUS DAY. IN RECENT TIME I
HAVE BEEN ASKED BY THE SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENT. SWAT TEAM TO
REPRESENT THEM. TO SHOW MY HONOR
. FOR CHIEF JUSTICE. I NOW WOULD
LIKE TO HONOR. CHAIRMAN DR
RICHARD PAN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SIR FOR VACATING SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN SIXTY FOUR I NOW HAVE.
PHYSICAL FORENSIC EVIDENCE IN MY
HAND THAT A CRIME HAS BEEN
COMMITTED IF THAT BILL IS TO
MOVE FORWARD. CRIMINAL CHARGES
WILL SHARE IDEAS I HAVE AT THIS
YEAR RELEVANCE UP SIR. I WOULD
LIKE TO. YEAH BUT THIS IS NOT
RELEVANT. YES TO SPEAK. TO EVEN
IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK ON THIS
BILL SERVES AS BE THIRTEEN
THIRTY NINE JOHNNY JUST MY NAME
AND- OKAY GO AHEAD SIR. MY NAME
IS FULL COLON NEUTRAL HYPHEN
CLAIMANT. HYPHEN STATE HYPHEN
WITNESS HYPHEN FEDERAL HYPHEN
WITNESS. HYPHEN POSTMASTER
HYPHEN FEDERAL HYPHEN JUDGE. IN
OPPOSITION ICE OKAY THANK YOU
SIR. OKAY THANK YOU- IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE ROOM
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL NOW OKAY SO WE'LL MOVE
IT TO THE PHONE LINES MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND
OPEN UP PHONE LINES FOR THOSE IN
OPPOSITION S. B. THIRTEEN THIRTY
NINE. LIKE THE SPEAKING UP.
THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE THIS PRESS
FUNDS NERO. IN ONE ZERO
PROPOSITION. CRYSTALLINE ONE
SEVENTY NINE. HI MY NAME IS
DENNIS I WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE
THE BILL. NINE THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT. HI I WOULD LIKE BOTH THE
L. FIND. THREE EIGHTY TWO. HI MY
INTERNET HEALTH THE RICHARD
CAPITAL. A WITNESS IN OPPOSITION
COULD I REQUEST TO BE NOT
WITNESSED ABOUT SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY NINE HOSPITAL ACROSS THE
PHYSICALLY THERE'S WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION AND THEN YOU KNOW
YOU'RE INTERESTED IN FOLLOWING
PROCESS AND THAT AND THEN WE CAN
AT A MINUTE MA'AM ARE YOU IN
OPPOSITION S. B. THIRTEEN B.
NINE. WELL I'D LIKE TO FOLLOW
YOUR PROCESS WHICH WOULD BE
ALLOW SOMEBODY IN THE PUBLIC TO
OPPOSE THE BILL AND GIVE
TESTIMONY AS OPPOSED TO JUST
GIVE THEM THEIR NAME RIGHT IN
THE PROCESS WHEN PEOPLE ARE
INTERESTED IN PARTICIPATING.
THIS REPRESENTATIVE GOVERNMENT
AFTER ALL IT IS AN AND I MEAN
CERTAINLY YOU COULD AFFORD
SOMEONE IN THE COMMUNITY TWO
MINUTES HELLO TO ME. BECAUSE
THIS I A DISTRACTION YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUTPAUL MANAFORT
FACILITIES MA'AM WHEN YOU'RE
POISONING THE CHILDREN WITH.
OKAY AND THE PARENTS NO NOI
KNOW I'M TRYING TO ASK PRODUCES
A LITTLE BIT LIKE SMOKING NEAR
IT WILL DISTRACT SENATE PUT THE
SUPERMAJORITY DOES. A LOT OF
SUPPORT MA'AM IF I CAN INTERRUPT
YOU FOR ONE MOMENT IF YOU'RE
STILL THERE IF YOU CAN HEAR ME-
YOU HAVE NOW SPOKEN ALREADY FOR
FORTY FIVE SECONDS IF YOU WANT
TO SPEAK FOR ANOTHER MINUTE AND
FIFTEEN IN OPPOSITION. TO S. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY NINE THE HOUSE
WE ROLLED INTO THE BILL BUT I
THINK SHE'S ALREADY OUT OF THE
QUEUE. WE WILL NEVER TAKE THE
SHOT. SO MAYBE INSTEAD OF
THINKING ABOUT OKAY MA'AM THIS
IS NOT ABOUT A VACCINE BILL.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT VACCINE BILL
MAN- MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND MOVING ON TO THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE AND I WOULD-
YES GO AHEAD. LINES TO NINETY
FIVE IS GO AHEAD. AB CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE SURE CAN. GREAT ONCE
AGAIN THE STREET A LOT AND- I'M
CALLING BECAUSE I REPRESENT
GENESEE BROWN NEWS IS RUNNING
FOR U. S. SENATE. WE ARE IN THE
WRONG OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
AND YOU WILL BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE
FOR FRIENDS IF YOU MANAGE TO
KEEP PEOPLE INFORMED THANK YOU
MA'AM. MY YOUR MIND THE NAME AN
ORGANIZATION YEAH YES THANK YOU
SO MISTER MODERATORS OR ANYONE
ELSE IN THE QUEUE. CURRENTLY OF
TWO OTHERS IN OUR QUEUE OKAY SO
I JUST WANT TO REMIND EVERYONE
IN THE QUEUE AT THIS POINT IN
THE PROCESS WE ARE ASKING FOR
YOUR NAME THE ORGANIZATION YOU
REPRESENT AND- YOUR STATEMENT
THAT YOU OPPOSE THIS BILL. NINE
THREE SEVENTY TWO. HI THIS IS
GABRIELLE IN GRAHAM FOUNDER OF
AND THAT SACRAMENTO COUNTY WE
OPPOSE THE CELL. NINE THREE
EIGHTY. HI THIS IS A FISH
BALLOTS FOUNDER MOMS ON THE
GROUND IN THE ADAMANTLY OPPOSED
TO THE. ONE THREE SIXTY TWO. ONE
THOUSAND EIGHT OPEN FIELD THANK
YOU. NINE THREE SEVENTY FIVE.
HELLO THIS IS JENNIFER CORNER
GRANT OPPOSE THIS BILL. FIND
THREE SIXTY NINE. HELLO CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES WE CAN- YOU. I
PROBABLY CALL VERY CLOSE THE
BILL. NINE THREE SEVENTY SEVEN.
THREE SEVENTY SEVEN ZERO. HOW
MANY BENEFITS RISING WITH AN
EMERGING- COUNTY ONLY OPPOSE THE
SELF THANK YOU. NINE THREE
SEVENTY NINE. THREE SEVENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM SURE AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO OTHERS IN
OUR QUEUE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
MR MODERATOR WILL BRING IT BACK
UP HERE THE DAY IS FOR
DISCUSSION MEMBERS ANYTHING
SOONER WE NUMBERS BILL ANY
DISCUSSION NOW. OKAY CENTER
PARENTS LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU-
SO AGAIN SB THIRTEEN THIRTY
NINE- FOR THOSE WHO ACTUALLY
READ THE BILL. THIS PROVIDES A
VERY IMPORTANT DATA FOR US TO
MAKE POLICY DECISIONS TO ENSURE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO EVER
HOSPITALS OPEN. AND AGAIN I LOOK
THINK IS A GOOD OPPORTUNITY
SPARKING CONVERSATIONS ALL
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING OUR LABOR
PARTNERS ON THE LOOMING TWENTY
THIRTY SEISMIC DEADLINE TO LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO HAVE
THE STYLE AUTHOR STRICTLY ASPEN
I THOUGHT. OUR EIGHT THINKCENTRE
PAN- WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS IN RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
PAN ALL RIGHT PAN HI MELINDA'S.
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE GONZALEZ
GONZALEZ HI A GROVE HER TADO
LEYVA LEVI LEE MON. LIMON I ROTH
RUBIO. RUBIO I WINNER WINNER I.
IT'S. R. EIGHT THAT BILL IS OUT
SEVEN OH BUT I THINK WE'RE GONNA
HOLD IT OPEN AND- THAT'S IT SO
THE SENATE CAN ONE OTHER CLOSER
OUT. THANK YOU AGAIN ADVICE FOR
PIZZA. YOU THANKS RIGHT TO THE
FINAL ITEM BEFORE YOU LIFT CALLS
ACTUALLY USER CONSENT CALENDAR
WE HAVE THREE ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- I NUMBER TWO
SB EIGHT FORTY TWO BUT CENTER
DODD WHICH IS- THAT WOULD BE A
PATH AS AMENDED- ALSO. HAVE-
SORRY. SO WE HAVE- ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE S. B. TWELVE NINETY
EIGHTH PLACE CENTER IT'S CHAU
BOCA WHICH WOULD ALSO BE TO PASS
AS AMENDED- TO THE PROBES AND
THEN FINALLY SB. FOURTEEN SIXTY
TWO BY CENTER BRADFORD WHICH IS
ALSO DUE PASSAGE MENDED AND-
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS- IS OUR
MOTION CONSENT CALENDAR. TO MOVE
AYE SIR LEYVA- CONSOLE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR PAN HI CAN I AM
MELINDA'S MELINDA'S RIGHT EGGMAN
EGGMAN AYE AGAIN SALAS GONZALEZ
I GREW. FURTADO LEYVA LEYVA I.
LIMON LIMON ACROSS. RUBIO RUBIO
AYE WIENER WIENER HI OKAY SO
IT'S CURRENTLY EIGHT ZERO WILL
HOLD TO THE LINE CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS RIGHT SO WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND BEGIN AT THE MOST
POPULOUS HERE OKAY WE'RE GONNA
START WITH ITEM NUMBER THREE SB
EIGHT FIFTY THREE BY CENTER
WIENER- CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ABSENT. MEMBERS
GONZALEZ HI GONZALEZ BY HER TADO
LEYVA LEYVA BY ROSS ALL RIGHT
ROTH. AYE RUBIO RUBIO HI. YEAH
ABOUT. THE ROLE OF BOOKS I THINK
YES I HAVE DIFFERENT COUNTY-
THAT'S REASONABLE OKAY SO WE'RE
ONLY A WRIST SENDERS- TO BE SURE
WE HAVE AN ACCURATE COUNT
APOLOGIZE SO AGAIN WE'RE GONNA
REPEAT TO VOTE. ON ITEM NUMBER
THREE SB. EIGHT FIFTY THREE THAT
RATIO I CENTER WIENER. STE
CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
OF THE ABSENT MEMBERS. HER TADO
LEYVA LEYVA BY RUBIO RUBIO BY.
THIS YEAH. OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT
TEN ZERO WAS ABOUT COMING HERE
YEAH SO SHE DOESN'T HAVE ENOUGH
YEAH UNDERSTAND THAT THE RULES.
RIGHT OKAY NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB EIGHT FIFTY EIGHT
BY CENTER WIENER. A CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MELENDEZ MELINDA'S NO
GROVE HER TADO LEYVA LEAVE AT
FIVE RUBIO RUBIO HI. EIGHT ONE.
OKAY. SEVEN SIX THAT BILLS L.
TWO EIGHT ONE. OKAY NEXT ITEM IS
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB NINE TWELVE
BY SALAMONE CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS HER
TADO LEYVA. NAY BUT BY. OKAY
THAT BILLS OUT TEN ZERO SIX
ITEMS ITEM NUMBER SIX- BY SURREY
CONSULT AT THAT SPEED START ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB NINE SEVENTY TWO
BY SARAH GONZALEZ TOLD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ABSENT MEMBERS
MELENDEZ MULLIN NO FURTADO LEYVA
LEYVA HI ROTH. RIGHT ROTH AYE
RUBIO RUBIO HI. AND ONE FORGET.
THAT BILL IS OUT NINE ONE. NEXT
ITEM IS- ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S. B.
NINE SEVEN FOUR NINE SEVENTY
FOUR BUCKS- CENTER PORTANTINO.
CONSOLE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS MELINDA'S. WROTE
HI MELENDEZ HI OKAY GROF HER
TADO LEYVA LEYVA AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE WIENER WIENER BY. OKAY
THAT BILL IS OUT NINE ZERO SIX
TIMES I AND NUMBER EIGHT S. B.
NINE EIGHTY SEVEN BY CENTER
PORTANTINO CONTROLLED PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL THAT'S MEMBERS.
MELENDEZ. GROVE HER TADO LEYVA
LEYVA BY ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO
RUBIO AYE WIENER WIENER AYE.
ZERO THAT BILLS FELT EIGHT ZERO.
SIX ITEM IS ITEM NUMBER NINE SB
NINE NINE NINE BY SARAH CORTESE
CONSOLE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF
ABSENT MEMBERS. MELENDEZ
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I A GROVE WE
MOAN HI LIMÓN HI RUBIO RUBIO AYE
WIENER WIENER AYE. IF YOU KNOW
IF I KNOW THE DIFFERENCE OKAY.
SO IT'S ON FIFTY. OKAY THAT BILL
IS OUT NINE ZERO SIX TIMES I AND
NUMBER TEN SB TEN FOURTEEN BY
SENATOR HERTZBERG. CONSULT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS PAN HI CAN I EGGMAN.
GROVE HER TADO LEYVA RIGHT LEYVA
AYE ROTH ROTH AYE RUBIO RUBIO
AYE WIENER WIENER I. SEVEN SEVEN
ONE SEVEN ONE OKAY THAT BILLS
OUT SEVEN ONE. NEXT ITEM IS ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN SB FOURTEEN
SIXTEEN BY CENTER EGGMAN ITS OWN
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL OF ABSENT
MEMBERS AND SALAS AND SALAS- A
GROVE FURTADO THE MOON. THE MOON
HI RUBIO HI RUBIO HI. NINE
THANKS THAT BILLS OUT NINE ZERO
SIX ITEM IS S. B. TEN TEN THIRTY
THREE BY CENTER PAN- CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ABSENT
MEMBERS GONZALEZ GONZALEZ ON A
GROW FURTADO. OKAY THAT BILL IS
OUT NINE ZERO. TWELVE NINETY SIX
IS READY OUTRAGE OKAY AND IN
SEVEN- OKAY SO- NEXT ITEMS I'M
NUMBER SEVENTEEN S. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTY NINE BY CENTER PAN
CONSOLE PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ABSENT MEMBERS MELINDA'S GROVE
HER TADO ROTH. ROTH I. CAPITAL'S
AL TO EIGHT ZERO OKAY THAT
EVERYTHING. FIFTY FIVE. OKAY
RIGHT NOW THAT'S GO TO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR- THE CONSOLE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS GROVE HER TADO ROTH ROTH
AYE OKAY WE CONSENT CALENDARS
OUT NINE ZERO. OKAY SO THAT
CONCLUDES THE AGENDA FOR THIS
HEARING OF THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON HEALTH THEY WANT TO THANK ALL
THE STAFF. WHO PUT THAT ISIS THE
UC SERGEANTS HAVE MAINTAINED TO
KEEP THINGS MOVING SMOOTHLY AND
OF COURSE ARE A TELECONFERENCE
LINE FOLKS AS WELL IF ANYONE
WISHES TO ACTUALLY REGISTER.
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY ON ANY THE
BILL'S PLEASE SUBMIT THAT TO OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE- SO IF YOU
WANT TO MAKE ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
THAT YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO MAKE AT
THE HEARING PLEASE DO SO. AND
WITH THAT THIS HEARING OF THE
SENATE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
HEALTH IS THAT CHURNED THANK YOU.